>> WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW.
>> THE CACTUS!
>> THE METS AND DIAMONDBACKS,
YOU GET TO SEE THAT COMING UP IN
A HALF-HOUR.
MADISON BUMGARNER ON THE HILL
AGAINST DAVID PETERSON.
THIS WILL BE THE RUBBER MATCH.
THE METS IN FIRST PLACE IN THE
NL EAST, EVEN WITH A HUGE AMOUNT
OF INJURIES.
BRIAN KENNY AND SEAN CASEY.
LOU GEHRIG DAY, THE FIRST MLB IS
DOING THIS OFFICIALLY HONORING
ONE OF THE ALL-TIME GREAT MEN OF
BASEBALL.
PINS FOR ALS AWARENESS HAS WELL.
WE WILL TALK TO PETE ALONSO.
HE IS BACK IN.
HE WAS IN THE GAME LAST NIGHT.
EVERYTHING GOES 10 INNINGS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WITH THE TYING RUN AT THIRD,
JOSH ROJAS, WHO HAVE THE DUSTUP
WITH MARCUS STROMAN AT THE END
OF THE FIFTH INNING.
>> BASE HIT!
WE ARE TIED.
>> HE HAD SOME WORDS.
HE GETS TO SHOUT AT THE TOP OF
HIS LUNGS HERE.
>> FAIR BALL!
INTO THE CORNER!
>> HERE COMES ESCOBAR!
HERE COMES SMITH!
DIAMONDBACKS WILL WIN THE
BALLGAME!
DIAMONDBACKS GET THE WALKOFF
WIN.
BRIAN: JOSH REDDICK WITH A
DOUBLE IN THE 10TH.
ARIZONA TAKES IT.
THE METS -- MOST OF THE
DIVISIONS ARE CLOSE.
THE METS, THAT IS A HEALTHY LEAD
FOR NOW.
3.5 GAME LEAD.
THE NATIONALS, SEVEN GAMES UNDER
500.
THE METS HAVE BEEN AMAZING.
THEY HAVE SO MANY INJURIES.
THEY HAVE SOMEHOW BEEN ABLE TO
STAY ON TOP.
JONATHAN WILL LEAD FOR THE METS
TONIGHT, FRANCISCO LINDOR
BATTING SECOND.
ALONZO.
DOMINIC SMITH IN LEFT.
BRANDON DRURY AND RIGHT.
JOSÉ PERAZA AND DAVID PETERSON.
YOU SEE SOME FAMILIAR
NAMES.
SO MANY INJURIES.
HOW HAVE THEY BEEN ABLE TO STAY
IN FIRST?
SEAN: IT IS AMAZING TO LOOK AND
SEE WHAT HAS HAPPENED.
ALL THE GUYS ON THE DL, IT IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
WHEN WE START TOP TO BOTTOM,
MCNEIL OUT THE GATES.
RUNNING DOWN TO FIRST, BLOWS OUT
THE HAMMY.
NEVER GREAT.
THERE IS A HUGE BAT AT THE TOP
OF THE ORDER.
BAM, HE BLOWS A HAMMY OUT, AT
THE SAME TIME, TWO BIG COGS IN
THE WHEEL GO OUT.
HERE, HIS LAST FIVE GAMES HAVE
BEEN BETTER BUT STILL UNDER 200.
JAMES MCCANN, THE OTHER BIG
SIGNING THIS OFF-SEASON FOR THE
METS, HE SCUFFLED AT THE PLATE.
THEY HAD TO HAVE GUYS STEP UP.
JONATHAN VILLAR HAS BEEN
AWESOME, DOING ALL THE LITTLE
THINGS RIGHT, STEALING BASES,
GETTING BIG HITS.
HIGH BASEBALL I.Q..
HE HAS BROUGHT A LOT OF ENERGY
TO THE TEAM.
TOMAS HAS REALLY STEPPED IN.
WITH MCCANN STRUGGLING, HE HAS
GOTTEN TIME BEHIND THE DISH,
STEPPED UP BEHIND THE PLATE,
OFFENSIVELY AND DEFENSIVELY,
THROWING GUYS OUT, BRINGING
ENERGY.
KEVIN PILLAR HAS BEEN GREAT.
HE GOT THAT.
THIS IS WHAT HE IS KNOWN FOR.
CENTER FIELD, COVERS THOSE GAPS.
WHEN HE TOOK THIS SHOT AGAINST
THE BRAVES A FEW WEEKS AGO,
RIGHT IN THE NOSE.
BAM, HE IS BACK.
THOSE GUYS ARE EXCITED.
THAT BRINGS A LOT OF ENERGY BACK
TO THE METS.
LOOK AT THE ROTATION.
SYNDERGAARD HASN'T PITCHED THE
SEASON.
STILL BANGED UP.
CARRASCO FROM THE INDIANS HASN'T
PITCHED EITHER.
THEY HAVE COUNTED ON STROMAN.
HE HAS BEEN A GUY THAT DID NOT
PLAY LAST SEASON BUT HAS STEPPED
UP THE SEASON BIG-TIME.
THIS GUY HAS BEEN GREAT.
A RESURGENCE OF HIS CAREER.
KEPT THE METS WHERE THEY NEED TO
BE.
YOU LOOK AT THESE GUYS.
THEY HAVE BEEN A HUGE REASON WHY
THE METS ARE STILL IN FIRST
PLACE IN THE EAST.
BRIAN: IF YOU TOLD ME ALL THOSE
THINGS WERE HAPPENING, THE
INJURIES, THEY HAVE NOT HAVE
THEIR FULL SQUAD, EVEN KNOWING
THEY HAVE JACOB DEGROM PITCHING,
FRANCISCO LINDOR IS HITTING .198
AND HAS STRUGGLED AT SHORTSTOP,
THERE ARE SEVEN GAMES OUT.
THE REST OF THE DIVISION HAS
SHRUNK BACK.
I THOUGHT THE BRAVES WOULD BE A
SUPERTEAM THIS YEAR.
SEAN: THEY HAVE SCUFFLED ALONG.
THE PHILLIES THINK THEY WILL GET
GOING BUT THEY NEVER DO.
THE NATIONALS.
I THOUGHT THEY WOULD BE SO MUCH
BETTER.
THEY ARE AT THE BOTTOM.
THE EAST IS ANYBODY'S FOR THE
TAKING.
THE METS ARE IN GREAT SHAPE.
THEY WEATHERED THE STORM.
THEY WILL GET HEALTHY.
LINDOR WILL GET GOING.
BRIAN: I WATCHED A BUNCH OF
GAMES START TO FINISH.
KEVIN PILLAR AND JONATHAN VILLAR
HAVE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL FOR A
TEAM THAT IS GOING TO HIT.
WHEN YOU HAVE GUYS THAT CAN
FIELD AND RUN, IT BRINGS A
DYNAMIC ENERGY.
SEAN: YOU NEED GUYS LIKE KEVIN
PILLAR, THE WAY HE PLAYS, THE
WAY HE CAN GET THEM AT CENTER.
JONATHAN VILLAR TAKING THAT
EXTRA BASE.
STEALS A LOT OF BASES.
YOU NEED THOSE GUYS.
BRIAN: WHEN YOU SEE THEM, YOU
FIGURE, THAT IS ONE OF THE BEST
BASE RUNNERS IN THE GAME, YES HE
IS, YEAR AFTER YEAR.
WE ARE ASKING YOU WHO WILL WIN
TODAY'S GAME.
THE METS OF THE DIAMONDBACKS --
THE METS OR THE DIAMONDBACKS.
LET US KNOW WHAT YOU THINK.
MADISON BUMGARNER HAS BEEN
GREAT.
HE HAS GOTTEN ROUGHED UP.
E.R.A. OVER EIGHT IN THE LAST
THREE STARTS.
HE HAS STRUGGLED.
5.15 E.R.A. THIS SEASON SO FAR.
WHO WILL WIN?
HERE'S WHAT IS COMING UP CLOSER
TO GAMETIME OVER THE NEXT
HALF-HOUR.
WE WILL RETURN BACK HERE, GET
USED TO IT, GET READY FOR THE
METS AND THE DIAMONDBACKS.
>> OH HANG ONTO THE ROOF!
>> THIS ONE IS OUTTA HERE!
>> LOOKING TO TAG ONE ON.
ESCOBAR.
THAT IS FOUR IN A ROW FOR
EDUARDO ESCOBAR!
6-0!
POWER!
>> CONGRATULATIONS, I AM PROUD
OF YOU.
>> HE SMACKS ONE IN THE AIR TO
DEEP LEFT CENTER.
BACK TO THE WARNING TRACK, AT
THE WALL, IT IS OUT OF HERE!
THE METS TAKE THE LEAD IN THE
NINTH.
TOMAS NIDO, HOME RUN.
THE METS MAKE IT 4-3.
GROUNDS DOWN TO FIRST, THE
SLIDE, SAVE!
HE DOES IT AGAIN.
THE METS RALLY FOR TWO IN THE
BOTTOM OF THE NINTH AND THEY
BEAT THE ORIOLES 3-2.
ANNOUNCER: THE STARTING LINEUP
FOR YOUR ARIZONA DIAMONDBACKS.
BRIAN: WELCOME BACK EVERYONE.
MLB GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME
SHOW PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
TAKE A LOOK.
METS HISTORY.
AT ONE POINT ED KRANEPOOL OWNED.
DARRYL STRAWBERRY, 380 GAMES.
PETE ALONSO, SHORT SEASON LAST
YEAR, 256 GAMES.
JOINING US NOW, PETE ALONSO IN
ARIZONA.
HOW ARE YOU?
PETE: DOING GOOD.
BRIAN: ARE YOU AWARE OF METS
RECORDS?
DO YOU EVER LOOK OVER AND SEE
WHO IS ON THE ALL-TIME RECORDS
GIVEN THAT YOU HIT SO MANY HOME
RUNS?
PETE: NOW I DID.
I SAW IT POP ON THE SCREEN.
I DON'T NECESSARILY PAY
ATTENTION TO THAT STUFF.
MY JOB IS TO COMPETE EVERY DAY,
GIVE MY TEAM THE BEST CHANCE
THEY CAN TO WIN.
I WANT TO BE OUT THERE, BE
HEALTHY AND GIVE ALL I GOT EVERY
DAY.
BRIAN: GIVE IT A COUPLE YEARS
AND THEN TAKE A LOOK AT IT.
SO MANY OF YOU WERE INJURED.
YOU WERE INJURED.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE WHEN YOU ARE
PILING UP ON THE BENCH, ON THE
I.L., WATCHING NEW METS BEING
SIGNED?
WHAT WAS IT LIKE TO DEAL WITH
THAT AND KEEP THE SHIP FLOATING?
PETE: THE BEST THING I COULD DO
IS HELP BE A COACH AND AWAY,
HELP POINT OUT SOME THINGS IN
THE GAME.
TAKING SOME TIME AWAY FROM THE
FIELD GIVES YOU A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE ON THE GAME, GIVES
YOU A CHANCE TO WATCH FROM A
DIFFERENT LENS.
I AM HAPPY I GET TO JOIN THE
PARTY AGAIN.
THE BOYS HAVE BEEN PLAYING WELL.
I AM EXCITED TO BE BACK.
SEAN: YOU JOINED IN A BIG WAY
THE OTHER NIGHT.
BIG KNOCK WITH THE BASES LOADED,
TWO RUN BIG FLY.
WITH JACOB DEGROM ON THE MOUND,
I'M INTERESTED TO SEE, YOU AS A
PLAYER GET TO WATCH THIS GUY
PITCH.
WHAT IS IT LIKE?
PETE: ABSOLUTELY GREAT.
HE IS THE BEST IN THE GAME NOW
AT WHAT HE DOES.
REALLY SPECIAL.
HE IS A HELL PING-PONG PLAYER
TOO.
[LAUGHTER]
SO FAR WE ARE UNDEFEATED IN THE
CLUBHOUSE.
SEAN: ARE YOU A BACKHAND GUY?
PETE: BOTH.
SEAN: THAT IS WHY YOU ARE GOOD!
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKING OF PING-PONG, I THINK
THIS ADDS TO IT, I KNOW BEING
FOR YOU A FIRST BASEMAN, WE
THINK OF PETE ALONSO A BIG HOME
RUN HITTER.
DEFENSIVELY, YOU TAKE PRIDE IN
THAT.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOUR GAME IS AT
ANOTHER LEVEL.
WHAT DISPLAYING GOOD DEFENSE
MEAN TO YOU?
PETE: THERE ARE TONS OF WAYS TO
WIN A BALLGAME.
YES, YOU CAN HAVE A BIG HIT,
DRIVE ONE OVER THE WALL, INTO
THE SEATS BUT TO ME, IF YOU GET
A HIGH QUALITY PITCHER ON THE
MOUND, LIKE TODAY WE ARE FACING
MADISON BUMGARNER, A HELLUVA
PITCHER, A TON OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
IF HE IS ON, IT WILL BE TOUGH TO
SCORE RUNS.
YOU CAN WIN THE GAME DEFENSIVELY
OR TAKE AN EXTRA-BASE.
THERE ARE SO MANY WAYS YOU CAN
WIN.
THE MORE I EVOLVE, THE BETTER I
CAN HELP MY TEAM WIN.
BRIAN: I AM AFRAID TO ASK BUT DO
YOU EVER ASK KEITH HERNANDEZ --
I KNOW -- HE WAS SOMETHING
SPECIAL AT FIRST BASE.
DO YOU EVER TALK ABOUT THAT?
PETE: SINCE COVID, KEITH HASN'T
COME TO THE CLUBHOUSE.
HE JUST KIND OF TALKS UPSTAIRS.
HE DOESN'T TALK TO US MUCH.
HE IS MORE IN THE BROADCAST.
THAT TYPE OF SIDE.
HE DOESN'T OFFER POINTERS OR
ADVICE.
HE HASWON A BOATLOAD OF GOLD
GLOVES BUT IF HE EVER WANTS TO
COME DOWN AND GIVE ADVICE?
BRIAN: YOU SHOULD HIT HIM UP.
WATCHING HIM FOR THOSE YEARS,
AGAIN, I KNOW HE IS BROADCASTING
BUT YOU SHOULD GO AFTER HIM.
WE WOULD ALL LEARN SOMETHING.
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT GAME PREP.
MADISON BUMGARNER IS PITCHING.
IS YOUR GAME PREP -- HOW DOES
THAT WORK?
THIS BASEBALL OPS COME TO YOU?
IS IT SIMPLE?
SOPHISTICATED?
HOW DOES IT WORK?
PETE: WE HAVE A TEAM APPROACH WE
GO OVER BEFORE EVERY DAY.
THERE ARE A LOT OF NUMBERS,
DATA, ANALYTICS.
I WILL NOT TELL YOU TOO MUCH
BECAUSE THEN I SHOW MY HAND AND
I DO NOT WANT TO DO THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
I HAVE TO PLAY TODAY.
SEAN: YOU HAVE BEEN A NEW YORK
ENOUGH TO KNOW THE FANS AND HOW
PASSIONATE THEY ARE ABOUT THE
PLAYERS.
LINDOR IS THE NEW GUY.
HE IS THE BIG GUY.
HE IS THE NEW GUY.
HE HAS STRUGGLED SO FAR.
WHAT CONVERSATIONS HAVE YOU HAD
TO TALK ABOUT DEALING WITH NEW
YORK FANS?
PETE: I HATE ANSWERING THIS
QUESTION.
LISTEN.
AT THE END OF THE YEAR, THIS
ISN'T GOING TO BE A QUESTION.
IT IS A MARATHON, NOT A SPRINT.
WHAT HE IS GOING TO DO AND WHAT
HE BRINGS EVERY DAY, IT IS TRULY
TREMENDOUS.
HE HAS GREAT ENERGY.
HE IS ALWAYS PREPARED.
HE IS THINKING ON ANOTHER LEVEL,
BASEBALL I.Q. THROUGH THE ROOF.
HE WILL BE ONE OF THE KEY
COMPONENTS THAT WILL HELP US WIN
A CHAMPIONSHIP.
HE IS NOT JUST A CHAMPIONSHIP
PLAYER.
HE IS A DAM GOOD PLAYER.
AT THE END OF 162 GAMES, ASK ME
THAT SAME QUESTION.
BRIAN: HOW ARE YOU SITUATED?
GIVEN THE WAY THE DIVISION IS
PLAYING OUT, YOU ARE ON TOP NOW.
THERE HAVE BEEN INJURIES.
THERE WERE DEFENSIVE PLAYERS
BROUGHT IN TO AUGMENT THE
ROSTER.
HOW ARE YOU SITUATED FOR THE
SUMMER?
PETE: I THINK WE ARE ABOUT TO
HIT OUR STRIDE.
WE HAVE A TON OF GUYS COMING
BACK.
KEVIN PILLAR CAME BACK, MYSELF.
SETH LUGO.
WE HAVE A COUPLE OTHER GUYS
PRIMED AND READY ON REHAB
ASSIGNMENTS.
WHEN WE GET BACK FROM THIS TRIP,
WE WILL HAVE MORE GUYS.
WE WILL SEE THE IL LIST TRICKLE
BACK IN THE LINEUP AND IT WILL
BE GREAT.
WE WILL BE DANGEROUS AS THE
SEASON GOES ON.
I AM EXCITED FOR THAT.
HELL, WE ARE IN FIRST PLACE AND
WE HAVE TO DO WHATEVER WE CAN TO
EXTEND THEIR LEAD.
BRIAN: THAT MAKES SENSE.
KEVIN PILLAR COMING BACK IS
AMAZING.
THAT WAS FRIGHTENING.
WHAT HAVE YOU SPOKEN ABOUT?
PETE: I TOLD HIM, MAN, ABSOLUTE
WARRIOR.
I HAVE NOTHING BUT THE HIGHEST
RESPECT FOR HIM.
LOVE HOW HE PLAYS THE GAME.
EXTREMELY TENACIOUS, GRITTY, HE
WORKS TREMENDOUSLY HARD.
HIS ATTITUDE EVERY DAY IN THE
CLUBHOUSE IS INCREDIBLE.
FOR HIM TO COME BACK, HIS FIRST
A.B., TOE THE LINE, HIT A LINE
DRIVE THROUGH THE POLE AFTER
SOMETHING SCARY HAPPENING -- IT
IS TRULY REMARKABLE.
JUST SHOWS HOW MUCH HE CARES,
NOT JUST ABOUT THE GAME AND THIS
TEAM BUT HE IS AN INCREDIBLE
TEAMMATE.
INCREDIBLE STORY.
BRIAN: HIS TOUGHNESS WAS
EVIDENT, EVEN THAT DAY.
IT HIT HIM SQUARE IN THE FACE.
SEAN: INCREDIBLE.
BRIAN: GOOD TO SEE YOU BACK ON
THE FIELD.
CASE AND I WILL GO OVER THE
PLAN.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN: SEE IT AND HIT IT.
BRIAN: BEST OF LUCK.
PETE: LFGM.
SEAN: THANKS BROTHER.
TIME FOR THE CREATOR SPOTLIGHT.
CHRIS WILLIAMS IS A BIG ANGELS
FAN AND HIS YOUTUBE FAN IS
DEVOTED TO EVERYTHING MLB FROM
THE SHOW TO THE LATEST NEWS.
WELCOME, CHRIS.
CHRIS: HEY.
GETTING PRETTY HOT OUT HERE.
IT IS ABOUT SUMMERTIME.
SEAN: YOU LOVE PLAYING MLB THE
SHOW.
MAYBE I NEED TO PLAY AT MORE.
I WISH I HAD THAT WHEN I WAS
YOUR AGE BUT WHO IS YOUR
FAVORITE TEAM TO PLAY WITH?
CHRIS: I HAVE TO GO WITH THOSE
DODGERS.
THEY ARE TOO GOOD.
SEAN: WHEN YOU ARE PLAYING WITH
THE DODGERS, WHO IS AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF RANKING?
CHRIS: MOOKIE BETTS.
HE IS DIFFERENT IN THAT GAME.
SEAN: IN REAL LIFE TOO.
WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE THING
ABOUT THE NEWEST EDITION?
CHRIS: THE CREATE A STADIUM
FEATURE.
IT IS AWESOME.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN SOMETHING LIKE
THAT IN A BASEBALL GAME SINCE
M.V.P. BASEBALL 2005.
LOTS OF COOL STADIUMS.
I HAVE A COOL ONE.
IT IS AN AWESOME FEATURE.
SEAN: YOUR STADIUM, IF YOU
CREATED A STADIUM, IS IT PART
FENWAY, PART WRIGLEY, PART
P.N.C.?
CHRIS: PEOPLE CREATE ALL KINDS
OF STUFF.
I HAVE A CALIFORNIA BEACH VIBE
STADIUM, HITTING HOME RUNS IN
THE OCEAN.
SEAN: THAT IS AWESOME!
EXCEPT IF YOU ARE BOOGIE
BOARDING AT THE TIME!
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS: EXACTLY.
SEAN: WHAT ABOUT SHOHEI OHTANI?
TALK ABOUT WHAT IS SO IMPRESSIVE
ABOUT WHAT HE DOES?
CHRIS: OHTANI IS A DIFFERENT
BREED.
I MEAN.
PITCHING AND HITTING?
AMAZING.
WE FINALLY HAVE HIM HEALTHY THIS
SEASON.
15 HOMERS NOW.
TWO OFF OF THE MAJOR LEAGUE
LEAD.
100 MPH WITH A NASTY SPLITTER
AND SLIDER.
DEVASTATING.
I WOULD NOT WANT TO FACE HIM IN
REAL LIFE.
SEAN: IT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
BEING A HITTER IN THE BIG
LEAGUES, WATCHING HIM HIT THE
WAY HE DOES AND BE AN
UNBELIEVABLE STARTER, IT IS LIKE
NOTHING WE HAVE SEEN BEFORE.
HOW ABOUT YOU?
WHAT IS ONE OF YOUR FAVORITE
MOMENTS YOU HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
WITH IN A GAME?
CHRIS: WATCHING THE NO-HITTER,
2012, JERED WEAVER.
I WAS 13 YEARS OLD.
I DID NOT KNOW WHAT WAS GOING
ON.
I ASKED MY DAD, WHY IS EVERYONE
AT THE EDGE OF THEIR SEAT?
JERED WEAVER HAS GIVEN UP NO
HITS IN THE SIXTH.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
IT IS A DIFFERENT ATMOSPHERE.
SEVENTH INNING, EIGHTH INNING, I
REALIZE HISTORY COULD GO DOWN
TONIGHT.
JERED WEAVER TOSSED A NO-HITTER
IN 2012 AGAINST THE TWINS.
AMAZING GAME.
I WAS CLOSE TO HIS FAMILY,
WASN'T SITTING TOO FAR, SEEING
HIS FAMILY HAPPY WAS AMAZING.
SEAN: NOTHING LIKE WATCHING A
NO-HITTER IN PERSON.
I HAVE BEEN A PART OF ONE,
VERLANDER'S.
I ENJOYED THIS, CHRIS.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
GOOD LUCK WITH THE CHANNEL, MLB
THE SHOW AND ALL THE GREAT
THINGS YOU ARE DOING.
CHRIS: APPRECIATE IT.
BRIAN: SEAN CASEY AND I WILL GO
OVER PICKS TO CLICK AND TALK
ABOUT LOU GERETURN, GETTING CLOE
METS AND DIAMONDBACKS.
MADISON BUMGARNER GETTING READY
TO GO.
♪
>> DON'T MAKE FUN OF ME OR MY
BALLCLUB.
>> THE HEART IS PALPITATING.
>> HE SHOOTS THAT ONE INTO
CENTER FIELD, A BASE HIT.
SLIPS ON HIS WAY TO FIRST.
NOW IT IS A SINGLE.
DRIVES IN A RUN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THAT IS REALLY GOING TO HURT
HIS NUMBERS.
>> YOU MIGHT BE RIGHT.
>> THEY NEED THE INTERPRETER.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT COUNTS AS
MULTIPLE TRIPS TO THE MOUND.
>> I DON'T THINK SO BUT THAT WAS
GREAT HUSTLE.
>> WIDE OPEN SPACE.
QUICK DIVING STOP.
HIS FIRST PLAY AS A FIRST
BASEMAN AND JAMES MCCANN --
NEVER PLAYED THE POSITION BEFORE
SINCE COLLEGE.
>> HE IS LIMITED TO JUGGLING ON
THE BENCH.
>> OUTSTANDING.
>> PRETTY GOOD.
IF HE CAN CATCH THEM.
>> BAD JOKE.
BRIAN: DAVID PETERSON GETTING
READY TO GO FOR THE METS, ON
EIGHT DAYS REST.
PETERSON VERSUS MADISON
BUMGARNER.
WELCOME BACK.
PICKS TO CLICK.
SEAN CASEY IS HERE.
SEAN: I AM READY.
BRIAN: HE HAS SEEN THIS.
[LAUGHTER]
FORMULATE YOUR ANALYSIS.
JACOB DEGROM HAS A 0.71 E.R.A.
REALISTIC M.V.P. CANDIDATE?
SEAN: YES.
IF THE METS KEEP DOING WHAT THEY
ARE DOING IS A TEAM, HE IS
REALISTIC.
IT MATTERS HOW THE METS DO.
IF JACOB DEGROM KEEPS DOING HIS
THING AND THE METS GET THE
PLAYOFFS, HE HAS A REAL SHOT.
BRIAN: IF HE IS HOVERING AROUND
BOB GIBSON'S RECORD -- BY THE
WAY DARLING SAID ON MLB
YESTERDAY, HE THOUGHT HE WAS
BREAKING THE RECORD.
1.21 E.R.A. -- I DON'T THINK
THAT WILL BE DONE.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE UP RUNS
SOMEWHERE.
TATIS IS KILLING IT.
RONALD ACUNA JR. KILLING IT.
THE PADRES MIGHT TAKE THAT
DIVISION.
IT IS A NARRATIVE ASPECT.
SEAN: FOR ME, IT MATTERS.
I'M NOT A VOTER.
THE VOTERS HAVE TO LOOK AT
EVERYDAY PLAYERS.
PLAYERS THAT PLAY EVERY DAY,
IMPACTS MORE GAMES.
BRIAN: AT THIS RATE IT WOULD
HAVE TO BE TATIS.
WHO IS YOUR FAVORITE TO WIN THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE PENNANT?
SEAN: THE PADRES.
I LIKE THE VIBE.
I LIKE WHAT THEY ARE DOING WITH
THE CHAIN.
I LIKE THE PITCHING.
THE BULLPEN IS GREAT.
I LIKE TATIS, HIS LEADERSHIP,
THE GREAT MIX OF VETERAN AND
YOUNG GUYS.
THERE IS SOMETHING ABOUT THEM.
LOOKS LIKE THEY HAVE ENOUGH.
BRIAN: ALL THAT AND A GREAT
BULLPEN AND TRENT GRISHAM.
THEY ARE COMPLETE.
SEAN: GOOD PLAYERS.
BRIAN: TOTAL RUNS SCORED IN
TODAY'S GAME.
OVER-UNDER 8.5.
SEAN: OVER.
THE LAST COUPLE NIGHTS YOU SAW
SOME OFFENSE HAPPENING.
ALONSO MIGHT GET INTO A BIG
ONE.
LINDOR IS STARTING TO GET HOT.
THIS MIGHT BE THE TIME.
OVER 8.5.
BRIAN: MADISON BUMGARNER IS
PUZZLING.
HE HAS THAT NO-HITTER.
IN TOTAL COMMAND.
E.R.A. OVER 8.
SEAN: HE GIVES UP THE LONG BALL.
SOMETIMES HE GETS INTO TROUBLE.
THE THREE RUN HOMER.
BRIAN: DAVID PETERSON AGAINST
MADISON BUMGARNER TO START.
HERE IS WHAT WE ASKED YOU
EARLIER.
81% ARE GOING METS.
YE OF LITTLE FAITH TO MADISON
BUMGARNER.
SEAN: HE HAS THE STUFF THAT
SHUTS DOWN.
BRIAN: METS FANS REMEMBER, THAT
WAS THE WILD-CARD GAME HE DID
WITH THE GIANTS.
SPEAKING OF THE 27 YANKEES,
TODAY IS THE FIRST EVER LOU
GEHRIG DAY, OFFICIALLY
RECOGNIZED.
ONE OF THE ICONIC PEOPLE IN ALL
OF BASEBALL.
ALL-TIME GREAT PLAYER, ICONIC
FIGURE.
IT IS GREAT HIS NAME STILL
RESONATES, GIVEN HE WAS AN ICON
AT THE TIME.
A MAN WHO FACED ADVERSITY,
TRAGEDY, HANDLED IT WITH SUCH
APLOMB.
STILL ONE OF THE TOP 10 PLAYERS
IN THE HISTORY OF BASEBALL.
SEAN: WITH LOU GEHRIG, IT WAS
THE PERSON HE WAS.
THE FINAL SPEECH HE GAVE.
CAL RIPKEN JR. MENTIONED HIM,
WHEN HE TALKED OF BREAKING THE
RECORD.
HE SAID WHEN PEOPLE STARTED
COMPARING CAL TO THE PERSON LOU
GEHRIG WAS, THAT WAS WHEN HE WAS
LIKE, MAN, THAT REALLY MEANS A
LOT.
ALS AWARENESS.
BRIAN: IT IS IMPORTANT TO
CONNECT THE GENERATIONS.
YOU CAN GO BACK AND LOOK AT THE
GREAT PLAYERS FOR THAT
CONNECTION.
THE PLAYERS ARE WEARING THE
PATCH FOR LOU GEHRIG DAY.
THE 41.
TOM SEAVER.
I ALWAYS BRING UP THE STATS.
HAD HE BEEN ABLE TO PLAY OUT HIS
LATE 30'S AS NORMAL, HE WOULD
HAVE PUT THE ALL-TIME RUNS
RECORD AND R.B.I. RECORD OUT OF
REACH.
HE WAS SECOND TO RUTH IN
R.B.I.'S, THIRD TO RUTH AND TY
COBB FOR RUNS.
HE WAS AVERAGING FOR HIS
PREVIOUS SEVEN YEARS, HOWEVER
YOU WANT TO PUT IT UP, 40 HOMERS
AND 150 R.B.I.'S PER YEAR.
HE WOULD'VE OWNED THOSE RECORDS.
RICKEY HENDERSON WOULD PULL UP
BEHIND LOU GEHRIG.
SEAN: YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE
STATS FOR COOPERSTOWN.
I DON'T THINK FANS GO BACK THAT
FAR TO APPRECIATE A GUY LIKE LOU
GEHRIG WHO PUT UP MAJOR NUMBERS
AND LEFT AT 37 YEARS OLD.
BRIAN: IT WAS A HIGH RUN-SCORING
ERA BUT THERE ARE WAYS TO
NORMALIZE IT.
HOW DID YOU DOMINATE AS COMPARED
TO THE RUN-SCORING IN YOUR ERA?
WHATEVER THE TOP WOULD BE WAS
WHAT LOU GEHRIG WAS DOING.
HE IS STILL ONE OF THE TOP
HITTERS IN THE HISTORY OF THE
GAME EVEN AS COMPARED TO OTHERS
WHILE HE WAS PLAYING.
LOU GEHRIG DAY, JUNE 2.
DAVID PETERSON, MADISON
BUMGARNER, THE GIANTS -- EXCUSE
ME -- YOU SEE WHAT I DID?
[LAUGHTER]
IT WAS A BIG WONDERING, MADISON
BUMGARNER ON THE FREE AGENT
MARKET.
HAS HE USED UP HIS BEST SELF
ALREADY?
THAT THEORY THROUGHOUT BASEBALL,
SOMETIMES PROVEN WRONG, JON
LESTER -- DO YOU PAY FOR A
PITCHER IN HIS 30'S ON THE FREE
AGENT MARKET?
SO FAR, THE RESULTS HAVE NOT
BEEN GREAT FOR MADISON BUMGARNER
AND THE DIAMONDBACKS.
SEAN: HE HAD SO MUCH SUCCESS
WITH THE GIANTS.
WHEN YOU WATCH HIM, THE
NO-HITTER, I THINK HE STILL HAS
THAT STUFF.
WHEN YOU WATCH HIM PITCH, WOW,
GOOD STUFF.
HE GETS IN TROUBLE, NOT SO MUCH
WITH THE GIANTS, BUT WITH THE
DIAMONDBACKS, HE WILL GIVE UP
THE BEGINNING OR GET INTO MORE
TROUBLE AND NOT NAVIGATE OUT
LIKE HE USED TO.
IT IS TOO SOON TO TELL.
RIGHT NOW, HE HAS NOT HAD THE
SUCCESS HE HAD IN SAN FRAN.
BRIAN: THESE METS.
ALL BALLPLAYERS NOW.
THEY DO MORE GAMEPLAYING THAN
YOU THINK.
BASEBALL OPS TEAM TO HANDING YOU
THE PAPER SAYING HERE IS WHAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT.
YOU CAN GO DEEPER, LOOK INTO
YOUR SWING PLANE AND HOW IT
COMPARES TO MADISON BUMGARNER.
SEAN: AMAZING.
PETE ALONSO SAYING THEY HAVE
MEETINGS BEFORE EVERY GAME TO GO
OVER WHAT PITCHERS DO.
THAT IS GREAT.
THAT IS WHERE ANALYTICS AND
OLD-SCHOOL COME TOGETHER.
BRIAN: GETTING CLOSER TO
GAMETIME.
FINAL COUNTDOWN, THE METS AND
DIAMONDBACKS.
RUBBER MATCH, THREE-GAME SERIES
AT CHASE FIELD.
E METS AND DIAMONDBACKS COMING
YOUR WAY, ENJOY THE GAME.
♪
>> HERE'S THE PITCH!
[CAPTIONS MADE POSSIBLE BY MLB
NETWORK]
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]
>> DRIVES IT DEEP!
>> WHAT A PLAY!
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
OH MY!
♪
SCOTT: IT IS A DAY IN THE DESERT
AFTER EXTRA INNINGS LAST NIGHT.
THE VISITING BALLCLUB IS
RESILIENT, THRIVING IN FIRST
PLACE WITH FIRST-CLASS PITCHING.
NO WORRIES.
MLB GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE PRESENTED BY STATE FARM
PUTTING THE FINISHING TOUCHES ON
A THREE-GAME SET FEATURING THE
METS AND THE DIAMONDBACKS AT
CHASE FIELD.
EACH TEAM HAS TAKEN A GAME IN
THE SERIES SO FAR.
HELLO TO EVERYONE WATCHING,
WORLDWIDE ON YOUTUBE.
SCOTT AND JOHN JOINING, THE
FORMER NEW YORK MET, 50 OF HIS
22 SEASONS WITH THE METS -- 15
OF HIS 22 SEASONS WITH THE METS.
WE WILL HAVE FUN BRINGING YOU
ENHANCED FEATURES STREAMING
LOCALLY.
IT IS FREE.
THE MLB YOUTUBE CHANNEL IS HERE
FOR YOU.
JUST PAST 3 MILLION SUBSCRIBERS
ON THE CHANNEL.
CONGRATS.
THAT NUMBER WILL INCREASE.
LOOKING FORWARD TO GIVING YOU
DUGOUT INTERVIEWS.
WE HAVEMICED UP PLAYERS,
INCLUDING FRANCISCO LINDOR.
WE HAVE ONE OF YOUR RIVALS, LUIS
GONZALEZ, JOINING.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON BOARD.
LUIS: GOOD TO BE JOINING YOU
TODAY AND I AM FORWARD TO THE
BROADCAST.
SCOTT: ONE MORE JOINING US IN A
BIT.
LET'S START WITH THE NEW YORK
METS.
WE DREW THIS UP FOR YOU, JOHN.
THE SUBWAY PLATFORM IS STACKED
WITH PLAYERS ON THE I.L..
AT ONE POINT, IT WAS SO CROWDED,
THE NUMBER WAS UP TO 17.
THIS WAS A BIG PART OF YOUR
CHILDHOOD.
JOHN: IT IS A LITTLE CLEANER
THAN WHEN I GREW UP.
SCOTT: THE METS HAVE WANTED IT
NICE AND CLEAN.
THEY ARE DOWN TO 13 PLAYERS ON
THE INJURED LIST AT THE MOMENT.
JACOB DEGROM BACK, COUPLE
STARTS.
KEVIN PILLAR IS BACK IN ACTION,
IN THE STARTING LINEUP TODAY.
PETE ALONSO ACTIVATED, MONDAY.
SETH LUGO BACK WITH THE
BIG-LEAGUE CLUB.
QUITE A FEW PLAYERS STILL
MISSING IN ACTION.
JOHN: EVEN THE RAT WAS ON THE
DL, WITH A SLICE OF PIZZA.
SCOTT: HE COMES OUT THE BEST ON
THE SUBWAY PLATFORM.
HERE IS WHO HAS BEEN
STEPPING UP.
THE REPLACEMETS.
PINCH-HIT, WALKOFF R.B.I.
THE NAMES GO ON AND ON.
JOHN: LONG YEAR, STARTERS
GETTING HURT, THE GUYS HAVE TO
STEP UP AND DO THE JOB.
THESE GUYS HAVE DONE A
TREMENDOUS JOB HOLDING THE FORT.
SCOTT:FARGAS ON THE I.L. NOW.
TOMAS NIDO MAKING A NAME FOR
HIMSELF.
JOHN: REALLY GOOD BAT THIS YEAR,
EARNING HIS PLAYING TIME.
SCOTT: HE WILL SPLIT PLAYING
TIME AT THE CATCHING POSITION
WITH JAMES MCCANN.
MCCANN IN THE STARTING LINEUP
TODAY.
JOSÉ PERAZA, BOTH GAMES THERE.
JOHN: HE WAS A STARTER FOR THE
REDS, PLAYED FOR THE RED SOX.
HE IS USED TO PLAYING EVERYDAY.
COMING OFF THE BENCH, NOTHING
FOR HIM.
SCOTT: JAMES MCCANN LOOKS LIKE
HE BELONGS AT FIRST.
TODAY HE IS BACK A CATCHER.
JOHN: HE NEEDED THAT.
HE HAS BEEN STRUGGLING
OFFENSIVELY.
PLAYING A PRETTY GOOD FIRST BASE
WHEN PETE ALONSO WAS OUT.
HE STEPPED UP BIG TIME.
SCOTT: THE SUBWAY RIDE IS NOT AS
BUMPY AS IT APPEARS.
FIRST-PLACE TEAM IN THE NL EAST.
THESE ARE GOOD-LOOKING NUMBERS.
A TEAM WE EXPECTED TO BE OFFENSE
HEAVY IS MORE ABOUT PITCHING AND
DEFENSE/
JOHN: THE PITCHING HAS CARRIED
THEM SO FAR.
YOU HAVE JACOB DEGROM, STROMAN,
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING A
TREMENDOUS JOB.
BULLPEN IS DOING A GOOD JOB.
LAST NIGHT THEY HAVE A HICCUP
BUT THE THREE STARTERS
ARE CARRYING THE TEAM RIGHT NOW.
SCOTT: LUIS, THE DIAMONDBACKS
ARE 2-14 IN THE LAST 16.
IT HAS BEEN A SLOW BURN THEY ARE
HOPING TO ERASE NOW AND A FRESH
MONTH.
LUIS: NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
THEY WERE WAITING FOR JUNE TO
COME AROUND.
YOU SEE THE DRY SPELL HERE IN
ARIZONA.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO GET
THINGS GOING.
THEY HAVE HAD A LOT OF
STRUGGLES.
20-36, SECOND WORST IN THE
MAJORS.
THEY HAVE HAD A LOT OF INJURIES
AND JUST CANNOT FIND A WAY TO
GET THINGS GOING.
THERE ARE A FEW BRIGHT SPOTS IN
THE DIAMONDBACKS LINEUP.
SCOTT: ONE OF THE BRIGHT SPOTS
IS A GUY WHO BROKE OUT WITH THE
CLUB A COUPLE YEARS BACK AND
AGAIN IS CONTRIBUTING IN THE
R.B.I. DEPARTMENT AS MUCH AS ANY
PLAYER IN BASEBALL.
HE LEADS THE NATIONAL LEAGUE
WITH 39 RBIS
FUNGI.
EDUARDO ESCOBAR.
HE COULD BE IN SOME TRADES, COME
JULY.
LUIS: HE IS THE BIG RUN PRODUCER
FOR THIS TEAM.
HE HAS HIT 16-17 GAMES.
YOU SEE NOW THE CONTRACTS AFTER
THE 2021 SEASON.
THERE ARE A COUPLE PIECES THAT
MAY BE SELLERS AT THE TRADE
DEADLINE FOR THE DIAMONDBACKS.
SCOTT: MAYBE MADISON BUMGARNER
GOES ON ANOTHER RUN.
QUITE A BIT OF TIME LEFT ON THE
CONTRACT.
HE IS STARTING TODAY.
LET'S BRING IN STEVE GILBERT,
OUT IN ARIZONA, LUCKY GUY.
WHAT HAS LIFE BEEN LIKE FOR
MADISON BUMGARNER AS A D-BACKS?
STEVE: IT HAS BEEN A ROLLER
COASTER.
HE STRUGGLED WITH HIS VELOCITY.
THIS SPRING AFTER A NORMAL
OFF-SEASON, HIS VELOCITY IS BACK
TO PRE-2020 LEVELS AND THAT HAS
LED TO SUCCESS.
AFTER A SLOW START, HE HAD FIVE
REALLY GOOD STARTS, INCLUDING A
NO-HITTER AGAINST THE BRAVES FOR
SEVEN INNINGS IN ATLANTA.
THE LAST TWO HAVE BEEN MORE OF A
STRUGGLE FOR HIM.
HIS ISSUES ARE WITH COMMAND, NOT
SO MUCH VELOCITY.
WHERE DOES HE THROW THE BALL IN
CRUCIAL SITUATIONS?
IF YOU CAN GET IT TO HIS ARM
SIDE, THE BACKDOOR CUTTER TO
RIGHT-HANDERS, MADISON WILL HAVE
SUCCESS.
LET'S SEE WHAT HE DOES WITH
STRIKE ONE.
IS HE ABLE TO DROP THE BACKDOOR
CUTTER IN ON RIGHT-HANDED
HITTERS?
SCOTT: WE WILL BRING YOU LINEUP
SEND FIRST PITCH FROM PHOENIX,
WITH THE METS BATTLING THE
DIAMONDBACKS ON YOUTUBE, NEXT.
♪
>> DON'T MAKE FUN OF ME OR MY
BALLCLUB.
>> THE HEART IS PALPITATING.
♪
>> AS RILEY SHOOTS THIS TO RIGHT
FIELD, THAT IS WELL HIT.
IT BOUNCES OFF, HE THEN FALLS
DOWN.
>> WENT OVER TO PICK IT UP.
>> THE 1-1.
OH!
CAUGHT NOT LOOKING.
HE WAS TRYING TO GIVE HIM THE
HEADS UP.
JUST DIDN'T EXPECT IT TO COME AT
HIM.
>> DON'T STRESS ANY OF THE
LIGAMENTS IN YOUR FINGERS OR
ANYTHING.
>> HE IS TRYING!
>> GOT IT!
>> OFF AGAIN, TATIS.
HOSMER.
INTO A SPLIT!
STEALS SECOND.
>> THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
IT IS LIKE THE FLOOR EXERCISES
IN THE OLYMPICS.
SCOTT: THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE
PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
SCOTT AND JOHN FRANCO, LUIS
GONZALEZ, STEVE GILBERT.
JUST ROLLING ALONG IN ARIZONA.
THE DIAMONDBACKS HOST THE METS.
EACH TEAM HAS TAKEN A GAME SO
FAR IN THIS THREE-GAME SET.
LET'S INTRODUCE LUIS ROJAS' STAR
TING NINE.
LINDOR HAS EXCELLENT NUMBERS
AGAINST ARIZONA.
PETE ALONSO ACTIVATED MONDAY.
KEVIN PILLAR BACK IN THE
STARTING LINEUP FOR THE FIRST
TIME SINCE COMING BACK FROM
BEING HIT BY A PITCH IN THE
FACE, 95 MPH FASTBALL.
WE WILL GET INTO IT.
SMITH, THE ONLY LEFTY POSITION
PLAYER IN TODAY.
PETERSON WILL PITCH.
MADISON BUMGARNER IS A PLAYOFF
LEGEND.
THE SEASON, UPS AND DOWNS SO
FAR.
THREE WORLD SERIES RINGS, NLCS
M.V.P., FOR TIME ALL-STAR AND HE
CAN SWING THE BAT.
LUIS: HE CAN DO A LITTLE BIT OF
EVERYTHING.
HE IS A JACK OF ALL TRADES ON
THE MOUND,, OFFENSIVELY AND ON
THE MOUND.
SCOTT: TODAY'S ODDS ARE COURTESY
OF FANDUEL.
OVER-UNDER A .5.
JOHN: LOW-SCORING TODAY.
I THINK BUMGARNER IS OFF TO A
BAD START.
I THINK HE IS AT THE TOP OF HIS
GAME.
I THINK HE WILL BE FINE.
I COULD BE WRONG.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: WE ARE UNDERWAY ON
YOUTUBE.
FIRST PITCH FOULED BACK.
MADISON BUMGARNER HAS BEEN A
BETTER PITCHER AT HOME SO FAR
FOR ARIZONA.
COMING OFF A COUPLE CLUNKERS, 14
RUNS IN HIS LAST 10 INNINGS, TWO
STARTS AGAINST COLORADO AND ST.
LOUIS.
MOSTLY FOUR-SEAMER AND A CUTTER.
HE WILL MIX IN A CURVEBALL AS
WELL.
JOHN: THE CUTTER IS A BIG PITCH
FOR HIM.
ONE OF THE THINGS LUIS WAS
TALKING ABOUT BEFORE THE GAME,
HIS FRONT SIDE, HE IS LEADING TO
MUCH WITH HIS FRONT SIDE, HIS
PITCHING ARM, IS JUST DRAGGING
THROUGH.
SCOTT: CLOCKED, LEFT-FIELD,
HEADING BACK, CASTRO, HE WILL
PLAY IT OFF THE WALL.
HE WILL GO BACK TO FIRST.
BIG TURNAROUND.
JONATHAN VILLAR IS ON BASE FOR A
THIRD CONSECUTIVE GAME IN THE
SERIES.
JOHN: THE PITCH LOOKED LIKE A
LAZY CUTTER.
WASN'T A SHARP CUTTER.
YOU HAVE TO TRY TO GET THAT TO
HIS BACK LEG.
TOO MUCH OF THE PLATE.
LUIS: EXACTLY RIGHT.
A LOT OF TIMES THAT IS HOW
BUMGARNER, HE HAS BEEN
CONSISTENT IN BEARING THE BALL
DOWN AND IN OR A LOT OF TIMES
GETTING HURT IN GAMES EARLY
BECAUSE HE IS LEAVING IT UP IN
THE STRIKE ZONE.
SCOTT: THAT BALL WAS TORCHED 108
MPH OFF THE BAT OF JONATHAN
VILLAR.
LINDOR SWINGING THROUGH 91 MPH.
OK LUIS,, I MENTIONED THREE
GAMES IN A ROW NOW, JONATHAN
VILLAR HAS REACHED BASE IN HIS
FIRST A.B..
MONDAY TUESDAY HE WALKS AND GETS
PICKED OFF.
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT YOU THINK THEY ARE SAYING
AT FIRST BASE NOW, HIM AND
CHRISTIAN WALKER?
I WILL KEEP MYSELF TIGHTER TO
THE BAG HERE ON WEDNESDAY?
LUIS: YEAH, OBVIOUSLY --
[LAUGHTER]
-- WHEN YOU ARE GETTING ON BASE
ALL THE TIME, YOU GET TO BECOME
GOOD FRIENDS WITH THE FIRST
BASEMAN OUT THERE.
SCOTT: WALKER BACK AT FIRST BASE
TODAY.
LINDOR.
JOHN: NICE TRY.
TRYING TO GET THAT BACKDOOR
CUTTER, RIGHT SIDE TO THE
RIGHTIES TO GIVE UP ON IT.
HE JUST MISSED.
IF HE CAN GET IN A LITTLE MORE
AND BE SUCCESSFUL TODAY, IT WILL
BE A TOUGH DAY FOR THE METS.
SCOTT: 2-2 SENT TO LEFT FIELD.
THAT WILL DROP.
JONATHAN VILLAR WILL MOVE TO
SECOND.
BACK-TO-BACK SINGLES TO START
THE DAY FOR THE METS OFFENSE.
LUIS: ANOTHER FASTBALL OVER THE
HEART OF THE PLATE.
LINDOR IS LOOKING TO GET HOT,
ONCE AGAIN, YOU CANNOT MAKE
MISTAKES IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
ZONE AGAINST THESE HITTERS.
SCOTT: LINDOR HAS GOTTEN HIS
BATTING AVERAGE ABOVE THE 200
MARK NOW.
.198 TO START THE DAY BUMPS UP
TO .202.
JOHN: HE HAS BEEN SWINGING THE
BAT PRETTY GOOD LAST COUPLE
GAMES, STARTING TO COME AROUND.
PLAYING IN NEW YORK IS NOT EASY
THE FIRST COUPLE MONTHS.
HE WILL GET USED TO IT.
THEY BOOED PIAZZA AND LOOK
WHAT HE DID.
SCOTT: THEY BECOME FAN FAVORITES
REAL QUICK.
JAMES MCCANN WAS OFF TO A SLOW
START.
PLAYED SOME FIRST BASE OVER THE
LAST 1.5 WEEKS AND HIS BAT LIT
UP.
FOUR EXTRA-BASE HITS IN HIS LAST
FOUR.
6-13.
SPEED ON THE BASES.
MCCANN SENDS ONE DEEP TO LEFT
FIELD, FORGET ABOUT IT!
JAMES MCCANN MUSCLES UP FOR HIS
FOURTH HOME RUN OF THE SEASON.
THE METS GRAB A THREE NOTHING
LEAD -- 3-0 LEAD.
JOHN: THREE PITCHES, THE FIRST
THREE BATTERS.
KNOCKING THE BALL IN ENOUGH.
HIS WHOLE FRONT SIDE IS LEAKING
OUT, THE BALL IS LABORING OVER
THE LITTLE PART OF THE PLATE.
LUIS: NICE PIECE OF HITTING
RIGHT HERE BY MCCANN.
GETS A GOOD PITCH DOWN THE HEART
OF THE PLATE AND DOES NOT MISS
ON A 92 MPH FASTBALL FROM
BUMGARNER.
SCOTT: YOU KNOW, GONZO, 92 MPH
OVER THE MIDDLE THESE DAYS, WE
ARE SEEING THAT OVER AND OVER.
THAT IS THE SOFT STUFF IN MLB, A
COUPLE TICS UNDER THE AVERAGE.
LUIS: A GUY LIKE BUMGARNER, YOU
HAVE TO HIT YOUR SPOTS.
THEY WILL MAKE YOU PAY FOR IT IF
YOU LEAVE IT OVER THE MIDDLE OF
THE PLATE.
THIS IS NOT THE START THE
DIAMONDBACKS WANTED TO GET INTO,
ESPECIALLY AFTER A HORRIBLE MAY
COMING INTO JUNE.
SCOTT: 411 FEET FOR MCCANN.
IN THE MONTH OF MAY FOR ARIZONA,
FIVE WINS, 24 LOSSES AFTER A
14-12 OPENING MONTH OF THE
SEASON.
THE BLITZ IS ON HERE IN THE
FIRST.
PETE ALONSO NOW BEHIND 1-2.
THAT IS SENT TO RIGHT CENTER AND
THAT WILL DROP.
SMITH OUT IN RIGHT TODAY.
PETE ALONSO, USUALLY MR. EXIT
VELOCITY, DID NOT NEED MUCH
MUSTARD THERE TO FIND HIMSELF A
KNOCK.
JOHN: PROBABLY JAMMED HIM A
LITTLE THERE.
HE IS SO STRONG HE CAN HIT THE
BALL ANYWHERE.
LUIS: FIRST FOUR HITTERS OF THE
METS, THE METS LOOK LIKE THEY
HAVE BROUGHT THEIR HITTING SHOES
THIS AFTERNOON FOR THIS GAME.
SCOTT: I THINK CHRISTIAN WALKER
HAS GOTTEN TO KNOW ALL THE
HITTERS PASSING BY HIM AT FIRST
BASE.
VERY SOCIAL TODAY MR. WALKER FOR
ARIZONA.
WELCOME BACK TO THE STARTING
LINEUP, KEVIN PILLAR WAS
ACTIVATED MONDAY.
NO MASK AT THE PLATE.
HE HAS THE SEA FLAT BATTING
HELMET, HIS FIRST START SINCE
MAY 17.
HE CONNECTS, UP THE MIDDLE, THAT
WILL GET THROUGH.
THE CAROUSEL CONTINUES FOR NEW
YORK.
LUIS: THAT IS A TOUGH BREAK.
YOU SEE INDECISIVENESS FROM THE
SECOND BASEMAN AND SHORTSTOP.
THEY LOOK LIKE THEY WERE BOTH
GOING TO GO FOR THE BALL.
THEY PEAKED AT EACH OTHER AND
BOTH BROKE AWAY FROM IT.
LUIS: TOUGH BREAK FOR BUMGARNER.
THE BALL HIT.
JOHN: WHEN YOU ARE STRUGGLING
WITH THE FIRST FOUR HITTERS, YOU
GET THAT GROUNDBALL, YOU THINK
THERE IS A DOUBLE PLAY, THERE IS
MISCOMMUNICATION AND YOU SAY,
WHAT IS GOING TO GO WRONG NOW?
SCOTT: GO AHEAD.
LUIS: VARGAS, PLAYING SECOND
BASE, WAS JUST TRADED BACK TO
THE DIAMONDBACKS TODAY FROM THE
PIRATES.
SO NOT A LOT OF WORK HIM AND
NICK AHMED HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO
TOGETHER.
SCOTT: DOMINGO LEYBA DESIGNATED
FOR ASSIGNMENT BY ARIZONA.
NOW DOM SMITH, THE LONG LEFTY
POSITION PLAYER IN THE LINEUP
FOR NEW YORK TODAY.
HE HAS BEEN LIGHTING IT UP THIS
WEEK.
HITS FOR THE FIRST FIVE BETTER
SO FAR TODAY FOR THE METS.
LUIS: YOU KNEW IT WOULD BE A
MATTER OF TIME BEFORE THESE NEW
YORK METS, THEY HAVE TOO MANY
GOOD HITTERS IN THEIR LINEUP.
THEY HAVE STRUGGLED ON THE ROAD
BUT THESE GUYS CAN HIT.
SCOTT: SMITH SENT A FASTBALL
YESTERDAY TO DEEP CENTER FIELD
AND SNAPPED A HOMERLESS DROUGHT
THAT HAD LASTED 138 AT-BATS.
HE RECEIVED M.V.P. VOTES LAST
YEAR.
HE LAYS OFF THE HIGH STUFF.
2-2.
FLASHBACK LAST NIGHT, PART OF
HIS THREE R.B.I. EVENING.
SWEET SWING.
JOHN: THE LEFT-HANDED PITCHER
TOO.
SCOTT: LEFTY ON LEFTY.
LUIS: YOU KNOW, JOHNNY, ON THE
MOUND, YOU ARE LABORING NOW.
21 PITCHES.
STRESS ON THE FIELD.
3-2, NOBODY OUT.
DOWN TO THE SIXTH HITTER IN THE
LINEUP.
SCOTT: SMITH SENDS ONE DEEP
RIGHT FIELD, SMITH HEADING BACK,
WALL AND HE MISSES IT!
IT KICKS UP AGAINST THE FENCE.
THAT WILL BRING EVERYBODY OVER
TO ANOTHER BASE.
WE ARE LOADED UP HERE IN THE
FIRST WITH NOBODY OUT.
NOT ENOUGH TO LEAVE THE YARD.
SMITH COULD NOT LINE IT UP IN
RIGHT.
DOM SMITH CONNECTS FOR A SINGLE.
LUIS: LONG SINGLE.
TOUGH BREAK.
PAVIN SMITH, NORMALLY FIRST
BASEMAN, GOT DRAFTED IS ONE, YOU
SEE THE ANGLE, HE THOUGHT HE WAS
AT THE CUT THAT SHOOTS OUT A
LITTLE TOWARD THE BULLPEN.
HE FELT LIKE HE RAN OUT OF ROOM
AND HE STILL HAD MORE TERRITORY.
SCOTT: HARD CONTACT, CERTAINLY
NO BREAKS FOR MADISON BUMGARNER
IN THIS FIRST INNING.
IT WAS A BUMPY RIDE FOR HIM LAST
TIME AROUND AGAINST ST. LOUIS,
FRIDAY.
JOHN: THE RUNNERS HAD TO HOLD TO
MAKE SURE HE DID NOT CATCH THE
BALL.
THEY ARE LOOKING TO TAG UP, THAT
IS WHY THEY DID NOT SCORE ON
THAT.
SCOTT: FIVE SINGLES.
LUIS: THEY MIGHT HAVE RULED THAT
A HIT.
JOHN: AIN'T GOT NO LEATHER ON
IT.
YOU WILL TAKE THAT.
LUIS: ABSOLUTELY.
HE DIDN'T GET THE R.B.I. BUT HE
WILL SACRIFICE THE ROUTINE OUT
FOR A BASE HIT.
JOHN: ABSOLUTELY.
SCOTT: THIS HAS BEEN A NIGHTMARE
IN THE FIRST FOR BUMGARNER.
SIX HITS FOR THE FIRST SIX METS,
FIVE SINGLES PLUS THE THREE RUN
HOMER FROM MCCANN.
CATCH PROBABILITY ON THAT LAST
FLY BALL WAS 95% FROM STATCAST.
ON THE GROUND, GOOD FOR ONE, THE
THROW TO FIRST, THEY DOUBLED
THEM UP.
FIRST OUTS OF THE GAME.
PETE ALONSO COMES ACROSS TO MAKE
IT 4-0.
LUIS: RIGHT NOW THE WAY THAT WAS
GOING, BUMGARNER WOULD
GLADLY TRADE THAT.
TAKE THAT DOUBLE PLAY.
SCOTT: PETE ALONSO SHAKING HIS
HEAD.
JOHN: HE PROBABLY THINKS HE
SHOULD HAVE SCORED ON THAT.
KNOWING HIM THE WAY I KNOW HIM,
THAT IS WHAT HE IS THINKING.
SCOTT: OVERALL, A SATISFYING
OPENING FRAME SO FAR FOR THE
METS.
LUIS: THEY WILL TAKE IT.
JOHN: YOU NEVER HAVE ENOUGH.
KEEP ADDING ON, KEEP TAGGING ON.
SCOTT: MAN ON THIRD.
GREAT NUMBERS FOR PERAZA IN HIS
CAREER AGAINST BUMGARNER, 4-9.
IT WAS 4-0 YESTERDAY FOR NEW
YORK.
ONE RUN GAME IN THE NINTH WITH
TWO OUTS.
JOSH ROJAS EVENED THE GAME UP AT
4-4.
D-BACKS WIN IT THANKS TO A JOSH
REDDICK DOUBLE IN THE 10TH.
MCCANN HAD THE R.B.I. FOR NEW
YORK LAST NIGHT.
LATE SWING FROM PERAZA.
THAT IS A GOOD LOOK, JOSH
REDDICK, MR. WALK-OFF YESTERDAY.
LUIS: I THINK HE DID THAT JUST
TO TRY AND GET THE TEAM GOING.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT HAPPENS
BUT TO TRY SOMETHING DIFFERENT
AND MOTIVATE THE GUYS.
SCOTT: WHOEVER THE STYLIST WAS,
PERFECTLY MATCHED THE COLOR OF
THE HAIR WITH THE UNIFORM.
[LAUGHTER]
LUIS: I HEARD AN INTERVIEW WITH
HIM.
HIS WIFE BOUGHT THE PRODUCT AND
IT WASHES OUT EVERY NIGHT WHEN
HE GETS IN THE SHOWER.
HE CAN WASH THAT OUT.
HE SAID AS LONG AS THEY WIN, HE
WILL KEEP THAT COLOR.
RIGHT NOW, LOOKS LIKE HE MAY BE
CHANGING IT.
THERE IS A LOT OF GAME LEFT.
THE COLOR MAY HAVE TO CHANGE
AFTER TODAY.
SCOTT: PAYOFF TO PERAZA.
ROLLER.
ESCOBAR WITH THE LONG THROW
ACROSS AND THE INNING COMES TO A
CLOSE.
SIX HITS FOR NEW YORK, FOUR RUNS
INCLUDING JAMES MCCANN WITH A
MAMMOTH BLAST TO LEFT.
4-0 BOTTOM FIRST ON
YOUTUBE.
>> JACOB DEGROM, EIGHT HITS, TWO
RBIS.
>> ONE INTO RIGHT FOR A BASE
HIT.
HE WILL BE WAVED AROUND.
THE THROW TO THE PLATE.
JACOB DEGROM, M.V.P.
>> TWO OUTS, RUNNER AT SECOND
WILL BRING UP PETE ALONSO.
>> DRILLS ONE IN THE AIR TO DEEP
LEFT FIELD.
THAT BALL IS OUT OF HERE!
>> PETE ALONSO, TWO MORE RBIS,
FOUR ON THE NIGHT AND THE METS
HAVE BROKEN THINGS OPEN, NOW 5-0
NEW YORK.
>> DEGROM GOES SIX IN HIS SECOND
START BACK FROM THE INJURED
LIST.
TYPICAL BRILLIANCE FROM DEGROM.
>> KEVIN PILLAR GETTING A HUGE
HAND FROM HIS DUGOUT.
>> HOW INCREDIBLE IT IS HE IS
BACK IN THE BOX LESS THAN TWO
WEEKS AFTER GETTING HIT IN THE
FACE.
>> IT GOES THROUGH FOR A BASE
HIT!
>> KEVIN PILLAR TWO WEEKS AFTER
GETTING HIT FLUSH ON THE NOSE,
UNDERGOING SURGERY, COMES BACK
AND GETS A BASE HIT HIS FIRST
TIME UP.
SCOTT: FOUR RUN FIRST FOR THE
METS.
TIME FOR THE DIAMONDBACKS TO
ANSWER.
YOU'RE STARTING LINEUP BEGINS
WITH A CATCHER IN THE LEADOFF
SPOT.
ESCOBAR LEADS THE NL IN RBIS.
PAVIN SMITH WITH A 12 GAME HIT
STREAK, HAD A HOME RUN
YESTERDAY.
MADISON BUMGARNER CAN SWING THE
BAT IN THE NINE SPOT, IF HE IS
STILL IN THE GAME BY THEN.
REAL TALK.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID PETERSON WORKING WITH A
HEALTHY FOUR RUN CUSHION BEFORE
HE STARTS HIS DAY, MAKING HIS
19TH CAREER START.
LAST YEAR, DEBUTED WITH THE METS
IN JULY.
STRONG ROOKIE CAMPAIGN.
HIS SOPHOMORE SEASON HAS BEEN
MORE INCONSISTENT.
JOHN: BUMPY ROAD THESE LAST
COUPLE STARTS.
LAST START, WENT SIX INNINGS,
GAVE UP THREE RUNS, CAME OUT
FEELING GOOD.
HE IS STILL BEING INCONSISTENT.
SCOTT: WE WILL WATCH THE SLIDER
TODAY AS HE STARTS KELLY WITH A
FASTBALL.
THAT IS THE PITCH LUIS ROJAS
SAID HAS HAD INCONSISTENCY WITH
SHAPE COMPARED TO LAST YEAR.
HE ATTRIBUTED SOME OF THAT TO
THE FACT HE HAD BEEN WORKING SO
MUCH ON THE REST OF HIS ARSENAL
THAT HE LOST A FEEL FOR THE
PITCH.
JOHN: HE HAS BEEN THROWING TO
THE CHANGEUP AND THE TWO-SEAMER.
I SAW HIM IN THE MINOR LEAGUES,
HE WASN'T THROWING AS HARD AS HE
IS NOW BUT HE WAS CONSISTENT
WITH THE SLIDER.
IT IS A TOUCHY-FEELY PITCH, THE
SLIDER.
YOU HAVE TO KEEP THROWING IT TO
GET A FEEL FOR IT.
SCOTT: 2-2 TO CARSON KELLY.
YOU DO NOT SEE A CATCHER IN THE
LEADOFF SPOT EVERY DAY, GONZO,
BUT HE IS LIKE TO
JOHN: HE IS TRYING TO GET HIS
BETTER HITTERS AT THE TOP OF THE
ORDER.
THERE ARE A CORE OF SWITCH
HITTERS.
ONE LEFT-HANDER.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT DAVID PETERSEN,
HIS SPREADS AGAINST LEFT-HANDERS
AND RIGHT-HANDERS, LEFT-HANDERS
WERE HITTING HIM A LOT AT HER.
SCOTT: -- A LOT BETTER.
SCOTT: IT IS A STARK CONTRAST.
RIGHTIES AT .205.
LUIS: I THINK THAT HAS A LOT TO
DO WITH HIS SLIDER.
HE HAS ALWAYS THROWN THREE
CHANGEUPS TO A LEFTY ALL YEAR.
THIS WAS THE FIRST TIME HE THREW
CHANGEUPS TO A LEFTY.
JOHN: YOU WOULD HAVE THOUGHT HE
WOULD HAVE MORE LEFT-HANDERS IN
THEIR.
TODAY, WITH THE ANALYTICS IN
TODAY'S DAY AND AGE, THE NUMBERS
ARE USUALLY'S ADDING OUT TO PUT
MORE LEFT-HANDERS IN THE LINE UP
AGAINST HIM.
THE D-BACKS DID NOT DO THAT
TODAY.
SCOTT: HERE IS BUMGARNER.
TODAY, FOUR LEFTIES ON THE BENCH
FOR ARIZONA.
BALL FOUR.
KELLY HAS BEEN EXCELLENT WITH
HIS PLATE DISCIPLINE THIS YEAR.
THE LEADOFF WALK SET UP DAVID
PETERSEN.
LUIS: HE IS CONSISTENT WITH
RELEASE POINT.
HE HAS TO WORK WITH HIS RELEASE
POINT.
HE HAS GOT TO STAY DOWN WITH HIS
CHANGEUP.
HE HAS THROWN 100.
A CHANGEUP THIS YEAR TO
LEFT-HANDED HITTERS.
SCOTT: OPPOSING BATTERS ARE JUST
2-22 AGAINST HIS CHANGEUP THIS
YEAR.
I ASKED IF HE SHOULD BE USING IT
MORE.
LUIS: I DEFINITELY THINK HE
SHOULD.
JOHN: HE IS THE GUY THAT RELIES
A LOT ON THE HEAVY SINKER TO GET
THAT GROUNDBALL DOUBLE PLAY.
LUIS: THAT WAS THE CHANGEUP
RIGHT THERE.
JUST GOT A LITTLE BIT AHEAD OF
HIMSELF.
THE SHOT OPEN, AND HE DID NOT
STAY CLOSED ON IT.
GOT TO STAY THAT CHANGEUP.
SCOTT: I'M GOING TO THROW
SOMETHING OUT THERE.
IT MAY BE A BIT UNCONVENTIONAL.
MARTE SYNCS ONE DEEP LEFT, AND
HE HAS GOT HIMSELF A TWO RUN
SHOT.
KETEL MARTE POWERS UP FOR HIS
FOURTH OF THE YEAR.
IT IS 4-2.
LUIS: THAT WAS A CHANGEUP THAT
DID NOT GET DOWN IN THE ZONE.
IT STOOD UP IN THE ZONE.
JOHN: I'M STARTING TO WORRY
ABOUT FRANCO'S OVER-UNDER.
WE ARE NOT EVEN OUT OF THE FIRST
INNING.
WE HAVE SIX RUNS ALREADY SCORED.
NOBODY OUT IN THE BOTTOM OF THE
FIRST.
SCOTT: IT IS A CAMEO DAY FOR
YOU.
YOU CAN DO WHATEVER YOU WANT.
JOHN: I THINK IT WAS A SLIDER.
I DON'T THINK IT WAS A CHANGEUP.
A LITTLE DOT ON IT.
IT JUST LINGERED IN THERE.
JOHN: IT WAS A SLIDER, AND THAT
WAS THE PROBLEM FOR PETERSEN.
LAST TIME, THE ROCKIES TOOK
ADVANTAGE.
IT HAS ACTUALLY BEEN A WHILE
SINCE WE SAW PETERSEN, COMING
OFF EIGHT DAYS OF REST.
THERE IS THE SLIDER.
LUIS: CAUGHT THE BALL ON HIS
BACK LEG.
LOOK WHERE THAT IS, RIGHT OVER
THE PLATE.
SCOTT: MARTE HAS TWO HOME RUNS
IN THE LAST WEEK THAT HAVE GONE
OVER 450 FEET.
HE HAD A 457 FOOTER OVER THE
WEEKEND.
LUIS: I WANT YOU TO KNOW THE
REASON I SAID THE RUNS WERE
GOING TO RESULT IS BECAUSE I AM
A PITCHER.
JOHN: THERE YOU GO.
THIS WILL FRUSTRATE A MANAGER
AND IT PITCHING COACH RIGHT NOW.
YOU ARE STRUGGLING, JUST AS
BUMGARNER DID.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER IF HIM
SITTING IN THE DUGOUT FOR THAT
LONG INNING, THAT LONG AMOUNT OF
TIME, MIGHT HAVE HAD SOME
LINGERING EFFECT TO HIM.
LUIS: THAT IS A GOOD POINT,
SITTING AROUND AND WAITING.
SCOTT: ESCOBAR SWINGING FOR
ANOTHER STATE.
LINDOR WITH A COUPLE OF GOLD
GLOVES.
POPPED UP.
AND THE CALL MADE BY THE SECOND
BASEMAN FOR OUT NUMBER ONE.
ESCOBAR RETIRED.
HE IS MIKE. TODAY AND HE IS A
JAM.
-- MIC'ED UP TODAY AND HE IS A
GEM.
>> WHAT HAPPENED?
SAY HELLO TO EVERYBODY.
DO YOU SEE ME?
OK.
A BEAUTIFUL DAY TO PLAY
BASEBALL.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
NICE SHOES TODAY.
SCOTT: THAT IS AS GOOD OF A MIC
CHECK AS THERE IS.
EDUARDO IS ONE OF THE, I WOULD
SAY, THIS CLUBHOUSE GUYS, AND
ALSO BEST COMEDIANS IN THE
SPORT.
I THINK A GLOBAL AUDIENCE WILL
ENJOY HEARING HIM THROUGHOUT THE
AFTERNOON.
I MEAN TOREY LOVULLO SAID HE IS
THE GUY THAT HANDLES SOME OF HIS
BUSINESS IN THE CLUBHOUSE
SOMETIMES, AND DOES IT IN A
LIGHT-MANNERED WAY.
JOHN: HE REALLY KEEPS THE
CLUBHOUSE LOOSE.
WHEN PLAYERS WALK HIM, THEY
ALWAYS SEEM TO FIND A GUY LIKE
HIM.
THEY WANT TO BE AROUND PLAYERS
THAT BRING A LOT OF THAT ENERGY
EACH AND EVERY DAY, AND HE IS
ONE OF THEM.
SCOTT: CHRISTIAN WALKER, CHOP
SHOP -- CHOP SHOP GETS THROUGH
THE RIGHT SIDE.
JOHN: THE SHIFT ON AGAINST HIM
THAT TIME.
SCOTT: WALKER, ANOTHER BASE
RUNNER FOR ARIZONA.
LUIS: THE THING WITH THE SHIFT
IS, IF YOU ARE GOING TO PITCH
AWAY, AND THE SHIFT DOES NOT
HOLD, THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN A PET
PEEVE OF MINE.
YOU SHOULD PITCH INTO THE
DEFENSES.
IF THERE IS A SHIFT AND YOU ARE
PITCHING AWAY, THERE IS NOBODY
IN THAT SPOT RIGHT THERE.
SCOTT: WHO IS THAT ON?
IS THAT ON THE CATCHER TO TRY TO
FORCE HIM TO PITCH IN A
DIFFERENT LOCATION?
LUIS: MAYBE HE MISSED A SPOT.
MAYBE HE PITCHED AWAY.
BEFORE THE GAME, THEY HAD A GAME
PLAN ON HOW TO PITCH EACH
HITTER.
MAYBE HE JUST MISSED HIS SPOT
THERE.
SCOTT: PAVIN SMITH SWING THROUGH
THE OFFSPEED STUFF.
IT IS 0-2.
JOHN: THIS KID HAS BEEN ONE OF
THE BRIGHT SPOTS FOR THE
DIAMONDBACKS.
THEY WERE HOPING TO BRING HIM
OFF THE BENCH AND GET A COUPLE
OF SPOTS STARTS, AND HE HAS
WORKED HIS WAY INTO THE LINEUP,
PLAYING ALL THREE OUTFIELD
POSITIONS AND PLAYING FIRST
BASE.
SCOTT: TAKES THE PITCH DOWN AND
AWAY.
HAD A HUGE A.B. IN THE 10TH.
BUT BEFORE THAT YESTERDAY, HE
SMACKS HIS FIFTH HOME RUN OF THE
SEASON.
A SHOT OF MARCUS STROMAN TO
RIGHT FIELD.
35 FEET ON THE BELT HIGH
FASTBALL.
A NICE BACKDROP.
NOT A FLIP.
A DROP FROM THE ROOKIE, HOOKED
-- WHO TOREY LOVULLO SAYS LOOKS
LIKE A VETERAN FROM DAY ONE.
BEST RICKY IN HITS.
TIED FOR THE MOST EXTRA-BASE
HITS WITH GARCIA SECOND IN RUNS
AND FIFTH IN O.P.S.
JOHN: A QUIET KID.
HE JUST GOES ABOUT HIS BUSINESS
EVERY DAY.
HE IS LEARNING HOW TO PLAY THE
OUTFIELD ON THE FLY.
SCOTT: SEVENTH OVERALL PICK IN
2017.
PETERSEN IN THAT DRAFT 13
SELECTIONS LATER.
JOHN: THE ROUTE WE ARE TAKING,
IT IS GOING TO BE A BULLPEN
GAME.
SCOTT: LIVE CHAT IS BUZZING AND
THEY ARE THINKING THE SAME
THING, THE YOUTUBE CREATORS.
HERE COMES THE SLUGFEST.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU.
I'M TOTALLY DOWN FOR A
HIGH-SCORING GAME.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU WERE GOING TO
GET YOUR WISH.
SMITH WAS DOWN 0-2 ON THAT MAYBE
-- ON THAT A.B.
THAT IS A ROOKIE WHO HAS KEPT
HIS PATIENTS IN CHECK.
JOHN: LOOKS LIKE A GOOD YOUNG
PLAYER.
RIGHT NOW, EARLY IN HIS CAREER,
I CONSIDER HIM A DOUBLE SITTER.
AS TIME GOES ON AND HE LEARNS
MORE ABOUT HIS SWING AND HIS
POWER DOES SHE HAS A LONG WHEN
YOU SHOWED A LITTLE WHILE AGO.
HE IS GOING TO HIT SOME HOME
RUNS WHEN SHE -- ONCE HE
DEVELOPS INTO A BETTER
PROFESSIONAL HITTER, BUT HER
THAN HE IS RIGHT NOW.
SCOTT: DOWNSTAIRS, NICK AHMED.
IT LOOKS LIKE WE ARE GOING TO
START TO GET SOME ACTION IN THE
METS BULLPEN.
ROBERT GSELLMAN GETTING UP.
THERE HE IS.
I IT WENT AROUND, A BALL AND A
STRIKE.
THE FIRST SIX METS REACH, ALL
HITS.
AND ON THE DIAMONDBACKS SIDE,
THE FIRST FOUR OUT OF FIVE REACH
HERE IN THE BOTTOM OF THE FRAME.
JOHN: LIKE LUIS SAID BEFORE, YOU
WANT TO THROW IS ZERO AS QUICK
AS YOU CAN AND GET BACK INTO
THAT HIT.
AND YOU CAN SEE WHAT HE IS DOING
HERE.
NOT TO KEEP REPEATING MYSELF,
BUT YOU CAN SEE HIS FRONT
SHOULDER IS FLYING OVER, AND
THAT IS LEAVING EVERYTHING FOR
THE PLATE.
JOHN: YOU CAN TELL HE IS
STRUGGLING TO GET IT AROUND.
AND SOMETIMES THOSE YOUNG
PITCHERS ARE SCARED TO PITCH IN
THE ZONE TO CONTACT.
>> HIS RELEASE POINT IS ALL OVER
THE PLACE RIGHT NOW.
MUCH HIS FRONT SHOULDER AS HE
FLIES RIGHT OVER IT.
SCOTT: DOES A LONG LAYOFF DO
ANYTHING FOR YOU?
HE IS COMING OFF OF EIGHT DAYS
OF REST.
THEY PUSHED HIM BACK TO GET
DEGROM IN THERE, AND STROMAN
FLIP WITH HIM YESTERDAY.
JOHN: I THINK THE LONG LAYOFF --
SHE GOT A RAINOUT.
HE GOT BUMPED FOR DEGROM, BUMP
FOR STROMAN.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
ARE LOW MAN ON THE TOTEM POLE.
SCOTT: PITCHED LAST WEEK ON
MONDAY AGAINST COLORADO.
AND HE WALKED AHMED.
LUIS: WE MIGHT GO OVER 8.5 IN
THE FIRST INNING.
SCOTT: IN HIS SECOND SEASON AS
METS MANAGER, HE HAS WATCHED
THREE FREE PASSES, A SINGLE, AND
A TWO RUN HOME RUN.
WE ARE AT 14 MINUTES ON THE
TIME.
LUIS: IT IS GETAWAY DAY.
YOU ALWAYS WANT A QUICK GAME ON
GETAWAY DAY.
IT DOES NOT LOOK LIKE IT IS
SHAPING UP TO BE THAT.
JOHN: YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE GUYS WANT TO GET TO THE NEXT
TOWN AND GET IN EARLY ENOUGH TO
HAVE A GOOD DINNER, BUT IT IS
NOT LOOKING THAT WAY RIGHT NOW.
THANK GOODNESS WE HAVE THE ROOF
CLOSED, BECAUSE IT IS GOING TO
BE A COOL 105 OUTSIDE.
SCOTT: VERY VALUABLE, THE
RETRACTABLE ROOF AT CHASE FIELD.
THERE IT IS.
CLOSED UP TODAY.
IT IS A HOT ONE.
THIS IS THE SPOT.
A POOL IN THE OUTFIELD.
VARGAS TAKES A STRIKE.
LUIS: JEREMY HEFNER, THE
PITCHING COACH, CAME OUT,
PROBABLY JUST TO SETTLE HIM
DOWN.
TELL EVERYBODY WHAT HE NEEDS TO
DO.
STAY BACK A LITTLE BIT.
JUST BE FREE AND EASY INSTEAD OF
AIMING THE BALL.
JOHN: A LOT OF TIMES, A COACH
WILL GO OUT THERE TO GIVE HIM A
LITTLE BREATHER, CATCH HIS
BREATH A LITTLE BIT, NOT TRY TO
OVEREXERT HIMSELF OUT THERE.
THE POOL SHUT WAS GREAT.
I WAS LOOKING FOR STEVE GILBERT
TO RELAX OUT THERE.
SCOTT: I'M SURPRISED THEY DID
NOT SET YOU UP THERE, GONZO.
LUIS: I WOULD HAVE LIKED TO BE
OUT THERE TODAY.
JOHN: HE IS JUST GUIDING HIS
BREAKING BALL NOW.
HE IS NOT THROWING IT WITH
ANYTHING BEHIND.
HE DOES NOT FEEL SAFE.
HE DOES NOT FEEL SECURE WITH IT.
SCOTT: HE DID NOT HAVE HIS BEST
STUFF LAST WEEK.
ENDED UP PUTTING UP A QUALITY
OUTING.
VARGAS, CHOPPER ON THE GROUND.
THAT IS GOING TO GET THROUGH THE
INFIELD, AND IT IS GOING TO
SCORE TWO FOR THE DIAMONDBACKS.
WE ARE TIED IN THE FIRST.
I'LL TOMORROW VARGAS JUST TRADED
FOR THIS AFTERNOON SHOWS UP IN
THE LINEUP.
HE IS BACK WITH THE
DIAMONDBACKS.
WE HAVE A FRESH BALLGAME IN THE
OPENING INNING.
LUIS: THAT IS A GOOD WAY TO MAKE
YOUR PRESENCE KNOWN.
JOHNNY WAS TALKING ABOUT
EARLIER.
THAT IS A ROUTINE DOUBLE PLAY
GROUND BALL BACK IN THE DAY.
NOT TODAY, WITH THE SHIFT GOING
ON.
THAT IS A BASE HIT FOR TWO
R.B.I.'S.
JOHN: I KNOW IF I GOT MY GROUND
BALL LIKE THAT AND I TURN AROUND
AND I DON'T SEE A SECOND BASEMAN
-- A LITTLE HEAT RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS THE WAY THE GAME IS
RIGHT NOW.
LUIS: THAT IS THE SAME THING
THAT HAPPENED TO BUMGARNER.
HE GOT A BALL THAT WAS HIT A
LITTLE BIT TO THE LEFT OF THE
SHORTSTOP.
WHEN YOU HAVE A SECOND BASEMAN
PLAYING ON THE LEFT SIDE OF THE
INFIELD AND THE SHORTSTOP IS
PLAYING IN THE FIVE HOLE OVER
BETWEEN SECOND AND THIRD, THOSE
BALLS GET THROUGH FOR BASE HITS.
SCOTT: YOU LOVE AND WHEN IT DOEU
ARE GOING TO HEAR IT FROM THE
GUYS.
LUIS: ESPECIALLY OLD GUYS LIKE
US.
>> ONE ON, TWO OUT HERE IN THE
TOP OF THE FOURTH INNING.
>> DOM HITS ONE DEEP TO RIGHT
CENTER.
IT IS OUT OF HERE.
THE METS LEAD IT, 2-0.
>> AFTER WE LEFT TO GO TO BREAK,
A BIT OF A DUSTUP.
JAWING AT EACH OTHER AFTER ROJAS
MADE THE FINAL OUT OF THE
INNING.
BOTH DOUG GETS EMPTY.
4-0 LEAD.
PAVIN SMITH HAS BEEN THE HOTTEST
HITTER IN THE LINEUP.
>> PAVIN SMITH CRUNCHES ONE, WAY
BACK.
GOODBYE.
>> THE METS LEAD HAS SHRUNK TO
4-3.
>> NO RUNS ALLOWED.
BUT THE TYING RUN AT THIRD AND
TWO OUT IN THE LAST OF THE
NINTH, JOSH ROJAS, WHO HAD THE
DUSTUP WITH MARCUS STROMAN AT
THE END OF THE FIFTH INNING.
>> JOSH ROJAS, WHO HAD SOME
WORDS WITH STROMAN, GETS THE
SHOW.
>> THE TYING AND WINNING RUNS
ARE ON BASE.
>> FAIR BALL INTO THE CORNER.
>> HERE COMES ESCOBAR!
HERE COMES PAVIN SMITH?
DIAMONDBACKS ARE GOING TO WIN
THE BALLGAME!
SCOTT: IT IS THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK.
SCOTT BRAUN, JOHN FRANCO, LUIS
GONZALEZ STEVE GILBERT.
THE VALLEY OF THE SUN.
THERE HAS BEEN NO SHORTAGE OF
HEAT SO FAR IN THE OPENING
INNING.
ROBERT GSELLMAN IN.
DAVID PETERSEN DOES NOT GET
THROUGH THE FIRST.
SEVEN BATTERS FACED.
35 PITCHES.
HE LEAVES, GIVING UP FOUR RUNS.
THERE IS A MAN HE IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR ON FIRST AND ON THIRD.
HE WAS IS SOMEONE WITH A NICE
E.R.A. ON THE SEASON.
THEY HOPE IT IS A LONG ONE.
JOHN: THEY HAVE TO STRETCH IT
OUT OR IT IS GOING TO BE ABLE
LIKE LOUIS SAID EARLIER.
FOR SOMEONE HAS A SINKER,
SLIDER.
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE, HE COULD
LOSE HIS CONTROL A LITTLE BIT.
SCOTT: THAT WILL CERTAINLY HELP
THE CAUSE.
A POP-UP OFF THE BAT OF TIM
LOCASTRO.
FIRST PITCH ON THE RELIEVER
HERE.
LOCASTRO WENT AFTER IT.
STEVE: THAT IS A TOUGH AT BAT.
YOU'VE GOT FIRST AND THIRD.
YOU ARE LOOKING FOR SOMETHING TO
DRIVE.
HE DID NOT WANT TO DO WHAT HE
DID HERE.
WANTED TO GET THE RUNNER AND
FROM THIRD.
-- IN FRON T -- FROM THIRD.
SCOTT: REMEMBER WHEN MADISON
BUMGARNER WAS PITCHING IN THE
FIRST?
NOW HE IS AT THE PLATE.
JOHN: PRETTY GOOD HITTER.
GOT TO BE CAREFUL WITH HIM.
SCOTT: 19 CAREER HOME RUNS AS A
PITCHER AT THE PLATE.
ALSO HAS A PINCH-HIT HOME RUN ON
HIS RESUME.
HAS NOT HIT ONE YET WITH
ARIZONA.
LAST YEAR, WE HAD THE D.H. IN
THE NATIONAL LEAGUE'S.
LIMITED MAYBE -- LIMITED A.B.'S
SO FAR.
THE LAST 50 YEARS, THE ONLY GUY
WHO DID IT MORE OFTEN WAS CARLOS
ZAMBRANO.
BUMGARNER IS THE KIND OF VETERAN
THAT MIGHT STILL GIVE THIS TEAM
5, 6 INNINGS BASED OFF HIS TRACK
RECORD.
LUIS: BUMGARNER WILL TRY TO
FIGURE IT OUT AS HE IS GOING OUT
THERE.
MAYBE GET FIVE INNINGS, MAYBE
SIX INNINGS.
SCOTT: FOR THE METS, PEDERSON
FAILED TO MAKE IT OUT OF THE
FIRST FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HIS
CAREER.
VARGAS AND AHMED ARE ON.
THAT MISSES HIM TO BUMGARNER.
THE TWO WORST OUTINGS FOR DAVID
PETERSEN.
IN HIS TWO-YEAR CAREER SO FAR,
BOTH COME AGAINST ARIZONA.
ANOTHER ONE, 1.2 ON MAY 7.
SCOTT: NO DOUBLE SWITCH.
GO AHEAD, GONZO.
LUIS: THAT IS TOUGH ON A
PITCHER.
HE HAS TO SIT THERE FOR EIGHT
MORE INNINGS AND WATCH THIS
BALLGAME.
SCOTT: LOOK WHAT WE DID HERE.
ODDS COURTESY OF FANDUEL.
ALREADY AT EIGHT.
ONE MORE, AND YOU ARE IN
BUSINESS.
I LIKE YOUR CHANCES.
LUIS: YOU ARE WELCOME.
THEY ARE NOT LISTENING TO ME.
GSELLMAN HAS SO MUCH MOVEMENT ON
HIS FASTBALL.
SINKS ONE WAY, SINKS ANOTHER
WAY, DIFFERENT ARM SLOT.
JOHN: I WAS AN ESSAY THAT.
HIS FIRST PITCH HE THREW TO
BUMGARNER GO FOR RIGHT NOW ON
HIS BACK FOOT.
IT IS AMAZING HOW MUCH MOVEMENT
HE HAS.
SCOTT: BUMGARNER, SOLID CONTACT
INTO LEFT.
THE D-BACKS JUMP AHEAD.
IT IS 5-4.
THE R.B.I. SINGLE FROM THE
PITCHER'S SPOT IN THE FIRST
ARIZONA HAS CLIMBED ALL THE WAY
BACK.
LUIS: THAT IS A GOOD HITTING
PITCHER.
STEVE: TO SAY THIS IS A CRAZY
GAME ALREADY IS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT, I WOULD IMAGINE.
SCOTT: HERE IS MAD BUM.
A BARNBURNER TODAY IN ARIZONA.
HE OWNS A RANCH.
I FEEL LIKE YOU WOULD LIKE THE
PHRASE.
CARSON KELLY WITH HIS SECOND
AT-BAT OF THE INNING.
JUST TO GO BACK TO SOMETHING I
WAS DREAMING OF PREVIOUSLY, NO
DOUBLE SWITCH, AND GSELLMAN IS
GOING TO LEAD OFF IN THE SECOND.
JOHN: IF SETH LUGO IS BACK, HE
COULD BE THERE LONG THEM.
CURIOUS TO SEE IF THEY DO.
SCOTT: WHEN NOW THEY TRAIL BY A
RUN.
NINE RUNS IN THE OPENING INNING.
HERE IN THE DESERT, THE METS
POWERED UP, BUT SO DID THE
DIAMONDBACKS.
KETEL MARTE WITH A 451 FOOT SHOT
DIAMONDBACKS IN THE FIRST.
>> THE QUESTION RIGHT NOW FOR ME
FOR THE METS IS, WHAT IS NEW
YORK GOING TO GET OUT OF THIS
GUY?
HE HAS A BAD BACK.
HE HAS SPINAL STENOSIS.
>> HE HAS MISSED 115 REGULAR
SEASON GAMES.
>> STILL TRYING TO GET ON TRACK.
HE IS 2-11 ON THE SERIES,
HITTING JUST .171 DURING THE
POSTSEASON.
>> WILL HIT TO LEFT FIELD.
IT MAY GO.
GOING BACK.
HERE IT GOES -- HOME RUN!
DAVID PRICE GETS HIS FIRST HOMER
IN THE SERIES.
AND THE METS HAVE TAKEN A 2-1
LEAD.
>> ALL THOSE SUMMERS AND
COUNTLESS HOURS SPENT IN THE
BACKYARD, AND THEN YOUR DREAMS
COME TRUE.
YOUR FIRST AT-BAT AT HOME IN
YOUR FIRST WORLD SERIES, YOU GET
YOUR CHANCE TO HIT A HOME RUN,
TO COME TO FRIENDS, FAMILY,
FANS, THE CITY.
GOING TO BE ONE OF THE BEST
MOMENTS I EVER HAVE ON A
BASEBALL FIELD.
SCOTT: WE ARE HEADING INTO THE
SECOND IN ARIZONA BUT LET'S TAKE
A STROLL BACK TO 1989.
TODD PRATT IN NLDS GAME FOUR,
OVER THE WALL, AND THAT WILL DO
IT.
NO STEVE FINLEY DOES NOT HAVE
THE BASEBALL.
TWO FRIENDS ON THE CALL TODAY
BOTH INVOLVE.
LUIS GONZALEZ SHAKING HIS HEAD
WATCHING THE HIGHLIGHTS RIGHT
NOW.
LUIS: I REMEMBER THAT LIKE IT
WAS YESTERDAY.
I WAS THE WINNING PITCHER OF THE
GAME.
>> I WAS TRYING TO FORGET THAT
LIKE IT WAS YESTERDAY.
[LAUGHTER]
NOW I HAVE TO SIT HERE AND STEW
OVER THAT FOR THE NEXT EIGHT
INNINGS.
SCOTT: WHAT DO YOU?
YOU HAVE THE RING.
LUIS: YOU ARE ONE UP ON ME WITH
THAT.
>> I KNOW, BUT HONESTLY I FELT
LIKE WE HAD JUST AS GOOD A TEAM
IN 1999 AS WE DID IN 2001.
THAT WAS A GREAT SERIES.
I STILL REMEMBER FINLEY RUNNING
INTO THE WALL AND TRYING TO MAKE
THAT.
IT WAS A GREAT SERIES.
LUIS: I GUESS THEY ARE GOING TO
KEEP GSELLMAN IN THE GAME AND
TRY TO GET A LITTLE LENGTH OUT
OF HIM.
THREE OR FOUR INNINGS.
MAYBE TWO OR THREE INNINGS.
THE BULLPEN IS WELL RESTED SIDES
TREVOR MAY, I WOULD SAY.
SCOTT: FOR SO MANY FORMER
STARTER.
IT IS BASICALLY LIKE GETTING A
START.
YOU SEE HOW BUMGARNER LOOKS HERE
IN THE SECOND ALL METS REACHED
VIA HITS.
THE METS OPEN A GAME WITH SIX
STRAIGHT HITS FOR THE SECOND
TIME IN FRANCHISE HISTORY.
THE LAST ONE IS JUNE 25, 1979,
AGAINST THE PIRATES COMING IN
THE SECOND OF A DOUBLE DIP AT
SHEA STADIUM.
STATE FARM DEFENSE ON YOUR LEFT
FOR ARIZONA.
NICK AHMED IS ONE OF THE BEST IN
THE BIZ AT SHORTSTOP.
>> IT IS GOING TO BE INTERESTING
TO SEE HOW BUMGARNER CHALLENGES
THIS LINEUP THE SECOND TIME
AROUND.
HE HAS A NEW LEASE ON LIFE.
HE HAS A ONE RUN LEAD AFTER YOU
THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO BE DOWN
FOR RUNS.
-- FOUR RUNS.
SCOTT: THAT IS THE FIRST
STRIKEOUT OF THE DAY.
LUIS, THIS IS WHAT I'M SAYING.
TWO YEARS LATER, THE MOST EPIC
MOMENT IN FRANCHISE HISTORY,
WALKOFF, GAME SEVEN, WORLD
SERIES, OFF THE BEST CLOSER
EVER.
THAT IS WHAT EVERY KID REAMS
ABOUT.
-- DREAMS ABOUT.
>> THAT FEELS LIKE YESTERDAY,
EVERY TIME I SEE THAT.
99, LOSING THAT GAME, BEING ABLE
TO COME BACK A COUPLE OF YEARS
LATER -- YOU DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
WORLD SERIES YOU ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO PLAY IN.
SO MANY GREAT PLAYERS HAVE
PLAYED THIS GAME.
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO WIN
ONE, IT IS A FRATERNITY.
YOU WILL NEVER FORGET IT.
SCOTT: 20TH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
WORLD SERIES IS ON NOVEMBER 4.
LEADOFF MAN JONATHAN VILLAR
SINGLED IN THE FIRST, LATER
SCORED ON THE MCCAIN HOMER.
THINK ABOUT IT.
WITH ALL OF THE STRIKEOUTS --
THERE IS THE SPRAY CHART.
WITH ALL THE STRIKEOUTS WE SEE
IN THE GAME TODAY CHIPSET TO
RIGHT, AND HE IS ON AGAIN.
HE IS GOING TO HEAD FOR TWO AND
GET IN THERE.
A SINGLE IN THE FIRST.
A DOUBLE IN THE SECOND.
CONTACT THE LORD TODAY.
>> THESE GUYS ARE DOING A GOOD
JOB.
DON'T SLEEP ON THE METS.
THESE GUYS ARE LEADING THEIR
DIVISION RIGHT NOW.
THEY HAVE SOME GUYS THAT ARE
INJURED.
WHEN THEY GET BACK, THIS
BALLCLUB, THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE
GREAT BENCH PLAYERS READY TO GO
TO FILL IN WITH THOSE OTHER
STARTERS.
THEY HAVE SOME GUY NAMED DEGROM
AT THE TOP OF THE ROTATION.
HE IS PRETTY GOOD.
SCOTT: HE LOOKED GOOD ON MONDAY,
TOYING WITH THE D-BACKS.
SIXTH SHUTOUT INNINGS.
TWO SINGLES, 70 PITCHES.
>> HOW ABOUT BEING ONE OF THOSE
REHAB GUYS?
WHEN HE WENT DOWN TO REHAB, ONE
OF THOSE A BALL GUYS, HAVING TO
FACE DEGROM --
>> I THINK HE WANTED TO PUT ON
INSTAGRAM, "SEND HELP."
>>
SOME OF THESE KIDS ARE COMING
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL OR COLLEGE
AND DID NOT SEE GUYS THROWING IN
THE MID TO UPPER 90'S.
NOW THEY ARE FACING A GUY
THROWING TRIPLE DIGITS.
THAT IS A TOUGH DRAW.
SCOTT: DEGROM HAS BEEN
UNBELIEVABLE THE LAST THREE OR
FOUR YEARS.
HE GOES OUT FREE AND EASY,
THROWING 101, 102 MILES AN HOUR.
HE IS VERY QUIET.
YOU NEVER HEAR HIM MAKE A PEEP
IN THE LOCKER ROOM.
HE DOES HIS JOB DAY IN AND DAY
OUT.
SCOTT: POPPED UP.
IT IS WALKER CALLING OFF KELLY
FOR THE SECOND OUT.
REWIND TO THE FIRST.
VILLAR, LINDOR, MCCANN WENT BASE
HIT, BASE HIT, THREE RUN BLAST.
LUIS: THEY GOT TOO MUCH AT THE
PLATE EARLIER IN THE COUNT.
THEY JUMPED ON HIM.
NOW IT SEEMS LIKE HE IS WORKING
THE BALL A LITTLE BIT MORE IN.
HE WILL FIGURE IT OUT AS A
VETERAN GUY.
IF HE GETS IN A GROOVE, METS
WILL BE IN TROUBLE HERE.
SCOTT: HE KNOWS HIS VELOCITY IS
NOT WHAT IT USED TO BE.
BACK IN THE DAY, HE THOSE
PITCHES IF HE IS THROWING MID TO
UPPER 90'S.
-- HE COULD GET AWAY WITH THOSE
PITCHES IF HE IS THROWING MID TO
UPPER 90'S.
NOW HE HAS TO FIND OTHER WAYS,
TRYING TO SPOT THOSE PITCHES IN
AND OUT OF THE STRIKE ZONE.
HE'S ON A FIVE-YEAR $85 MILLION
CONTRACT, COMING FROM THE
GIANTS.
OVER TO ARIZONA FOR THE 2020
CAMPAIGN.
HE SIGNED UP THROUGH 2024.
I FEEL LIKE WE HAVE BEEN
WATCHING BUMGARNER FOREVER.
HE'S 31 YEARS OLD.
ALREADY IN HIS 13TH SEASON.
MCCANN UP THE MIDDLE.
SOLIDLY STRUCK.
HERE COMES VILLAR ROUNDING
SCORED.
HE WILL SCORE EASILY.
-- VILLAR ROUNDING THIRD.
MCCANN'S FOURTH R.B.I..
WE ARE IN THE SECOND.
LUIS: HAD FOUR HITS THE OTHER
NIGHT AGAINST ATLANTA.
TWO MORE HITS TONIGHT.
AND AGAIN, THAT BALL WAS NOT IN
LIKE HE WANTED, IT WAS MIDDLE.
SCOTT: LEADOFF MAN FOR NEW YORK
SCORED TWICE.
WE ARE UP TO ALONSO FOR THE
SECOND TIME TODAY.
WE SAW THE CURVEBALL FROM
BUMGARNER.
DOES HE NEED TO MIX THAT IN
MORE?
LUIS: I THINK SO, BUT HE'S GOT
TO BE CAREFUL BECAUSE THESE ARE
DANGEROUS HITTERS IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE ORDER.
IF YOU ARE STRUGGLING WITH YOUR
COMMAND, YOU BETTER FIND
SOMETHING THAT IS WORKING WELL
FOR YOU.
IF NOT, THESE GUYS ARE GOING TO
MAKE YOU PAY.
SCOTT: THAT IS A GOOD PITCH.
JOHN: BACKDOOR CURVEBALL THERE
AT THE FIRST PITCH.
THAT WAS A CUTTER IN.
HE'S GOT TO BE VERY CAREFUL.
SCOTT: NICELY FRAMED THERE TOO
BY KELLY.
LUIS: YOU SEE A GUY LIKE PETE
ALONSO ON THAT PITCH, 83 MILES
AN HOUR, HIS EYES LIT UP
THINKING HOW HE WOULD DRIVE THAT
BALL.
LAST NIGHT, FIRST CAME BACK FROM
THE INJURED LIST.
MADE HIS IMPACT KNOWN REAL
QUICK.
SCOTT: MONDAY HIS SEVENTH HOME
RUN OF THE SEASON, LEADS THE
TEAM.
AND THIS IS STRIKE THREE.
SO TWO K'S A RUN AND WE
ARE TIED AT 5-5 AFTER ONE AND A
HALF.
>> AND THIS ONE TO A WIDE OPEN
SPACE.
MCCANN WITH A GREAT DIVING STOP.
>> MCCANN DRIVES ONE OUT TO LEFT
FIELD.
TAPIA GOING BACK.
AT THE WALL.
IT IS OUT OF HERE.
JAMES MCCANN, NUMBER THREE
HITTER AND FIRST BASEMAN, IT'S A
HOME RUN.
>> THE 2-1 PITCH LIFTED.
TO THE TRACK.
TO THE WALL.
IT'S GONE.
A HOME RUN.
>> A LINE DRIVE TOWARD CENTER.
ARE READY AT BACK.
-- HEREDIA BACK.
I CAN GETS TO SECOND.
HE'S ON HIS WAY TO THIRD.
RELAY THROW FROM SWANSON WON'T
BE MADE.
>> BASE HIT GOING INTO RIGHT
FIELD.
LINDOR WILL GET TO THIRD EASILY.
MCCANN 3-3 ONTO FIRST WITH A
SINGLE.
HE'S GOT A SINGLE, DOUBLE, AND
HOMER.
GROUND BALL.
SHORTSTOP HOME.
SWANSON SLIDES AND CAN'T GET IT.
VILLAR RACES AROUND TO SCORE.
IT WILL BE 4-4 TONIGHT FOR
MCCANN.
THE METS INCREASED THEIR LEAD TO
7-1.
>> THIRD TIME IN HIS CAREER HE'S
HAD A FOUR HIT GAME.
SCOTT: BACK ON YOUTUBE WITH OUR
FIRST POLL QUESTION OF THE DAY.
IF YOU ARE WATCHING ON YOUR
PHONE, ON YOUR COMPUTER, HELP US
OUT AS WE ARE LOOKING FOR THE
EPIC PLAYOFF PITCHING LEGEND OF
THE PAST 50 YEARS.
WHICH PITCHER WOULD YOU WANT
MOST ON YOUR POSTSEASON ROSTER?
WE ARE GOING SINCE 1969, WHEN
THE MOUND WAS LOWERED.
WE BRING IT UP TODAY BECAUSE
BUMGARNER IS PITCHING AND HE WAS
RIDICULOUS IN SOME WORLD SERIES
APPEARANCES FOR THE GIANTS.
2016, HE BASICALLY CARRIED THE
SQUAD.
SCHILLING IS ON THE LIST, ALONG
WITH SMOLTZ AND MARIANO RIVERA
AND WEEDS GONZALEZ.
-- AND LUIS GONZALEZ.
WE WILL GET YOUR PICKS AND SEE
IF IT HOPES TO SWAY THE CROWD.
JOHN, I SEE YOU IN DEEP THOUGHT.
IF YOU HAD ONE GUY TO PUT ON
YOUR POST SEASON ROSTER?
JOHN: I WILL TAKE RIVERA.
ALL THREE ARE GREAT PICKS.
SCOTT: HE ONLY BLEW ONE GAME.
ONE BLIP ON THE RADAR.
THAT WAS GONZALEZ IN 2001.
LUIS: YOU SAW HOW HE PICKED THE
CLOSER, RIGHT?
[LAUGHTER]
IT IS A TIGHTKNIT BUNCH OF GUYS.
YOU REALLY CAN'T GO WRONG WITH
ANY OF THOSE GUYS.
IF YOU'RE GOING STARTERS, YOU'VE
GOT SMOLTZ, WHO WAS DOMINANT FOR
SO MANY YEARS.
SCHILLING WAS PROBABLY ONE OF
THE MOST PREPARED PITCHERS.
BUMGARNER, THE RUN HE HAD --
SHOOT, I WILL THROW ALL THE
NAMES IN A HAT AND WHATEVER YOU
PICK YOU CAN'T GO WRONG.
EVEN MARIANO CLOSING GAMES OUT.
THE OTHER THREE ARE THE
LONGEVITY GUYS, GUYS LIKE
FRANCO.
THEY COME LATE TO THE PARTY AND
CELEBRATE WITH EVERYBODY AT THE
END.
LUIS: SOMEBODY HAS GOT TO DO IT.
[LAUGHTER]
HE'S THE GUY THAT EVERYBODY
ORDERS DINNER AND AT THE END HE
LEAVES AFTER THE CHECK COMES.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: HE GETS THE FIRST OUT IN
THE HOME SECOND TO KETEL MARTE.
OMAR MANAEA IS HANGING WITH US
TODAY, RUNNING THE METS ACCOUNT.
WHEN YOU ARE A G.M. IN A GAME
LIKE TODAY AND YOU KNOW IT IS A
LONG ONE, YOU DON'T WANT TO PLAY
ONE OF THOSE LONG ONES AND LOSE.
WE HAVE A LONG ONE.
ACCORDING TO OMAR, THIS HOLDS
EXTRA MEANING ON GETAWAY DAY.
WE HAD A 43 MINUTE FIRST INNING.
ESCOBAR WATCHES BALL ONE.
DID YOU ACTUALLY MAKE A
SELECTION, LUIS?
YOU ARE ON THE CALL TODAY.
LUIS: I DID NOT.
I DID THE POLITICAL ROUTE.
SCOTT: EVERYONE ELSE HAS TO
PICK.
JUST GIVE ME A GUY.
LUIS: YOU GUYS ARE IN STUDIO,
AND I DON'T KNOW IF SMOLTZY IS
THERE OR NOT.
I STRUGGLED WITH HIM MY WHOLE
CAREER.
I WANT TO MAKE HIS DAY IF HE'S
AROUND STUDIO WITH YOU GUYS.
YOU WILL SEE, OVER THERE.
-- SEE HIM OVER THERE.
SCOTT: I WILL LET HIM KNOW WHEN
I PASS HIM IN THE HALLWAY.
LUIS: ABSOLUTELY.
SCOTT: DOWNLOAD TO ESCOBAR, WHO
IS MIC'ED UP TODAY.
>> SAFE!
[APPLAUSE]
SAFE!
SCOTT: HE IS SOMETHING ELSE.
I WAS TELLING JOHN ABOUT HIM
BEFORE THE GAME.
I SPENT TIME WITH EDUARDO
ESCOBAR.
HE IS VOCAL, HE IS HILARIOUS.
BILINGUAL, SO HE CAN MAKE ANYONE
LAUGH IN THE CLUBHOUSE.
AND THAT IS CONNECTED TO RIGHT.
HE'S GOT HIMSELF A SINGLE.
HE CAN SWING THE BAT TOO.
HE IS THE N.L. R.B.I. LEADER.
STEVE GILBERT JUST SAW THAT IN
PERSON.
HOW FUN IS HE TO WATCH?
>> HE IS A REALLY GOOD CLUBHOUSE
GUY.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF FUN WITH HIM.
HE IS DEATHLY AFRAID OF CATS.
I DON'T MEAN BIG CATS, I MEAN
LIKE YOUR HOUSEHOLD CATS.
DAVID PERALTA USED TO BRING A
STUFFED CAT INTO THE DUGOUT AND
NOW AND AGAIN THROW IT AT HIM.
IT WOULD ALWAYS SCARE HIM.
THEY HAVE DONE ALL KINDS OF
PRANKS WITH THAT.
SCOTT: THE D-BACKS MASCOT IS A
BOBCAT, CORRECT?
LUIS: YEAH, THAT WAS NAMED AFTER
BANK ONE BALLPARK, THE ORIGINAL
NAME OF THE STADIUM.
SCOTT: THAT IS A LINER TO
ALONSO.
HE WILL STEP ON THE BAG.
DOUBLE THEM UP AND RETIRE THE
SIDE.
A LASER.
PETE IN THE RIGHT SPOT.
A SCORELESS BOTTOM OF THE
SECOND.
5-5 AFTER TWO.
♪
>> OFF THE SIDE OF THE MOUND.
CRAWFORD CAN'T GET IT.
A SINGLE.
HE'S GOING TO GO OVER THAT WAY.
DICKERSON WAS BACK.
>> HE'S IN SAFELY IN SIX
STRAIGHT GAMES.
>> DUNKS IT IN FRONT OF
DICKERSON.
THAT IS THE SECOND TIME DAVID
SMITH HAS FOUND A BASE HIT
OVER THERE.
>> GETS BY ROGERS.
NOBODY HOME AT FIRST.
THAT WILL GET TWO IN.
MAYBIN SMITH FOR THE DOUBLE.
IT IS A ONE RUN BALLGAME.
MAYBIN HITS IT DEEP TO LEFT
CENTER.
MAYBIN SMITH HITS OFF THE WALL.
HERE COMES KETEL.
MAYBIN SMITH HAS TIED THE
BALLGAME.
MAYBIN SMITH, STAY HOT.
YOU CALLED IT EARLIER.
HE IS PUTTING THESE DOUBLES IN
THE ABSOLUTE PERFECT SPOTS.
IT WILL BE A TRIPLE.
>> BAT ON THE GROUND.
IT IS A BASE HIT.
MAYBIN SMITH MAKING A 10 GAME
HITTING STREAK.
SCOTT: THIS IS THE OAKLAND
ATHLETICS NBA REFEREE RIGHT
HERE.
[WHISTLE]
A DOUBLE TECH.
>> HE'S CHECKING ME UNDERNEATH.
>> TAKE US TO BREAK!
GIVE US A CALL!
SCOTT: HE IS GOOD.
HE JOINS US TODAY FOR THIS HALF
INNING ON YOUTUBE.
YOUTUBE CREATORS, YOU KNOW WHAT
TO DO IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
HIT US UP AND I WILL RELAY IT TO
THE GREAT STEPHEN VOGT, OUR
STATE FARM INTERVIEW IN THE
DUGOUT.
I'M SURE YOU CAN'T GET ENOUGH OF
THAT CLIP.
THAT WAS MONEY.
NATIONAL AUDIENCE.
IT SHOWED YOUR UNIQUE REFEREE
ABILITY.
STEPHEN: IT WAS FUN.
WHEN YAN GOMES INVITED ME TO
COME ON INTENTIONAL TALK WITH
HIM, IT TURNED INTO A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS.
A LOT OF FUN.
SCOTT: WE SAW IT ON INTENTIONAL
TALK ON MLB NETWORK YEARS BACK.
WE WILL HAVE A POLL QUESTION FOR
FUNNIEST PLAYER IN MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
YOU ARE ON THE LIST.
WE WILL SEE HOW THAT GOES LATER.
LET'S START OFF WITH SOME
QUESTIONING.
FIRST OFF, WHO IS PICKING ON YOU
IN THE DUGOUT THROUGHOUT THE
DAY?
STEPHEN: THAT IS ASDRUBAL
CABRERA.
HE'S UNFORTUNATELY ON THE I.L.
RIGHT NOW, SO HE'S GOT A LOT OF
TIME ON HIS HANDS.
HE KNOWS I LIKE TO CHEW SOME
GUM.
SCOTT: WHY DON'T YOU LET THE
YOUTUBE AUDIENCE KNOW WHAT IT IS
LIKE TO SWING A BAT, ESPECIALLY
WITH GUYS THROWING MID 90'S
REGULARLY AND DO SO WITHOUT
BATTING GLOVES?
STEPHEN: FUNNY STORY.
FOR ME, I WAS IN HIGH A IN 2010
AND TOOK SOME BAD BATTING
PRACTICE.
I RIPPED MY GLOVES OFF AND WENT
THE REST OF THE PRACTICE WITHOUT
BATTING GLOVES.
TWO HITS THAT NIGHT AND HAVE NOT
LOOKED BACK SINCE.
THE WAY YOU SWING A BAT AT UPPER
90'S WITHOUT BATTING GLOVES IS A
LOT OF PINE TAR.
YOU MAKE SURE IT IS STUCK TO
YOUR HANDS AND WON'T GO FLYING
OUT.
LUIS: LUIS GONZALEZ HERE.
MADISON BUMGARNER TODAY
STRUGGLED EARLIER.
NOW A PITCHING CHANGE.
YOU HAVE CAUGHT HIM FOR A LONG
TIME IN THE GIANTS SYSTEM AND
NOW HERE.
STEPHEN: THE THING WITH BUM IS
WHEN HE'S GOT HIS COMMAND DOWN,
THAT IS WHEN YOU SEE HIM GETTING
QUICK OUTS.
TODAY IT SEEMED LIKE HE WAS
MISSING OVER THE MIDDLE AND THE
STUFF WAS NOT AS SHARP.
USUALLY WHEN YOU SEE WHAT
HAPPENED THESE FIRST COUPLE
INNINGS WITH HIM, THE COMMAND
WAS OFF AND THINGS WERE NOT AS
SHARP.
FORTUNATELY THE OFFENSE PICKED
US UP.
WE ARE ALL KNOTTED UP WITH A
CHANCE TO WIN.
SCOTT: RILEY SMITH IS IN THE
GAME FOR ARIZONA.
WE ARE IN THE THIRD.
NOW IT'S DOM SMITH.
WE ARE TALKING TO STEPHEN VOGT
ON YOUTUBE TODAY.
WE SAW 10 RUNS IN THE FIRST
COUPLE INNINGS.
IS IT JUST ONE OF THOSE DAYS?
DOES IT FEEL LIKE A HITTER'S
DAY?
ROOF CLOSED IN ARIZONA THIS
AFTERNOON.
STEPHEN: YEAH, IT KIND OF
STARTED OUT THAT WAY.
WE WERE JOKING AROUND ABOUT THE
PACE OF PLAY.
WE WERE OFF TO A HOT START SO
FAR TODAY.
IT IS FUNNY WHEN YOU GET GAMES
LIKE THAT.
YOU PUT UP A FOUR SPOT AND WE
ARE ABLE TO PUNCH THEM BACK.
THAT IS WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO.
THAT GETS EVERYBODY TO GET BACK
INTO THE GAME, BACK ON YOUR TOES
AND READY TO GO.
I DON'T THINK THE PACE OF THE
GAME WILL CONTINUE THAT WAY, BUT
YOU NEVER KNOW.
IT COULD BE ONE OF THOSE DAYS.
SCOTT: WIDE OPEN LEFT SIDE FOR
DOM SMITH TO COME THROUGH.
A ONE OUT BASE RUNNER FOR NEW
YORK.
WE CHECK OUT SOME PITCHING
INJURIES FOR ARIZONA.
WEAVER, WIDENER.
WE SAW A BULLPEN SESSION FOR ZAC
GALLEN THE OTHER DAY.
HOW FUN IS IT TO CATCH ZAC
GALLEN?
THIS IS A STUD STARTER MISSING
IN ACTION FOR ARIZONA.
PITCHABILITY STUFF IS OFF THE
CHARTS.
STEPHEN: HE IS AN ABSOLUTE TREAT
TO CATCH.
I'VE SEEN VERY FEW PEOPLE,
ESPECIALLY FOR AS YOUNG AS HE
IS, THAT PUT THE TIME AND THE
FOCUS.
HE KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT HE'S DOING
WITH EVERY PITCH.
HE WANTS TO MAKE EVERY PITCH
PERFECT.
HE'S GOT FOUR LEGITIMATE, BONA
FIDE PITCHES.
HE WILL BE A GOOD PITCHER FOR A
LONG TIME IN THIS LEAGUE.
IN MY OPINION, HE'S A TOP OF THE
ROTATION ARM THAT HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WIN CY YOUNGS.
IT HAS BEEN FUN TO CATCH HIM.
SCOTT: SMITH IS ON FIRST.
ONE OUT.
BRANDON DRURY TAKES A STRIKE.
TALKING TO STEPHEN VOGT.
LET'S GET TO SOME YOUTUBE
CREATOR QUESTIONS.
AUSTIN STARTS US OFF.
YOU HAVE TO PLAY A THREE ON
THREE BASKETBALL GAME.
WHICH TEAMMATES ARE YOU TAKING
TO PLAY WITH YOU?
STEPHEN: OH, MAN.
RIGHT OFF THE BAT, NICK AHMED.
THIS IS ONE OF THE BEST ATHLETES
I'VE EVER PLAYED WITH.
I THINK HE SAID HE ENDED UP
SCORING 38 POINTS IN A HIGH
SCHOOL GAME.
HE WOULD BE MY NUMBER ONE PICK.
THEN PROBABLY TIM LOCASTRO
BECAUSE NO ONE WOULD BE ABLE TO
GUARD HIM.
WE WOULD GIVE HIM THE BALL AND
HE WOULD RUN BY EVERYBODY.
THOSE ARE THE TWO MORE ATHLETIC
GUYS ON THIS TEAM.
SCOTT: GREAT CHOICES.
WE ARE LOOKING AT LOCASTRO RIGHT
NOW.
BEST SPRINT SPEED IN ALL OF
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
2-1 TO DRURY.
SKIED.
WALKER WILL CLEAR SOME SPACE AND
HAUL IT IN.
HERE IS ONE, WHAT IS THE GO-TO
FLAVOR OF GUM?
STEPHEN: WE'VE GOT THE DOUBLE
BUBBLE PACK AND THE ORIGINAL
WATERMELON.I AM A GREEN APPLE
FAN.
GREEN APPLE GUM IS MY FAVORITE.
DON'T KNOW WHAT, JUST A BIT OF
SOUR.
ONLY LASTS FOR ABOUT 15 SECONDS
AND YOU HAVE TO GET ANOTHER
PIECE.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU HAVE TO ENJOY THE GREEN
APPLE WHILE YOU CAN.
SCOTT: A LITTLE WAKE-UP CALL,
THEN IT GOES AWAY.
STEPHEN: I'M JUST READY FOR
THESE COVID PROTOCOLS TO LOOSEN
UP SO I CAN HAVE SOME SUNFLOWER
SEEDS.
MY GOODNESS.
IT HAS BEEN OVER A YEAR SINCE WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HAVE
SUNFLOWERS -- HAVE SUNFLOWER
SEEDS.
SCOTT: I AM ROOTING FOR YOU.
YOU ARE TROOPERS IN THE DESERT.
LUIS: YOU HAVE TO PUNCH A HOLE
IN THE MASK TO SPIT THOSE SEEDS
OUT.
SCOTT: THERE IT IS.
CAN YOU TOSS THAT TO SOMEBODY?
STEPHEN: NO, THAT NETTING
HINDERS OUR ABILITY TO GIVE AWAY
SOUVENIRS.
SCOTT: HOW OFTEN DO YOU GUYS
ATTEMPT TO RACE LOCASTRO?
I WILL SAY THAT IS PROBABLY
NEVER?
STEPHEN: NEVER.
THERE IS NO NEED TO.
THIS GUY IS THE FASTEST MAN IN
BASEBALL FOR A REASON.
AS CONFIDENT AS I AM IN MY SPEED
ABILITIES, I'M NOT GOING TO
TEMPT FATE AND ASK TIM LOCASTRO
TO RACE.
WE WILL LET HIM KEEP THAT CROWN.
SCOTT: WE SHOWED YOU A
BAREHANDED GRAB ON THE SLOW
ROLLER.
THIS ONE IS A FLOATER.
PAVIN SMITH MAKES THE CATCH.
PRETTY CLEAN INNING.
SMITH IS STRANDED.
THANKS FOR THE TIME.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
STEPHEN VOGT HANGING WITH USRILE
AND PITCHES A SCORELESS THIRD.
>> 2-2.
A LITTLE ARM SIDE RUN.
WHAT A PLAY AT THIRD BY JONATHAN
VILLAR!
>> VILLAR CRANKS ONE DEEP TO
CENTER.
AT THE WALL AND TOWARDS THE
APPLE.
>> STAYS FAIR.
IT IS A HIT.
THEY ARE LETTING IT ROLL.
IT IS GOING TO STOP.
IT IS A FAIR BALL NEXT TO THIRD
BASE.
>> THIS ONE TO A WIDE OPEN
SPACE.
MCCANN WITH A GREAT DIVING STOP.
>> MCCANN DRIVES ONE OUT TO LEFT
FIELD.
TAPIA GOING BACK.
WARNING TRACK AT THE WALL.
IT'S OUT OF HERE.
JAMES MCCANN, NUMBER THREE
HITTER AND FIRST BASEMAN, HITS A
HOME RUN.
>> FLIES INTO LEFT.
AND THE BALLGAME IS OVER.
METS TAKE 3 OUT OF FOUR FOR THE
ROCKIES.
>> STRUCK HIM OUT WITH A
CHANGEUP.
SIX STRIKEOUTS ON THE NIGHT.
HE HAS RETIRED EIGHT IN A ROW.
STRIKE THREE CALLED.
>> STRUCK HIM OUT.
>> THREE IN A ROW FOR DEGROM,
NINE FOR THE NIGHT.
SCOTT: LAST OF THE THIRD HERE AT
CHASE FIELD.
IN CASE YOU ARE GOING, WAIT, WHY
IS HE BRINGING UP FIVE POINT
VIDS, WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE?
THESE ARE YOUTUBE CREATOR'S
JOINING US, ALONG WITH THE MLB
ACCOUNT, METS AND TOM AND BACKS
CHANNEL -- AND DIAMONDBACKS
CHANNEL.
YOU CAN CHECK OUR LIVE GAME
COMMENTARY FEATURING YOUTUBE
CREATORS.
YOU CAN SEE THAT CHAT GOING ON
RIGHT NOW.
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS, AND THE
POLLS AS WELL.
LET'S WRAP UP OUR FIRST POLL.
JOHN FRANCO SAYING IT WAS ALL
ME.
THE FIRST PITCH IS SWUNG ON BY
PAVIN SMITH.
HE IS RETIRED BY A GROUND BALL
IN THE THIRD.
51% OF THE AUDIENCE THANKS
MARIANO RIVERA IS THE GUY.
THE DIAMONDBACKS ACCOUNT SAYS
OH, THE GUY THAT GAVE UP A HIT
THAT WON US THE WORLD SERIES IS
IN THE POLL.
THAT IS A STRONG COMEBACK.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN: STILL HOLDING THAT GRUDGE.
LUIS: IT GOES TO SHOW JOHNNY
FRANCO'S FRATERNITY IS STILL
GOING STRONG.
JOHN: THAT WAS ALL RELIEF PITCH
ES.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: STRONG NEW YORK AUDIENCE
TODAY.
THEY KNOW WHAT MARIANO RIVERA
DID IN NYC FOR MANY YEARS,
SHUTTING TEAMS DOWN IN BIG
MOMENTS.
JOHN: GSELLMAN HAS SETTLED IN
WELL.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO
DO, MAKE SURE THEY STAY AHEAD OF
THE HITTERS, KEEP THE GAME
MOVING.
SCOTT: HE'S AHEAD OF AHMED.
LUIS: IF GSELLMAN CAN TAKE THEM
DEEPER IN THE GAME, THE METS
LEAVE AFTER THE GAME AND HEAD
OVER TO SAN DIEGO, WHICH SHOULD
BE A BIG SERIES FOR THE PADRES
AND THE METS.
JOHN: THAT IS A FOUR GAME
SERIES.
IT WILL BE A LONG WEEKEND.
SCOTT: A LOT OF THE PADRES
COMING UP FOR NEW YORK.
THEY ARE ON THEIR SECOND
NINE-GAME TRIP OF THE SEASON.
GSELLMAN'S PART OF THIS
NOTABLE RELIEF THAT HAS BEEN
EFFECTIVE SO FAR.
TREVOR MAY IS IN A RUT AT THE
MOMENT.
THERE IS CASTRO AND LOUP.
FAMILIA HAS BEEN FANTASTIC THIS
YEAR.
SEAN REID-FOLEY RECENTLY SENT
BACK DOWN.
JOHN: WHAT A DIFFERENCE A YEAR
MAKES.
LAST YEAR THEY STRUGGLED.
SCOTT: NINTH IN BASEBALL, AROUND
3.5 WITH THAT MARK IF YOU LOOK
AT THE PAST.
LUIS: THAT DRASTIC CHANGE SHOWS
YOU WHY THEY ARE ONE OF THE
LEADERS IN THE LEAGUE RIGHT NOW.
SCOTT: VILLAR PUTS AWAY AHMED.
THIS COPYRIGHTED TELECAST IS
PRESENTED WITH AUTHORITY OF THE
OFFICE OF THE COMMISSIONER OF
BASEBALL AND MAY NOT BE
REPRODUCED OR RETRANSMITTED IN
ANY FORM.
THE ACCOUNTS AND DESCRIPTIONS OF
THIS GAME MAY NOT BE
DISSEMINATED WITHOUT EXPRESS
WRITTEN CONSENT.
TWO OUTS.
HERE IS VARGAS, WHO KNOCKED IN
TWO RUNS IN THE FIRST WITH HIS
BASE HIT.
ALL THE BULLPEN TALK AND A GUY
WHO WAS NOT ON THAT LIST WHO
COULD BE PITCHING TODAY LATER IN
THE GAME IS SETH LUGO, WHO HAS
BEEN ONE OF THEIR BEST RELIEVERS
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL SEASONS.
JOHN: ABSOLUTELY.
HE HAS BEEN THE MOST CONSISTENT
GUY IN THE BULLPEN THAT WENT
FROM STARTER TO RELIEVER.
FINALLY HE'S IN THE BULLPEN.
HE IS HEALTHY NOW.
I AM PRETTY SURE WE WILL SEE
SETH SOMETIME TODAY.
SCOTT: HE FINISHED LAST YEAR AS
A STARTER, BUT BACK IN OF RELIEF
ROLE.
-- IN A RELIEF ROLE.
JOHN: UNFORTUNATELY SYNDERGAARD
AND CARRASCO HURT.
THEY WOULD BE IN THE ROTATION.
SCOTT: SOME METS FANS WERE
WONDERING IF THEY WERE GOING TO
SEE HIM YESTERDAY IN THE LATE
STAGES.
JOHN: I THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO
COME IN A GAME YESTERDAY MYSELF.
TREVOR MAY HAD A REAL TOUGH
INNING THE NIGHT BEFORE.
LAST NIGHT HE STRUGGLED A LITTLE
BIT.
SETH LUGO WAS READY TO GO.
SCOTT: DO YOU THINK THEY WERE
SAVING HIM FOR A LESS STRESSFUL
INNING TO START OFF HIS SEASON?
JOHN: HE HAS BEEN AROUND FOR A
WHILE.
I DON'T THINK YOU HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT STRESSFUL WITH SETH.
HE'S GOT GOOD STUFF.
SCOTT: THREE GROUND BALLS IN THE
INNING.
THAT ONE TURNED NICELY BY
GSELLMAN.
BAREHAND.
ABOUT-FACE.
GSELLMAN, THREE UP, THREE DOWN
IN THE THIRD.
ONE MORE TIME.
WHAT DID YOU SAY?
JOHN: BEST ATHLETES ON THE
FIELD.
LUIS: WE WILL TALK ABOUT THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
♪
>> I'M SO EXCITED TO BE HERE.
>> WANT TO HEAR THE MOST
ANNOYING SOUND IN THE WORLD?
AHHHHHH!
>
SCOTT: NEXT FOUR QUESTIONS ON
THE PHONE'S PLAYER IN THE SPORT
RIGHT NOW.
--FUNNIEST PLAYER IN THE SPORT
FUNNIEST PLAYER IN BASEBALL
RIGHT NOW.
THERE ARE YOUR OPTIONS.
DIAMONDBACKS FANS ARE GOING TO
GO HARD FOR VOGT.
ROBERT GSELLMAN CONTINUES
ANOTHER ADVANTAGE HE HAS PITCHED
WELL SO FAR IN SOME LONG RELIEF
FOR NEW YORK.
JOHN: THAT IS WHAT LUIS ROJAS
WAS HOPING.
LONG WEEKEND AHEAD OF THEM.
SCOTT: JUST LIKE HE PRODUCES AS
A PITCHER, AND HE IS 0-2 TODAY.
FUNNIEST PLAYER OF THOSE FOUR.
JOHN CAN YOU FIRST.
JOHN: I KIND OF LIKE HARRY
CARAY.
SCOTT: LUIS?
LUIS: HE HAS ALWAYS BEEN FUNNY
WITH THAT STUFF  I WAS
TRYING TO THINK BACK THAT WHEN
WE PLAYED WITH THESE GUYS, THE
CANCER CHARACTERS, YOU ALWAYS
HAD THE -- CAST OF CHARACTERS,
YOU ALWAYS HAD A FUNNY GUY IN
THE LOCKER ROOM, BUT HE ALWAYS
HOPED HE COULD PRODUCE A LITTLE
BIT, TOO.
THESE GUYS HAVE ALL BEEN ABLE TO
PRODUCE.
HOLLINS IS PROBABLY MY PICK.
SCOTT: EXCELLENT BROADCASTER,
THAT DEREK COLLINS.
OLD-SCHOOL HARRY CARAY STYLE.
LET OF SNOW.
CHIME IN.
-- LET US KNOW.
WE WILL DO OUR PLAYER OF THE
GAME POLE ON-- POLL ON YOUTUBE.
LUIS: JOHNNY, I'M CURIOUS TO
SHOOT WAS YOUR FUNNY GUY WHEN
YOU GUYS PLAYED FOR A LONG TIME?
JOHN: THERE WAS A BIG, TALL
PITCHER, ERIC KELMAN.
HE WAS PRETTY FUNNY IN THE
LOCKER ROOM.
WE HAD A COUPLE -- I WAS PRETTY
FUNNY, BUT YOU KNOW, WHEN I HAD
TO BE.
LUIS: YOU HAD A LOT OF FREE
TIME.
ALL YOU HAD TO DO IS SHOW UP TO
WORK IN THE NINTH INNING AND YOU
WERE OK.
JOHN: BEST JOB IN BASEBALL, 9:50
TO 10:00 EVERY NIGHT.
[LAUGHTER]
LUIS: I HAD A MARK GRANT WHEN I
WAS A YOUNG PLAYER, A
BROADCASTER WITH THE PADRES.
HE USED TO DO THIS UMPIRE STOOD.
IT WAS AMAZING.
JOHN: HE DID ALL THE UMPIRES, I
REMEMBER THAT.
SCOTT: NICE LEAPING GRAB A BIKE
ESCOBAR TO RETIRE VILLAR.
LINDOR IS LOVING D-BACKS
PITCHING TO SEASON AND WE ARE
LOVING THAT HE IS MIC'D UP.
>> HOW YOU DOING?
I GOT THAT MIC TODAY.
YEAH, I'M MIC'D UP.
HEY, HEY.
THE FAST ONE IS OVERPOWERING.
SCOTT: THAT IS THE GOOD STUFF,
LUIS.
HE WAS TALKING TO PILLAR ABOUT
THE FASTBALL FROM MADISON
BUMGARNER, WHO IS OUT OF THE
GAME.
BUNT DOWN FROM LINDOR AND HE
WILL RACE OVER TO FIRST AND BEAT
THE THROW.
FRANCISCO LINDOR WITH THE BUNT
SINGLE WITH TWO OUTS IN THE
FOURTH.
LUIS: THIS IS ANOTHER TOOL THIS
GUY CAN HURT YOU WITH.
HE'S GOT SPEED, PLACE FANTASTIC
DEFENSE, HAS POWERFUL  YOU
SEE HIM GETTING A GOOD BUNT
DOWN.
JOHN: I WANT TO SAY IN THE LAST
WEEK OR SO, HE'S DONE THAT THREE
OR FOUR TIMES ALREADY AND GOTTEN
A COUPLE OF HITS OUT OF IT.
THAT WILL HELP HIM RAISE HIS
AVERAGE A LITTLE MORE AND BUILD
MORE CONFIDENCE IN HIM.
TEAMS KEEP GIVING IT TO HIM.
WHY NOT TAKE IT?
LUIS: AND YOU KNOW, NEW YORK
CITY, IF YOU DON'T COME OUT OF
THE GATES PRODUCING, THEY ARE
GOING TO GET ON YOU ANYWAY, AND
NOW HE IS STARTING TO SETTLE IN
A LITTLE BIT.
YOU WILL SEE THE NUMBERS GO BACK
TO WHERE THEY NORMALLY ARE.
HE GOT OUT OF THE GATES A LITTLE
SLOW TRYING TO DO TOO MUCH FOR A
NEW TEAM.
JOHN: ABSOLUTELY.
I TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU.
SCOTT: JAMES MCCANN GOES AFTER
THE FIRST PITCH.
IT IS THE SEEING-EYE SINGLE FOR
JAMES MCCANN.
TWO AVOID FOR NEW YORK.-- TWO
ABORD FOR NEW YORK FULL -- TWO
ABOARD FOR NEW YORK.
JOHN: LOOKS LIKE A SHIFT HIT
RIGHT THERE.
LUIS: YEAH.
MCCANN IS LOVING IT RIGHT NOW.
HE IS HAVING A THREE-FOR-THREE
DAY.
HE HOPES THIS GOES ALL DAY LONG.
JOHN: GETTING HIS GROOVE BACK.
SCOTT: TWO SINGLES AND A
THREE-RUN HOMER FOR JAMES
MCCANN.
CLEANUP HITTER PETE ALONSO WITH
TWO ABOARD.
PETE'S 1-2.
SINGLED IN THE FIRST, STRUCK OUT
IN THE SECOND.
HE WAS THE LAST BATTER THAN
BUMGARNER FACED.
RILEY SMITH REPLACING HIM AND
TRYING TO WORK THROUGH THIS FOR.
26-YEAR-OLD ON THE MOUND, PICKED
UP HIS FIRST CAREER SAVE ON
SUNDAY, FINAL THREE INNINGS
AGAINST THE CARDINALS IN A 9-2
WIN.
THAT WIN MEANT SOMETHING FOR
THIS HOME BALLCLUB.
IT SNAPPED A 13-GAME LOSING
SKID, AND MANAGER TOREY LOVULLO
SAID THERE WAS SOME CELEBRATING
GOING ON.
OF COURSE, THE LONG ROAD AHEAD
FOR THIS TEAM, BUT THEY WERE
FIGHTING, AND THEY FOUND A
VICTORY AGAINST A GOOD BALLCLUB
IN THE NL CENTRAL ON SUNDAY.
JOHN: ALWAYS SEEMS LIKE WHEN YOU
ARE STRUGGLING, YOU'RE PLAYING
THE HOT TEAMS.
CARDINALS ARE A GOOD TEAM.
METS COME IN, LOOKING FOR THE
WEAKER TEAMS TO HELP YOU GET
OVER THE HUMP.
LOSING 13 A ROW IS A TOUGH WAY
TO COME TO THE BALLPARK EVERY
DAY, BUT HE GOT TO KEEP
BATTLING.
IT IS A LONG SEASON.
SCOTT: THE D-BACKS MOVE ON TO
MILWAUKEE STARTING TOMORROW.
NOT AN EASY TEAM TO FACE WITH
THEIR STARTING LINEUP, OR THEIR
STARTING ROTATION, I SHOULD SAY,
EVEN MORE SO.
LET'S BRING YOU BACK TO MONDAY.
PETE ALONSO SAID NO REHAB
ASSIGNMENT, NO PROBLEM.
FOUR R.B.I.'S FOR PETE.
WELCOME BACK.
LUIS: THAT HOMER RIGHT THERE, I
WAS HERE THAT NIGHT.
IT WAS HAMMERED WAY UP THERE.
SCOTT: HE SPRAINED HIS RIGHT
HAND AND WAS PLACED ON THE SHELF
ON MAY 18.
HE HAD BEEN STRUGGLING AND
TRYING TO PLAY THROUGH THE
INJURY, AND THE METS SAID TAKE A
BREAK AND HE IS BACK IN A BIG
WAY.
LUIS: YOU GOTTA THINK, THE METS
ARE GOING TO BE THERE.
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE MCNEIL,
CONFORTO.
THEY HAVE HAD KEY INJURIES TO A
LOT OF GUYS.
NOW THEY GET ALONSO BACK.
THESE GUYS ARE GOING TO BE IN
THE MIX AT THE END OF THE YEAR.
THEY ARE GOING TO MAKE SOME
NOISE.
THEIR BULLPEN IS DOING
FANTASTIC.
THEY HAVE GOT GOOD STARTING
PITCHING.
JOHN: THE OTHER THING IS THE NL
EAST IS STRUGGLING -- THE
PHILLIES, THE NATIONALS, THE
BRAVES, THE MARLINS.
GOT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT.
LUIS: AND YOU HAVE A NEW OWNER
THAT WANTS TO WIN, AND HE HAS
EXCITED ALL THE FANS IN THE
CITY, BECAUSE HE KNOWS YOU ARE
COMPETING AGAINST THE YANKEES
DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
THEY WANT TO PUT A WINNER BACK
OUT ON THE FIELD.
PAY THE EXTRA MONEY TO GET A GUY
LIKE LINDOR AND ADD THE PIECES
THEY NEED.
YOU KNOW THAT IF THEY ARE IN
CONTENTION, THEY ARE GOING TO GO
OUT THE TRADE DEADLINE AND GET
SOMETHING.
SCOTT: STATCAST, POWERED BY
GOOGLE CLOUD, SETTING US UP WITH
PETE ALONSO'S 450-PLUS BOMBS
SINCE 2018.
HE HAS DONE IT NINE TIMES.
TIED FOR SECOND BEST IN MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL.
BIG, STRONG, IDEAL CLEANUP
HITTER IN THE GAME.
JOHN: HE LOVES COMING TO THE
BALLPARK AND HE HAS FUN.
HE IS A GREAT TEAMMATE.
SCOTT: HAD A DREAM ROOKIE
SEASON.
ALL-STAR, HOME RUN DERBY CHAMPA,
53 HOMERS.
IT SETS UP FOR ESCOBAR TO PUT IT
AWAY.
AT 5-5.
RILEY SMITH SUPERSTITIOUS.
>> SINCE I WAS THREE YEARS OLD,
ALL I EVER WANTED TO BE WAS A
BASEBALL PLAYER.
I LOVE IT SO MUCH.
>> THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ENJOY
WHAT THEY DO FOR A LIVING, AND
THEN THERE IS PETE ALONSO.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT THE
PASSION WILL EVER GO.
PEOPLE WILL HAVE TO RIP THIS
DAMN JERSEY OFF ME.
>> ALONSO PRECIOUS INTERVIEWS
WITH THE SAME INTENSITY HE
CRUSHES BASEBALLS, AND PLANS TO
ATTACK THE NEXT DECADE AND A
HALF LIKE A MAN SHORT ON TIME.
>> IN MOST PROFESSIONS, IF YOU
HAVE A DOCTOR OR A LAWYER AND
THEY TRULY LOVE IT, THEY CAN
PRACTICE UNTIL THEY DIE.
FOR ME, I CAN'T DO THAT.
I HAVE A SHORT WINDOW.
I WANT TO MAXIMIZE MY TIME.
>> ALONSO AIMS TO SQUEEZE EVERY
LAST TOP OUT OF HIS TIME, HIS
SKILLS, AND HIS PLATFORM.
>> I WANT TO BE A GOOD PERSON, I
WANT TO BE A GOOD DUDE, I WANT
TO BE A HUMAN FIRST BEFORE
BASEBALL PLAYER.
WITH THE PLATFORM, IF YOU ARE
NOT IMPACTING PEOPLE IN A
POSITIVE WAY, YOU AREN'T DOING
IT RIGHT.
SCOTT: WE ARE IN THE HOME
FOURTH, KNOTTED UP AT 5.
EACH WEEK ON OUR YOU TO
BROADCAST WE WILL FOCUS ON THE
CONTENT CREATOR.
OUR CREATOR SPOTLIGHT SHINES ON
LIGHTSKINCHRIS.
HE COVERS ALL THINK MLB.
HIS MAIN GOAL, GROW THE GAME.
LOVE THAT.
OVER 20,000 SUBSCRIBERS ON HIS
YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
SAY HELLO TO US, CHRIS.
HE IS A BIG MIKE TROUT FAN.
SEEN SOME OF HIS WORK PLAYING
MLB THE SHOW ON YOUTUBE.
VERY ENTERTAINING FELLOW.
ALL OF THOSE YOUTUBE CREATORS
ARE SPENDING TIME WITH US TODAY
IN THE LIVE CHAT, CONTRIBUTING
QUESTIONS.
INCLUDING ON THE POSTGAME SHOW,
30 MINUTES DEDICATED TO THE
DIAMONDBACKS AND THE METS.
2 2/3 OF SCORELESS BASEBALL.
GETS READY TO WORK IN THE
D-BACKS' FOURTH.
LOCASTRO IN THE PITCHER'S SPOT
AND THE TOP OF THE LINEUP.
RILEY SMITH BEHIND LOCASTRO IN
THE LAST SHOT.
LONG MAN FOR THE DIAMONDBACKS
LOOKS LIKE HE IS GOING TO
CONTINUE.
LUIS: I THINK BOTH MANAGERS ARE
GOING TO STICK WITH THEIR GUYS,
BECAUSE THEY WILL ALL THE OTHER
TEAMS DOWN-- HOLD THE OTHER
TEAMS DOWN.
JOHN: ROJAS IS HOPING THAT
GSELLMAN WILL GET THROUGH THIS.
CASTRO, MAYBE ONE OF THOSE GUYS
WILL COME IN NEXT.
SCOTT: THIS IS THE RUBBER MATCH
IN THIS SERIES.
DIAMONDBACKS TAKING A NEXT WAS.
STRIKING DOWN THE PIPE TO
LOCASTRO.
NEED A NEW ONE.
LUIS: NICE PIECE OF FIREWOOD
THAT YOU DON'T NEED TO USE IN
ARIZONA.
YOU SEE THE RUN ON THAT BALL
JUST COME RIGHT IN ON HIS HANDS.
JOHN: GOT A GOOD TWO-SEAMER.
LUIS: MAN, IT'S HARD.
ONCE YOU COMMIT TO THAT PITCH,
IT IS HARD TO DRAW YOUR HANDS.
YOU COULD SEE LOCASTRO WAS
TRYING TO DO IT BUT HE COULDN'T
GET IT IN FAR ENOUGH.
SCOTT: THERE IT IS AGAIN.
JOHN: THOSE ARE TWO BALLS OUT OF
THE ZONE.
IN THE ZONE, IN THE ZONE, AND
THEN LAST-MINUTE IT BREAKS.
SCOTT: THAT WENT A BIT MORE OVER
THE PLATE, BUT HE GOT IT TO FLY
OUT TO RIGHT.
LUIS: THAT'S A BIG -- YEAH,
THAT'S A BIG FIRST OUT.
YOU KEEP ONE OF THE SPEEDIEST
GUYS IN BASEBALL WITH THE
PITCHER COMING UP.
SCOTT: RILEY SMITH 0-10 THE
SEASON.
NASH THIS SEASON.
--THIS SEASON.
LOCASTRO IN THE EIGHT SPOT, THEY
CALL HIM THE WORLD'S FASTEST
HUMAN IN ARIZONA.
GOT THE GEAR, THE MERCHANDISE,
THE WHOLE THING.
JOHN: DOES LOCASTRO KNOW HOW TO
BUNT?
LUIS: HE DOES.
AND THAT AMAZES ME SOMETIMES, A
LOT OF THE PLAYERS DON'T REALLY
USE IT AS MUCH.
YOU SAW LINDOR DO IT.
THERE YOU SEE THE STRIKEOUT.
BUT LINDOR KNOWS HOW TO UTILIZE
HIS GAME.
HE IS A HOME RUN HITTER, BUT IF
YOU ARE GOING TO GET YOU A BUNT
SINGLE, ESPECIALLY GUYS IN THE
LINEUP.
YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE TO DRAG BUNT
YOU CAN PUSH IT BETWEEN FIRST
AND SECOND BASE WASN'T YOU KNOW
YOU ARE GOING TO BEAT HIM
BECAUSE HE IS ONE OF THE FASTEST
GUYS IN THE GAME.
IT DON'T UTILIZE IT AS MUCH AS
THEY USED TO.
SCOTT: TIM LOCASTRO HAS ONE
CAREER BUNTED.
-- CAREER BUNT HIT.
BY THE WAY, THAT WAS THE FIRST
STRIKEOUT FROM METS PITCHING
THIS AFTERNOON.
COMES IN THE FOURTH INNING FROM
GSELLMAN, WHO IS PAINTING.
LUIS: JOHNNY, YOU THINK IF HE
GETS TO THE INNING THEY STRETCH
HIM OUT ONE MORE?
JOHN: I WOULD.
I WOULD TRY TO GET AS MUCH OUT
OF HIM AS POSSIBLE.
FOR SIGN OF TROUBLE, BRING
SOMEBODY IN.
-- FIRST SIGN OF TROUBLE, BRING
LUIS: I AGREE WITH YOU.
I THINK WITH ALL THE MOVEMENT HE
HAS HAD, HE HAS GIVING SOME FITS
TO THE D-BACKS HITTERS.
SCOTT: THERE IS DRURY.
LOOK AT GSELLMAN GO, AS HE
RETIRES THREE AND A ROW AGAIN IN
THE FOURTH.
HE IS ON A ROLL.
>> HE JUSTIN SMOAK SAID.
-- HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> GREAT BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
>> THAT IS GOING TO GO.
>> THAT BALL WAS CRUSHED.
>> HE'S GOING TO DO IT.
>> STRIKE THREE.
THAT IS A GREAT PLAY.
TALKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS.
THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
SCOTT: MLB ORIGINAL SEASON T
LIVE EVERY WEEK.
SEE MORE ABOUT THE GAME YOU
LOVE ON YOUTUBE.COM/MLB.
KEVIN PILLAR IS BACK IN THE
STARTING LINEUP FOR THE FIRST
TIME SINCE MID-MAY.
THIS WAS UGLY.
HIT BY A PITCH, 95 MILES AN
HOUR.
HE SUFFERED SOME FACIAL
FRACTURES.
THIS COULD BE A DOCUMENTARY, THE
SEASON OF KEVIN PILLAR, AND
INSPIRATION.
NEW YORK CITY LOVES TOUGH,
GRITTY COMPETITORS.
THIS GUY IS AT THE TOP OF THE
LIST.
HE SHOWS UP THE NEXT DAY
JOKINGLY ASKING TO BE IN THE
LINEUP.
TALKING TO EVERYONE ABOUT HOW HE
FELT FORTUNATE THE BASEBALL
ENDED UP WHERE IT DID.
TWO INCHES LEFT OR RIGHT, TWO
INCHES HIGHER.
LOOK AT HIM AGAIN.
2-3.
JOHN: THE THING ABOUT HIM IS HE
IS A GREAT TEAM AND THE GUYS ON
THE TEAM LOVE HIM.
HE IS A THROWBACK.
HE WAS PART OF MY TEAM WENT I
PLAYED.
HE COMES TO THE BALLPARK
PREPARED TO PLAY.
HE WAS DOWN 36 SECONDS WHEN HE
WALKED OFF ON HIS OWN POWER.
IN HOSPITAL, TWEETING OUT HE
WILL BE FINE.
GREAT PLAYER, GOOD GUY, CAN PLAY
ALL THE OUTFIELD POSITIONS,
VETERAN GUY WHO KNOWS HIS ROLE.
LUIS: YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT,
JOHNNY, AND YOU CAN TELL THE
TYPE OF GUY HE IS.
HE WAS MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PITCHER ON THE ATLANTA BRAVES
TEAM AND HE WAS ABOUT HIS OWN
INJURY, YOU ARE GOING TO BE OK,
PART OF THE GAME.
SHOWS YOU WHAT TYPE OF GUY HE
IS.
SCOTT: JACOB WEBB, RELIEVER FOR
THE ATLANTA BRAVES, WHO FELT
TERRIBLE.
KEVIN PILLAR, VERY MUCH NOT
AFRAID.
CHANCES OF IT HAPPENING AGAIN
ARE QUITE LOW.
DOM SMITH, LEFT FIELD.
IT IS OFF LOCASTRO'S GLOVE GIVE
TO ON TO START THE FIFTH FOR THE
METS.
JOHN: DOM SMITH STARTING TO HEAT
UP A LITTLE BIT, TOO.
LUIS, I WANT TO GET BACK TO
PILLAR.
AS A HITTER, WHEN YOU GET HIT IN
THE FACE LIKE THAT, WHAT IS
GOING THROUGH YOUR MIND?
I KNOW THE ODDS OF IT HAPPENING
AGAIN IS VERY RARE, MAYBE, BUT
GOING THROUGH YOUR MIND AT THE
TIME?
LUIS: YOU'RE RIGHT.
I HAVEN'T BEEN HIT IN THE FACE
BEFORE, BUT WHEN I PLAYED, THEY
HAVE SHOULDER INJURIES AND ELBOW
, THINGS LIKE THAT, DIVING FOR
OF ALL.
WHEN YOU GET IN THE GAME,
EVERYTHING SPEEDS UP.
HE IS ON FIRE RIGHT NOW.
THREE OR FOUR HITS IN THE
SERIES.
IT IS LIKE NOTHING HAS AFFECTED
HIM.
HE IS HITTING 90-PLUS-MILE AN
HOUR FASTBALLS.
JOHN: NOT TRYING WAY FROM
NOTHING.
LUIS: THAT IS A BIG MENTAL
HURDLE BECAUSE YOU HAVE A LOT OF
TRAUMA TO YOUR BODY AND STEPPING
RIGHT BACK ON THE FEEL LIKE IT
IS NOTHING.
SCOTT: BIG CUT AND A MISS FROM
BRANDON DRURY.
PILLAR HAD HIS FIRST AT-BAT BACK
ON MONDAY.
THEY HAD TO COMPROMISE.
ONE TO BE BACK IN THE STARTING
LINEUP, WE WILL ACTIVATE YOU.
WE WILL SLOW PLAY THIS.
MONDAY WAS THE FIRST TIME HE
PARTICIPATED IN PREGAME
ACTIVITIES TO GET HIMSELF RAMPED
UP AGAIN.
DRURY CLOCKS IT, OVER SHORT COME
AND HERE COMES PILLAR.
THE METS TAKE THE LEAD BACK.
BRANDON DRURY COMES THROUGH WITH
AN R.B.I. HIT.
LUIS: THAT HAS GOT A FEEL GOOD
FOR DRURY, HIS FORMER TEAM THE
ARIZONA DIAMONDBACKS TO COME AND
GET A BIG HIT AGAINST HIM.
YOU SEE THE PITCH, RUN BACK OVER
THE MIDDLE PART OF THE PLATE
WASN'T THAT IS WHERE THE
BIG-LEAGUE HITTERS WILL MAKE YOU
PAY FOR IT.
SCOTT: GREAT READ BY PILLAR, OFF
TO THE RACES.
JOHN: THAT IS WHAT THE MET FRONT
OFFICE DID THIS OFF-SEASON, THEY
GOT VETERAN GUYS LIKE PILLAR,
LIKE DRURY, GUYS WHO WIN IN THE
BIG LEAGUES BEFORE.
SCOTT: THEY HAVE A NAME FOR
THEM, TOO.
BENCHMARK.
-- BENCH MOB.
PERAZA IS PART OF THAT GROUP.
LUIS: AND I THINK THE METS WENT
OUT AND GOT THE RIGHT PIECES.
THEY GOT BALLPLAYERS, THEY HAVE
GOT GUYS -- THEY KNOW THEIR
ROLES ON THE TEAM.
ROJAS HAS DONE A FANTASTIC JOB
WITH THE PERSONNEL HE HAS.
EACH PLAYER KNOWS WHAT THEIR
ROLE IS ON THE BALLCLUB.
SCOTT: GIVEN THE METS' STANDING
IN THE DIVISION AND THE FACT
THAT A WEEK AGO THEY HAD 17
PLAYERS ON THE INJURED LIST,
LUIS ROJAS HAS TO BE IN THE
CONVERSATION FOR MANAGER OF THE
YEAR RIGHT NOW IN THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE.
HERE IS BILLY MCKINNEY, WHO
COULD STEP UP AND THE PITCHER'S
SPOT ON PERAZA.
ON THE GROUND, COULD BE TWO.
THROW OVER TO FIRST IS IN TIME
TO DOUBLE UP PERAZA AND THE
METS.
MOVING OVER TO THIRD IS THE
SMITH.
WE WILL GET A PINCH HITTER NOW.
VARGAS TO AHMED TO WALKER.
JOHN: SCOTT, GETTING BACK TO
YOUR POINT, METS THIS YOU HAVE
USED 43 PLAYERS IN 47 GAMES.
LAST YEAR IN 2020 THEY USED 47
PLAYERS TOTAL.
SCOTT: HOW MANY GAMES WERE
PLAYED LAST YEAR?
60.
HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO.
LUIS: AND THAT JUST GOES TO SHOW
YOU THE DEPTH THAT THEY HAVE.
BRANDON DRURY, FOR INSTANCE,
SUPPOSED TO BE A CORNERSTONE
HERE, JUST COULD FIND HIS WAY,
STRUGGLING A BIT OFFENSIVELY,
GOES AND PLAYS IN DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS.
NOW HE IS ONE OF THE ROLE-PLAYS
COMING OFF THE BENCH AND FEELING
AND WHEN HE HAS TO.
ASH FILLING IN WHEN HE HAS TO.
--FILLING IN WHEN  HE HAS
TO.
SCOTT: MCKINNEY HAD A HUGE
SPRING TRAINING FOR THE
MILWAUKEE BREWERS AND HE WAS
QUIET LAST WEEK.
THERE IS DRURY WITH THE
DIAMONDBACKS.
THOSE ARE HIS BEST DAYS.
PICKED UP IN THE JUSTIN UPTON
DEAL.
THE YANKEES WERE HOT ON HIS
TRAIL FOR YEARS.
WORKING BETTER IN QUEENS.
LUIS ROJAS FOR THE NL MANAGER OF
THE YEAR IF THE SEASON
ENDED TODAY?
JOHN: HE WOULD GET MY VOTE.
MY SON PLAYED IN THE MINOR
LEAGUES FOR THE METS AND LUIS
WAS HIS MANAGER FOR YEAR.
JUST LIKE HIS DAD,
MILD-MANNERED, HAS THE RESPECT
OF HIS PLAYERS.
BEEN IN THE ORGANIZATION FOR A
LONG TIME.
SCOTT: ONLY 39 YEARS OLD.
LUIS: HE HAS PUT HIS TIME IN.
A LOT OF THE CORNERSTONE PLAYERS
ON THIS METS TEAM HAVE COME
THROUGH THE METS SYSTEM.
HE IS FAMILIAR WITH A LOT OF THE
PLAYERS BUT THERE'S THE COMFORT
FACTOR THAT HE HAS FOR A LOT OF
THE GUYS ON THE TEAM.
THE SECOND YOUNGEST MANAGER.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING.
HE HAS BEEN AROUND THE BLOCK FOR
A LOT OF THESE GUYS.
THAT IS WHY YOU SEE HIM PLAYING
HARD FOR HIM.
SCOTT: HIS FATHER WAS A PRETTY
GOOD SKIPPER, TOO.
JOHN: AND THEY WENT OUT AND GOT
-- I'M SORRY --THE BENCH COACH
--
LUIS: NO, NO --
JOHN: LUIS GREW UP WITH
HIM A LITTLE BIT.
HE KNOWS HIM A LONG TIME.
LUIS: YOU SPIN AROUND -- HE HAS
BEEN AROUND.
LUIS HAS COME FROM A GOOD
BASEBALL FAMILY, TOO.
HE HAS GROWN UP WITH THAT IN HIS
HOUSEHOLD.
SCOTT: DIDN'T MAKE IT FAR AS A
PLAYER, BUT VERY YOUNG MANAGER
IN THE D -- IN THE METS' MINOR
LEAGUE SYSTEM.
HE HAS PUT IN HIS TIME.
LUIS: WE ALL KNOW AS BASEBALL
PEOPLE WHEN YOU ARE A D METS OR
YANKEES MANAGER, YOU ARE IN THE
HOT SEAT FROM DAY ONE.
YOU ARE IN THE MECCA SO EVERYONE
IS WATCHING YOU CONSTANTLY.
AT HIS AGE BEING THE MANAGER OF
A BIG TEAM LIKE THAT, IT SHOWS
HE IS BASEBALL SAVVY AND READY
TO TAKE OVER THAT JOB.
JOHN: HE HAS THE SAME DEMEANOR
EVERY DAY.
SCOTT: BILLY MCKINNEY IS PUTTING
TOGETHER QUITE THE BATTLE RIGHT
NOW.
BACK TO MONDAY.
BILLY MCKINNEY.
GOOD WORK BY G.M.'S ACTS GOT TO
PICK HIM UP.
LAST WEEK IN HIS METS DEBUT, HE
IS IN THE CLEANUP SPOT.
IT WAS ONCE A PRETTY HIGHLY
REGARDED PROSPECT, PLAYS A SOLID
OUTFIELD.
ON THE GROUND.
NICE DIVING STOP AT FIRST BY
WALKER.
AND THE METS DO GET ONE ACROSS
IN THE FIFTH.
IT IS KEVIN PILLAR BACK IN THE
STARTING NINE TODAY.
THE SINGLE AND THEN DRURY BRINGS
HIM HOME.
METS DIAMONDBACKS 5, ON
YOUTUBE.
>> WE ARE HEADING TO THE NINTH
INNING.
HE HAS RETIRED 24 CONSECUTIVE
BATTERS, SO WE HAS THE BOTTOM
THREE HITTERS IN THE LINEUP TO
FACE AGAINST THE INDIANS.
SWING AND A HIGHFLYING BALL
TOWARDS LEFT CENTER FIELD.
JACKSON ON THE RUN, STILL GOING.
HE MAKES THE CATCH!
OH, MY GOODNESS.
YOUR IS THE ONE TO.
BOUNCING BALL TO SHORT.
TWO OUTS.
GROUNDBALL, RIGHT SIDE.
HE IS SAFE.
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
>> BOUNCING BALL, LEFT SIDE.
NEVER BEEN THIS DISAPPOINTED
AFTER A TIGERS WIN.
WHAT AN OUTSTANDING PERFORMANCE
TONIGHT.
I FEEL FOR YOU.
SCOTT: LET'S PUT A LID ON THE
LATEST POLL QUESTION.
FUNNIEST PLAYER IN BASEBALL --
OOH, TIGHT RACE.
BRETT PHILLIPS COMES OUT ON TOP.
HUGE MOMENT IN THE WORLD SERIES
FOR TAMPA BAY.
BRENT SUTER WITH HIS "DUMB AND
DUMBER" IMPRESSION COMING OUT IN
FOURTH PLACE.
MORE POLLS LATER INCLUDING THE
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
LOOK WHO IS BACK FOR NEW YORK.
SETH LUGO ON THE MOUND FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN 2021, AS WE GET A
GLANCE AT HIS 2020 NUMBERS.
HE MAKES HIS SEASON DEBUT RIGHT
NOW.
JOHN: SET IS COMING BACK FROM
THE LITTLE ELBOW SURGERY.
BOWEN SPURS IN HIS ELBOW.
PASSED BALL AND THE UPPER 90'S,
GREAT OVERHAND CURVEBALL.
HE IS ANOTHER COMPETITOR.
HE CAN GIVE YOU MULTIPLE
INNINGS.
SCOTT: STARTS KETEL MARTE WITH
THE STRIKE.
2, 3, AND 4 IN THE ORDER FOR
ARIZONA.
10 RUNS IN THE FIRST TWO INNINGS
COMBINED FOR THESE TEAMS.
BATS HAVE COOLED A BIT SINCE
THEN.
THERE IS THE CURVEBALL FROM LUGO
.
GSELLMAN WAS FANTASTIC.
IN RELIEF OF DAVE PETERSON, WHO
DIDN'T HAVE HIS GOOD STUFF
TODAY.
JOHN: I'M SURE SETH HAS GOT A
LITTLE ADRENALINE FLOWING RIGHT
NOW, SITTING OUT MOST OF THE
SEASON, WAITING FOR THIS MOMENT
TO COME BACK TO THE BIG LEAGUES.
SCOTT: YOU SEE THE WAY HE DANCES
AROUND WITH HIS LEFT FOOT AND
THEN FIRES.
MARTE SENDS IT IN THE AIR.
VILLAR MAKING THE CATCH.
THERE IS ONE AWAY.
LUIS: WHEN YOU GET A GUY JUST
COMING BACK OFTEN INJURY MAKING
HIS FIRST APPEARANCE, THAT
ADRENALINE HAS TO KICK IN.
GOT TO SLOW YOURSELF DOWN AND
GET IN THE GROOVE AND THE
RHYTHM.
ONE-RUN LEAD RIGHT NOW.
HE KNOWS HE IS IN A TIGHT GAME.
NOT LIKE HE HAS A FOUR-, FIVE-
RUN LEAD WHEN HE IS OUT THERE
WORKING.
JOHN: YOU WANT TO PUT HIM IN A
PRESSURE SITUATION.
HERE'S A PRESSURE SITUATION
TODAY.
LUIS: FACING THE HEART OF THE
ORDER.
HE IS FACING THE 2, 3, 4 GUYS IN
THE BATTING ORDER, BEST HITTERS
IN THE CLUB.
SCOTT: HERE IS ESCOBAR.
ANOTHER CURVEBALL.
LUGO KNOWN FOR THE SPIN RATE ON
THAT CURVE.
LATE START DUE TO ELBOW SURGERY
BACK IN FEBRUARY.
ESCOBAR DIDN'T GO AROUND.
LUGO IS 31 YEARS OLD.
I MENTIONED LAST YEAR HE
FINISHED IN THE ROTATION BUT
BACK IN THE RELIEF ROLE AND CAN
GO MULTIPLE INNINGS.
JOHN: MAKING THE BULLPEN A
LITTLE STRONGER THAN WHAT IT HAS
BEEN.
SCOTT: AND HE STRIKES OUT
ESCOBAR WITH SOME HIGH HEAT.
NEW TO THE GAME OF THE WEEK FOR
THE 2021 SEASON, THE YOUTUBE
PLAYER OF THE GAME.
HANDS WATCHING ON MOBILE DEVICES
AND COMPUTERS CAN PARTICIPATE IN
THE BALL TWO DECIDE WHO RECEIVES
THE CUSTOM TROPHY.
I'M TELLING YOU, PLAYERS LOVE
THIS THING.
STAY TUNED FOR THE PLAYER OF THE
GAME PULLING OPTIONS LATER IN
THE SHOW.
YOU KNOW HOW IT IS, LUIS.
PLAY 162, THIS BREAKS THINGS UP.
YOU ARE ON THE GLOBAL STAGE, GET
A TROPHY, AND THESE ARE THE MOST
COMPETITIVE HUMAN BEINGS ON THE
PLANET AND THEY WANT THESE BAD
BOYS AND THEY GET THEIR NAME
ENGRAVED ON IT.
LUIS: NICE PIECE OF HARDWARE
SOMEONE IS GOING TO BE TAKING
HOME TODAY.
SCOTT: BILLY MCKINNEY IN RIGHT
FIELD.
LUIS: I THINK THAT TROPHY MEANS
A LOT TO THE PLATE BECAUSE IT
WAS VOTED ON BY THE YOUTUBERS.
SCOTT: FANS DECIDE.
SHIFT TO CENTER.
PILLAR IS THERE.
THREE QUICK OUTS FROM SETH LUGO.
MAYBE WE WILL SEE MORE FROM HIM
IN THE NEXT INNING.
>> MAKE FUN OF ME?
>> HEART IS PALPITATING.
>> YES.
>> AND HE SHOOTS THAT ONE INTO
CENTER FIELD, BASE HIT.
>> OH NO1
>> SLIPS ON HIS WAY TO FIRST.
NOW IT'S A SINGLE.
>> OH NO!
>> THAT IS REALLY GOING TO HURT
HIS HOME TO FIRST NUMBERS.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, YOU MIGHT BE
RIGHT.
>> THEY NEED INTERPRETER.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT COUNTS AS
MULTIPLE --
>> KNOW, BUT IT IS GREAT HUSTLE
FROM THE INTERPRETER FOR THE
CARDINALS.
>> THIS ONE TO A WIDE OPEN
SPACE.
HE HITS PETERSON FOR THE OUT.
FIRST PLATE AS THE FIRST
BASEMAN, AND JAMES MCCANN NEVER
LET THE POSITION BEFORE, SINCE
COLLEGE.
>> OH, MIDSTREAM.
OUTSTANDING.
>> NOW HE IS REALLY TURNING IT
ON.
SCOTT: ON THIS INAUGURAL LOU
GEHRIG DAY, JOINED MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
ALS.
VISIT MLB.COM/4ALS TO LEARN
MORE.
IT MARKS THE DAY LOU GEHRIG
BECAME THE YANKEES' STARTING
FIRST AND STARTED THE STREAK OF
2103 CONSECUTIVE GAMES PLAYED.
IT WILL BE AN ANNUAL EVENT ON
THIS VERY DAY, JUNE 2, AND ALL
FOR A GOOD CAUSE AS WELL.
YOU SEE THE 4 ALS LOGOS IN
BALLPARKS AROUND THE COUNTRY
UNIFORM PATCHES, ALS WRISTBANDS
ARE AVAILABLE AS WELL.
REMEMBERING THE LEGACY OF THE
GREAT LOU GEHRIG AND ALL OF
THOSE LOST TO THE DISEASE THAT
BEARS HIS NAME.
RAISING RESEARCH FOR ALS TODAY.
I'M SITTING THERE TO A 2001 LOU
GEHRIG AWARD WINNER IN JOHN
FRANCO.
JOHN: GREAT HONOR, GREAT AWARD.
WHAT CAN YOU SAY ABOUT LOU
GEHRIG BUT GREAT HUMANITARIAN?
SOMETHING AS A PLAYER THAT YOU
TRY TO GIVE BACK AS MUCH AS YOU
CAN AND HELP OUT AS MUCH AS YOU
CAN.
SCOTT: TAYLOR CLARKE IS IN THE
GAME FOR ARIZONA, THIRD PITCHER
OF THE DAY.
HERE IS  VILLAR.
THAT ONE IS SMACKED TO RIGHT
CENTER FIELD.
MARTE CHASING AND LANDING IT.
FRANCISCO LINDOR IN THE TWO
SPOT.
MIC'D UP TODAY.
>> WHEN THE NAILS ARE JUMPING
THIS MUCH, IT MEANS I'VE GOT
CLAWS.
THE GOOD THING ABOUT PLAYING
EARLY AND HAVING THE ROOF CLOSED
IS WE STAY RELAXED.
EARLY GAME IN TEXAS BEFORE THE
STADIUM -- WOO!
ALL RIGHT, TAKE ME OUT.
SCOTT: LOVE IT.
A LITTLE INSIDE STUFF FROM
FRANCISCO LINDOR, INCLUDING A
LITTLE NAIL MAINTENANCE.
WE GOT A CLOSE-UP, TOO.
GET RID OF THOSE CLAWS.
GOOD WORK OVER THE LAST WEEK,
TOO.
LINDOR AND MCCANN WERE OFF TO
SLOW STARTS AT THE PLATE.
YOU CAN SEE BOTH OF THEM
SCORCHING THE PAST SEVEN DAYS OF
BASEBALL.
LUIS: AND LINDOR BEING SUCH A
GREAT PLAYER, HE SET THE BALL
HIGH BECAUSE HE HAD FANTASTIC
SPRING TRAINING.
HE WAS HITTING HOMERS AND GOT
EVERYBODY EXCITED.
ALL THE METS FANS EXCITED.
TO GET OUT OF THE GATE AS THOUGH
AS HE HAS COMMITTED TO STEADY
CLIMB TO GET OUT, BUT YOU ARE
SEEING THE LINDOR EVERYBODY HAS
EXPECTED.
SCOTT: LOCKED UP TO A LONG-TERM
DEAL THAT KICKS INTERNET YEAR.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST DEALS IN
MAJOR LEAGUE HISTORY.
JOHN: SCOTTY, YOU WILL TAKE
THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: I WILL TAKE A QUARTER OF
THAT -- I DON'T KNOW THE MATH,
BUT A TENTH, 20TH.
3% OF THAT LONG-TERM DEAL -- YOU
WILL SEE HIM IN A METS UNIFORM
FOR A LONG TIME.
JOHN: HE IS GOING TO BE A LEADER
IN THAT CLUB.
THE FIRST DAY HE CAME IN, HE
TOOK CHARGE.
JEFF MCNEIL, J.D. DAVIS TELLING
HIM HOW THEY SHOULD SET UP AND
HOW HE LIKES THE BALL.
AND IN THE LOCKER ROOM, TOO,
ALWAYS HAVING A SMILE ON HIS
FACE.
LUIS: JOHNNY, YOU KNOW, ONCE HE
STARTS HITTING LIKE HE IS
CAPABLE OF DOING, HE IS GOING TO
RELAX MORE, AND HIS PERSONALITY
IS GOING TO SHINE ON THE
BALLCLUB.
SCOTT: METS NEEDED TO CLEAN UP
THEIR DEFENSE OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS.
LINDOR A BIG PART OF THAT SO FAR
THIS SEASON.
THAT IS A SPINNER TO LEFT.
LOCASTRO ON THE RUN.
HE'S FAST.
AND HE RUNS IT DOWN.
TWO OUTS, AND JAMES MCCANN STEPS
UP TODAY.
HIS THIRD THREE-HIT GAME OF THE
SEASON.
SMASHED IN THE FIRST INNING TO
PUT THE METS UP 3-0, AND THEN
AN R.B.I. SINGLE AND THE SECOND
WASN'T DRIVEN IN FOUR SO FAR
TODAY AND GETS ONE ON THE RIGHT
SIDE.
BIG SMILE ON THE FACE OF JAMES
MCCANN AFTER HIS THIRD HIT, AND
THERE HE COMES FOR AT BAT NUMBER
FOUR OF THE DAY.
POTENTIAL YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE
GAME AT THIS POINT WITH THIS
PERFORMANCE?
JOHN: I WOULD SAY SO.
LUIS: I WOULD PUT HIM IN THAT
LUMP SUM, TOO.
SCOTT: HE HAD A FOUR-HIT DAY ON
SATURDAY, THREE CAREER FOUR-HIT
GAMES SATURDAY AGAINST THE
BRAVES, INCLUDING AN
OPPOSITE-FIELD HOME RUN IN THE
THIRD.
WE SAW HIM SMACK HIS FOURTH IN
THE OPENING INNING.
THAT IS LOUD CONTACTED TO RIGHT,
BUT SMITH WILL DRIFT BACK AND
MAKE THE CATCH.
TAYLOR CLARKE DOES HIS JOB FOR
THE DIAMONDBACKS WITH THE WE
HAVE PLAYED 5.5.
METS UP 1.
>> OH, MY!
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF!
>> THIS ONE IS --
>> OUTTA HERE!
>> ESCOBAR!
THAT'S 4 IN A ROW FOR EDUARDO
ESCOBAR!
IT'S 6-0.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
I'M PROUD OF YOU.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> NIDO SMACKS ONE IN THE AIR TO
DEEP LEFT CENTER.
BACK GOES OZUNA ON THE WINNING
TRACK.
IT'S OUTTA HERE!
THE METS TAKE THE LEAD IN THE
NINTH ON A TOMAS NIDO HOME RUN!
ANDY METS LEAD IT 4-3.
>> MAZEIKA GROUNDS ONE TO FIRST.
COMING HOME IS MANCINI.
METS THE WIND -- THE METS WHEN
IT!
THE  METS RALLY FOR TWO IN THE
BOTTOM OF THE NIGHT AND THEY
BEAT THE ORIOLES 3-2.
SCOTT: 6-5, METS, IN THE HOME
SIXTH.
ONE MORE POLL QUESTION
BEFORE THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE
GAME FOR LATER ON.
CAP ACQUISITION IN THE NATS --
TOP ACQUISITION IN THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE.
NOLAN ARENADO, TREVOR BAUER.
YU DARVISH LOOKING PRETTY SHARP
FOR SAN DIEGO.
HERE IS FRANKIE.
DEFENSE OUCH I NEED THE OFFENSE
SO FAR, BUT BAT STARTING TO COME
AROUND FOR LINDOR.
IT IS WHICH ACQUISITION WILL
HAVE THE BIGGEST IMPACT IN 2021.
I THINK THAT IS A KEY PART,
BECAUSE LINDOR COULD GO ON A
RUN.
WE HAVE SEEN HIM SWINGING THE
BAT WELL OVER THE LAST WEEK IN
CHANGE.
NOLAN ARENADO OFF TO HIS USUAL
START IN 2021.
GONZO, YOU PICK FIRST.
LUIS: I'M GOING TO GO WITH --
WELL, THE DODGERS PICKING UP
TREVOR BAUER IS PROBABLY HUGE
PICKUP FOR THEM BECAUSE IT
EXTENDED THE STARTING ROTATION
THEY HAVE.
I'M GOING TO GO WITH BAUER.
SCOTT: NO RELIEVERS ON THIS
BOARD.
[LAUGHTER]
LUIS: HE IS GOING TO GO OFF THE
CHART, I THINK.
SCOTT: MARK MELANCON HAS BEEN
PRETTY GOOD FOR THE PADRES.
JOHN: I'M GOING TO GO PASS.
SCOTT: YOU CAN'T PASS.
JOHN: I'M HOPING LINDOR.
GLIMMER OF HOPE RIGHT NOW.
SWINGING THE BAT WELL.
HIS DEFENSE WE ARE NOT WORRIED
ABOUT.
AND HIS LEADERSHIP IS GOING TO
HELP.
SCOTT: PAVIN SMITH LEADING OFF
THE DIAMONDBACKS' SIXTH.
JOHN: WHAT MAKES LUGO SO
EFFECTIVE IS HIS CURVEBALL IS A
78, 79 MILES AN HOUR.
IT MAKES HIS FASTBALL LOOKED
FASTER THAN WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
SCOTT: LUGO SAT DOWN THE FIRST
THREE THAT HE FACED IN THE
FIFTH.
TRAVIS BLANKENHORN CHECKING IN
AT SECOND BASE, AS HE WAS CALLED
UP YESTERDAY
JOSE PERAZA OVER TO THIRD BASE.
SCOTT: AND THAT IS PAST
BLANKENHORN INTO RIGHT CENTER.
CAVEN WITH HIS FIRST HIT, AND HE
KEEPS -- PAVIN SMITH WITH HIS
FIRST HIT, AND HE KEEPS HIS
STREAK ALIVE.
THE ROOKIE COMING THROUGH, AND
HE HAS GOT HIMSELF A 13-GAME
HITTING STREAK.
LUIS: HE HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
MOST CONSISTENT HITTER'S FOR
THIS CLUB SINCE THE START OF THE
YEAR.
YOU SEE HIM HUSTLING RIGHT OUT
OF THE BOX THINKING DOUBLE RIGHT
OUT OF THE GATES.
NICE EASY DOUBLE.
SCOTT: THERE IS THE STREAK, 13.
LEADING BASEBALL IN HITS FOR
FIRST-YEAR PLAYERS.
LUIS: YOU SEE A LOT MORE YOUNG
PLAYERS COMFORTABLE NOW GETTING
IN THE LEAGUE BECAUSE THERE IS
MORE SOCIAL MEDIA, YOU HAVE YOUR
YOUTUBERS AND GUYS LIKE THAT.
WHEN I CAME UP AS A ROOKIE, I
WAS MORE INTIMIDATED BECAUSE I
CAME OUT OF COLLEGE AND MINOR
LEAGUE AND THERE WAS NOT A LOT
OF EXPOSURE AS FAR AS TELEVISION
AND DIFFERENT TYPES OF SOCIAL
MEDIA THAT THESE GUYS COULD SEE.
NOW THEY KNOW EVERYTHING THAT IS
GOING ON.
THEY WALK IN THE CLUBHOUSE, IT
IS LIKE THEY KNOW THE PLAYERS
WHEN THEY GET THERE.
JOHN: ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
SO MUCH SOCIAL MEDIA.
EVERY GAME IS ON TV.
I THINK THAT HELPS THE PLAYERS A
LOT.
YOU COME TO THE SYSTEM A LOT
QUICKER NOW.
SCOTT: SECOND-LONGEST CURRENT
HITTING STREAK FOR SMITH.
2-1.
SETH LUGO MADE 4 REHAB
APPEARANCES BEFORE POPPING UP
WITH THE BIG-LEAGUE CLUB.
I IS PITCH COUNT WAS 33 --
HIGHEST PITCH COUNT WAS 33.
NUMBER 19 IN THE AIR.
FLOATER IS GOING TO FALL FOR THE
KNOCK.
NICK AHMED WITH A BASE HIT.
PAVIN SMITH OVER TO THIRD.
SCOTT: THEY ARE ON THE CORNERS
FOR VARGAS.
AARON LOUP HEATING UP.
JONATHAN VILLAR LEFT THE GAME
WITH RIGHT HAMSTRING TIGHTNESS.
JOHN: ANOTHER HAMSTRING INJURY.
THAT IS THE KEY --
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN: CONFORTO AND MCNEIL WITH A
HAMSTRINGS AND NOW THE LARK.
-- NOW VILLAR.
SCOTT: WHAT IS IT, GONZO?
LUIS: THEY ARE EATING TOO MUCH
HEALTHY FOOD.
JOHN: I AGREE, GONZO.
SCOTT: I'M ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THAT CONVERSATION.
LUIS: I KNOW YOU ARE.
[LAUGHTER]
LUIS: PROBABLY DRINKING ONE OF
THOSE FANCY SHAKES BETWEEN
PITCHES.
JOHN: ABSOLUTE RIGHT, CHOCOLATE
MILK AND THE WATER BOTTLE.
SCOTT: COFFEE WITH COCONUT
WATER.
THAT IS WHERE THE BALL NEEDS TO
GO TO PULL OFF THE RUN WITH
SMITH IN THIRD.
LUIS: I HAVE SEEN THE SCOTTY
BRAUN WORKOUT PROGRAM.
I'M STAYING AWAY FROM THAT ONE.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: I'VE BEEN OFF THE IL FOR
A WHILE NOW.
I'M DOING OK.
JOHN: GET SOME OF THAT FATTY
FOOD BEFORE YOU PULL THOSE
MUSCLES.
LUIS: THAT IS A DEBATE WITH OLD-
SCHOOL AND A NEW-SCHOOL GUYS,
BECAUSE YOU TALK TO THE OLD
SCHOOL GUYS, THEY WANTED TO PLAY
EVERY DAY AND THEY ATE WHATEVER
THEY WANTED TO.
NOW YOU GO TO THE BALLPARK AND
THERE ARE SPECIALIZED MEALS FOR
THESE GUYS, THEY ARE HAVING
THEIR PROTEIN SHAKES, VITAMINS,
ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT THINGS.
THEY LOOK GOOD GETTING OFF THE
BUS, BUT THEY CAN'T STAY
HEALTHY.
JOHN: YOU GOTTA A SNEAK A PIZZA
IN ONCE IN A WHILE.
SCOTT: EVERYONE IS BIGGER,
STRONGER, FASTER.
STRETCHING SOUNDS GOOD.
MAYBE SOME YOGA.
LUIS: THEY HAVE THOSE PLANS, TO
COME IN ARIZONA, A LOT OF THOSE
PLACES.
SCOTT: METS HAVE RUNNERS ON THE
CORNERS.
TWO STRIKES -- MAKE THAT
DIAMONDBACKS WITH RUNNERS ON THE
CORNERS.
TWO STRIKES ON VARGAS WILL NOW
IT IS 2-2.
AHMED WITH A BASE HIT TO MOVE
HIM OVER.
JOHN: I BELIEVE THE METS HAVE
THEIR COOK TRAVEL WITH THEM TO
MAKE SURE THE MEALS ARE PREPARED
PROPERLY.
LUIS: I THINK BRAUNY DOES, TOO,
DON'T YOU, SCOTT, WHEN YOU GO ON
THE ROAD?
SCOTT: I COOK MYSELF  VARGAS
MAKES CONTACT LEFT SIDE.
PERAZA HAS TO EAT THE BASEBALL.
THE DIAMONDBACKS TIE IT OFF THE
INFIELDER KNOCK FROM VARGAS.
LUIS: VARGAS HAS HAD AN IMPACT
IN ESCAPE HIS FIRST DAY -- IN
THIS GAME HIS FIRST DAY BACK
FROM THE TRADE THIS MORNING,
DRIVEN IN THREE RUNS ALREADY.
JOHN: GOING BACK TO WHAT YOU
SAID EARLIER, JUST MAKE CONTACT
FOR GUYS ON BASE.
JUST ENOUGH TO HAVE THE RUN
SCORED.
IN FIELD SINGLE.
LUIS: YOU ARE SEEING WITH THE
VELOCITY THAT THESE PITCHERS
HAVE NOW, THEY ARE THROWING MID
TO UPPER 90'S.
THE GAME WILL EVENTUALLY REVOLVE
BACK TO GUYS PUTTING THE BALL IN
PLAY AND MAKING THINGS HAPPEN.
IN THE OLD SCHOOL DAYS IF YOU
DIDN'T PUT THE BALL IN PLAY, YOU
WEREN'T GOING TO GET TO THE BIG
LEAGUES.
NOW IT IS ABOUT POWER AND
STRENGTH.
THESE GUYS HITTING BALLS A MILE.
THREE STRIKEOUTS THEY ARE
ACCEPTABLE -- TWO OR THREE
STRIKEOUTS A DAY ARE ACCEPTABLE.
JOHN: IN THE OLD DAYS YOU WOULD
HAVE A LITTLE KITTY.
BASE HIT, ANOTHER FIVE DOLLARS.
GUYS WOULD ANTE UP AND AT THE
END OF THE YEAR YOU HAVE A NICE
DINNER.
SCOTT: THERE IS THE LINE FOR
LUGO, LOOKING FORCE FIRST OUT IN
THE SECOND -- LOOKING FOR THE
FIRST OUT IN THE SECOND INNING
OF WORK.
QUICK FRAME IN THE FIFTH.
SETH RUNNING TO SOME TROUBLE IN
THE NEXT INNING.
SMITH DOUBLE.
AHMED WITH A SINGLE.
INFIELD HIT FOR VARGAS.
JOSH REDDICK IS ON DECK.
GOOD PINCHHITTING OPTIONS TODAY
FOR ARIZONA.
THAT IS CAUGHT ON THE FLY BY
LUGO, AND THEY WILL DOUBLE HIM
UP.
NICK AHMED WAS OFF THE BAG, AND
THAT IS A BIG TWO OUTS.
LUIS: YEAH, THAT'S A HUGE OUT,
AND SCOTT, YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
IT EARLIER, HOW MANY TIMES HAS A
GUY LIKE LOCASTRO BUNTED.
THIS IS ONE OF THE PARTS OF HIS
SKIN THAT HE IS GOING TO HAVE TO
WORK ON AND TRY TO GET BETTER
AT, ESPECIALLY WITH HIS SPEED.
HE SHOULD GET THOSE FALLS DOWN.
HE BUNTED THAT RIGHT BACK TO THE
PITCHER.
NICE FOR LUGO TO TURN THE DOUBLE
PLAY.
SCOTT: SLIDING STOP CATCH ON THE
RUN IN THE AIR FOR LUGO.
YOU HEAR LINDOR.
JOHN: HOW ABOUT THE PICK BY
LINDOR?
SCOTT: FANTASTIC.
LUIS: GOOD PLAY ON BOTH ENDS.
LUGO MADE A NICE PLAY, AND THE
PLAY BY LINDOR ON SECOND.
SCOTT: HERE IS REDDICK.
HE HAD THE WALKOFF TO-RUN DOUBLE
YESTERDAY IN THE 10TH.
HE IS ON FIRE SINCE JOINING THE
DIAMONDBACKS.
.370, HAS DRIVEN IN SIX, SEVEN
DOUBLES AND IS FIRST COUPLE
WEEKS WITH THE TEAM.
HE WAS SIGNED IN MID APRIL,
MINOR LEAGUE CONTRACT.
SIZZLING IN HIS LAST THREE
GAMES.
LUIS: HE WAS A GUY THAT THE TEAM
DESPERATELY NEEDED, THAT VETERAN
BAT IN THE LINEUP.
SPEND SOME TIME IN RENO, AAA
AFFILIATE FOR THE DIAMONDBACKS,
UNTIL HE WAS READY TO GO.
SCOTT: YESTERDAY HE WAS THE BIG
MAN IN THE 10TH, AFTER A GREAT
AT-BAT FROM DAVID SMITH.
TWO ON.
THAT WAS JUST SLIGHTLY FAIR.
IT WAS REVIEWED AND THE CALL
STOOD, EVEN THOUGH TREVOR MAY
STILL THINKS IT'S A FOUL BALL.
JOSH REDDICK, MR. WALKOFF,
BRINGING IN 2.
OFTEN THE CORNER BY BILLY
MCKINNEY.
IN LITTLE COLD.
FELT SO GOOD FOR JOSH REDDICK
POSTGAME.
AND HE STRIKES OUT.
AFTER A BUMPY BEGINNING TO THE
SIXTH, RECOVERS WITH
AN ATHLETIC DOUBLE PLAY AND A
STRIKEOUT, BUT WE ARE TIED AGAIN
AFTER SIX.
>> GOING INTO GAME SEVEN,
SCHILLING ON THE MOUND, WE FELT
GOOD, AND WITH RANDY IN RELIEF
WE FELT EVEN BETTER IF WE HAD TO
GO THAT ROUTE.
>> CURT SCHILLING THREW WELL,
BUT AFTER THE EIGHTH, HE CALLED
UPON HIS BEST OPTION TO MAKE
SURE THERE WOULD BE NO MORE
DAMAGE.
>> AND THE BIG UNIT IS COMING IN
THE BALLGAME.
>> THE PLACE GOT LOUD WHEN THE
BIG FELLA CAME IN FROM THE
BULLPEN.
GETTING GOOSEBUMPS THINKING
ABOUT IT RIGHT NOW.
>> MAN THREW OVER 100 PITCHES
YESTERDAY AND HE IS COMING IN
THE NEXT DAY.
>> I THINK ANYTIME SOMEBODY GOES
ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT IS
EXPECTED AND HAS SUCCESS DOING
IT, THAT IS WHAT CEMENTS YOU IN
THE LORE OF BASEBALL.
>> SWING AND A MISS, STRUCK HIM
OUT.
JANSSEN RETIRES ALL 4 HITTERS HE
FACES.
AND THAT SETS THE STAGE FOR THE
BOTTOM OF THE NINTH INNING.
DIAMONDBACKS WIN!
THEY ARE THE WORLD CHAMPIONS!
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU PLAY FOR, SO
I'M THANKFUL I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE
GREATEST MOMENT OF MY CAREER
WITH MY TEAMMATES.
SCOTT: STEP UP TO THE PLATE,
COMPETE ONLINE AND CRUSHED
DINNERS IN THE MLB HOME RUN
DERBY.
DOWNLOADED FROM THE APP STORE AT
GOOGLE PLAY TODAY.
WATCH ALL OUT OF MARGATE --
MARKET REGULAR GAMES A LIVE OR
ON-DEMAND.
VISIT MLB.TV FOR DETAILS.
CRUISING INTO THE SEVENTH, THE
DIAMONDBACKS PICK UP A RUN IN
THE BOTTOM OF THE SIXTH.
THE METS OUT HITTING ARIZONA
14-8 SO FAR THIS AFTERNOON.
FIREWORKS.
ONE MORE FROM ARIZONA TO TIE IT.
BACK-AND-FORTH WE GO.
NOW EVEN AT 6-6.
HERE COMES KEVIN GINKEL OUT OF
THE BULLPEN FOR TOREY LOVULLO AS
DIAMONDBACKS TEAM -- TOREY
LOVULLO'S DIAMONDBACKS TEAM.
MIDDLE OF THE ORDER FOR THE
METS, 4, 5, SIX.
IT STARTS WITH PETE ALONSO, WHO
IS 1-3.
TAKES A DEEP BREATH.
WE SEE CHRISTIAN WALKER DO
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BETWEEN EACH
PITCH.
STAYS UP FOR SMITH, OUT NUMBER
ONE.
>> THESE GUYS ALL HAVE ROUTINES
TO GET THEIR MIND RIGHT
BEFORE THEY GET IN THE BOX AND
RELAX A LITTLE BIT.
NEXT MAN UP COULD BE RYAN
BUCHTER FOR THE D-BACKS.
HERE COMES THE FEARLESS KEVIN
PILLAR, TWO HITS TODAY.
LET'S BRING IN STEVE GILBERT.
HOW IMPRESSIVE HAS KEVIN BEEN,
NOT JUST THIS WEEK, BUT NOW
TODAY, BACK IN THE STARTING
LINEUP FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE
SUFFERING SOME FACIAL FRACTURES
ON A HIT BY PITCH?
YOU WILL SEE HIM THIS ONE TO
CENTER.
HE'S GOT IT.
THE GOLD GLOVER HAULS IT IN.
STEVE: ABSOLUTELY, SCOTT.
WE WERE TALKING EARLIER ABOUT
THE RESPECT HE HAS IN THE
CLUBHOUSE.
I THINK A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THAT
IS JACOB DEGROM.
AFTER HIS START THE OTHER NIGHT,
DEGROM SAID THE HIGHLIGHT OF THE
NIGHT FOR HIM WAS THE FACT THAT
PILLAR GOT THAT BASE HIT.
I THINK THAT SPEAKS TO HOW THEY
FEEL ABOUT HIM IN THE CLUBHOUSE.
SCOTT: ONE OF THE ULTIMATE
COMPETITORS.
IN THE NEW YORK CROWD HAS REALLY
GRAVITATED TOWARD KEVIN PILLAR.
>> GUYS WHO HUSTLE, GUYS WHO ARE
GRINDERS.
THE UNIFORM IS ALWAYS DIRTY.
STEVE: THEY ALWAYS WANT THOSE
GUYS WHO PLAY HARD.
THAT IS A TESTAMENT TO PILLAR,
THAT A GUY LIKE DEGROM, WHO IS A
STAR PITCHER ON THEIR TEAM, HAS
THE UTMOST RESPECT FOR A GUY
LIKE KEVIN AND WANTS TO WEAR HIS
NUMBER WHEN HE GOES ON A REHAB
ASSIGNMENT.
THAT'S AWESOME.
SCOTT: DOM SMITH SEARCHING FOR
HIS FOURTH HIT OF THE DAY.
HE IS 3-3.
SINGLE -- A FEW SINGLES AND HE
HOMERED YESTERDAY.
PITCHER SPOT COMING UP NEXT.
LAST YEAR, SMITH HIT .316 AND 50
GAMES THAT IN -- IN 50 GAMES.
>> THE OTHER THING ABOUT HIM, HE
HAS BEEN PLAYING A REALLY GOOD
LEFT FIELD.
A SOLID LEFT FIELD.
SCOTT: TAKES THE 2-1.
I SPOKE TO HIM ABOUT THAT IN
SPRING TRAINING.
HE SAID JUST REMEMBER, I HAVEN'T
PLAYED MUCH OUTFIELD IN MY LIFE.
HE WAS THRUST INTO THAT SPOT
LAST YEAR, SWUNG THE BAT WELL,
AND HE HAS IMPROVED
SIGNIFICANTLY THIS YEAR.
AND A FIVE PITCH WALK.
IF YOU LIKE THE STAT DEFENSIVE
RUNS SAVED, ONE OF THE DEFENSIVE
METRICS USED TO JUDGE FIELDERS,
DOM SMITH IS ABOVE AVERAGE THIS
YEAR.
MUCH IMPROVED ON THE DEFENSIVE
SIDE.
A NEW PITCHER COMING IN.
RYAN BUCHTER GINKEL, A TWO OUT
BASE RUNNER FOR THE METS IN DOM
SMITH.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
>> WHEN YOU ARE THE FRANCHISE,
THAT SAYS A LOT ABOUT WHO YOU
ARE AND THAT SAYS A LOT ABOUT
WHO TOM SEAVER WAS.
>> NUMBERS ONLY BEGIN TO EXPLAIN
THE LEGACY OF GEORGE THOMAS
SEAVER.
HE ARRIVED ON THE MOUND FOR THE
LOWLY NEW YORK METS.
>> COLLEGE KID FROM CALIFORNIA,
WENT TO USC, HE WAS SO POLISHED.
>> I REMEMBER THE FIRST TIME I
FACED HIM.
THAT'S WHAT I'VE GOT.
IT'S PROBABLY BETTER THAN WHAT
YOU'VE GOT.
HE GAVE THEM RESPECT.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, CREDIBILITY WAS
THERE.
>> THOSE WHO HAVE NOT BELIEVED
IN US BEFORE I THINK HAVE EVERY
RIGHT TO BELIEVE IN US NOW.
>> IT LOOKED LIKE THE CUBS WERE
GOING TO RUN AWAY WITH THAT
DIVISION.
THE METS, IT WAS ONE OF THOSE
MAGICAL CLUBS.
>> WE ALWAYS FOUGHT, AND IT'S
THE GREATEST FEELING IN THE
WORLD.
SCOTT: GOOGLE CLOUD IS HELPING
POWER STATCAST WITH DATA POINTS.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS THE OFFICIAL
CLOUD TECHNOLOGY OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
WE ARE SEARCHING FOR THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE.
PLAYER OF THE GAME.
IF YOU ARE WATCHING, YOU CAN
VOTE.
STAY TUNED.
PULLING OPTIONS COMING IN A
LITTLE BIT.
WE CREEP INTO THE LATER INNINGS
HERE, NOW IN THE SEVENTH, DOM
SMITH WALKED AND TOREY LOVULLO
DECIDED IT'S A QUICK COOK TODAY.
HE GOES TO RYAN BUCHTER.
>> FIFTH PITCHER OF THE GAME FOR
ARIZONA.
THE VETERAN, 34 YEARS OLD.
>> I AM NOT SURE THEY KNOW THE
SCOUTING REPORTS.
SCOTT: HE STOLE ONE YESTERDAY,
SECOND OF HIS CAREER.
HE SNUCK ONE IN THERE YESTERDAY.
BY HIMSELF, TWO OUTS, KEITH
HERNANDEZ ON THE CALL.
HE WAS POINTING OUT THIS COULD
BE A GOOD TIME TO GO.
GOOD CALL BY KEITH, TOO.
DARE HIM TO DO IT AGAIN?
>> LEFTY ON THE MOUND, MIGHT BE
A LITTLE TOUGHER TODAY.
>> HE'S WAITING TO SEE IF THE
RUNNER COMMITS ARE NOT.
>> THE PINCH HITTER IS MASON
WILLIAMS HE WAS ACTIVATED BY THE
METS ON MONDAY.
THE FIRST PITCH HE SAW WAS AN
OPPOSITE FIELD SINGLE.
RYAN BUCHTER HAS ALLOWED NINE
STOLEN BASES, BUT HE HAS ALSO
CAUGHT 11 BASERUNNERS WHEN HE
HAS BEEN ON THE MOUND.
NOT THE GUY YOU TEST.
WILLIAMS GOING LEFT, DRIFTING
BACK IS CASTRO, AND HE GRABS IT.
THE SEVENTH.
RYAN BUCHTER STRANDS A RUNNER
AND LET'S STRETCH.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE WONDERING
WHY THE DIAMONDBACKS.
THIS TEAM IS NOT THE SAME TEAM
THAT LOST LAST YEAR.
>> HE REALLY BROUGHT LEGITIMACY
TO THE TEAM.
YOU REALIZE YOU'RE GOING TO WIN
WITH GOOD PITCHING AND GOOD
DEFENSE.
CONVINCING RANDY TO SIGN HERE
WAS THE PERFECT STORM.
HE PUT THE DIAMONDBACKS ON THE
MAP.
>> RANDY JOHNSON WILL TAKE THE
MOUND FOR THE FIRST TIME AS A
DIAMONDBACK.
>> BALL ON THE INSIDE CORNER.
>> RANDY WAS A GUY THAT PITCHED
ON EMOTION, AND USUALLY IT WAS
ANGER.
HE WAS ANGRY AT ANYBODY THAT
STEPPED IN THE BOX.
>> HE WALKS UP TO THE MOUND.
>> HE WAS CAUGHT UP IN THE
MOMENT, GETTING PRETTY ANIMATED.
>> HE IS NASTY.
>> 2-2 TO CASTRO.
RANDY JOHNSON HAS TIED THE MAJOR
LEAGUE RECORD OF STRIKEOUTS AND
A NINE INNING GAME.
>> GO, GO, GO.
>> I THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO GET
HIM OUT.
>> HE IS ONE OF THE BEST BASE
RUNNERS I HAVE EVER SEEN.
>> WE THOUGHT WE WOULD GET HIM
OUT NO MATTER WHAT.
>> THAT'S A HARD PLAY.
YOU ARE OUT AT THIRD.
SCOTT: FRANCISCO LINDOR
DISCUSSING THE DOUBLE PLAY.
OUR LATEST POLL, THE N.L.
OFF-SEASON ACQUISITION THAT WILL
HAVE THE BIGGEST IMPACT.
YOUR WINNER, IT WAS REALLY
CLOSE, TREVOR BAUER BY A POINT
OVER FRANCISCO LINDOR.
I THINK THE IMPORTANT PART IS
WILL HAVE THE BIGGEST IMPACT.
NOTICE THE SLOW START AT THE
PLATE.
EXPECTING BIG THINGS FOR THIS
SEASON AND BEYOND.
CASTRO IS GOING TO TAKE OVER IN
THE SEVENTH AGAINST THE
DIAMONDBACKS TOP OF THE ORDER.
>> THIS HAS BEEN A VERY GOOD
SEASON.
HE CAME OVER FROM BALTIMORE IN A
TRADE, FASTBALL, SLIDER, PRETTY
GOOD CHANGEUP.
THAT PITCH IS REALLY HELPING HIM
OUT THIS SEASON.
>> THAT SINKER AVERAGES 98 MILES
PER HOUR.
MISSES IN TO CARSON KELLY.
DID YOU LIKE THAT COMBO WITH
LINDOR EXPLAINING THE NEED TO
DOUBLE UP NICK AHMED?
>> HE IS DEFINITELY AWARE OF
EVERYTHING GOING ON OUT THERE.
I THINK IT WAS BRANDON DRURY HE
WAS TALKING TO.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A VIEW FOR THE
GAME OUT THERE AND I THINK THAT
IS WHAT HE DOES SO WELL.
HE ANTICIPATES THE BALL BEING
HIT TO HIM, TRYING TO SHIFT GUYS
AROUND ON DEFENSE.
THAT IS WHAT MAKES HIM ONE OF
THE BEST IN THE GAME.
>> KELLY FOULS OFF THE ONE P1 --
1-1.
MIGUEL CASTRO HAS REALLY TAKEN
THE NEXT STEP AS A RELIEF
PITCHER.
THE RISE BEGAN LAST YEAR WHEN HE
WAS CAUSING SO MUCH MORE SWING
AND MISS THAN WE ARE USED TO
SEEING.
BACK TO LINDOR FOR A MOMENT.
WE KNOW HE CAN PICK IT AT SHORT.
HE HAS A TWO TIME GOLD GLOVER.
BUT HE SAID HE IS LOOKING TO GET
BACK TO HIS PRIME FORM THAT HE
PUT TOGETHER FROM 2016-2019.
THINGS REALLY PICKED UP FOR HIM
DURING THAT TIME.
LAST YEAR WASN'T GREAT, BUT IT
WAS ONLY A 60 GAME SEASON.
MARTE GOES DOWN ON A PITCH THAT
GETS CASTRO.
>> ONE OF THE CRAZIEST THINGS I
HAVE EVER SEEN.
>> AND THEN HE LOOKED AT CASTRO
LIKE HE DID SOMETHING WRONG.
>> HE WAS MAD AT CASTRO.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING, MAN?
YOU ARE EMBARRASSING ME ON
YOUTUBE.
>> I DIDN'T EXPECT THAT PITCH TO
MOVE FOUR FEET LIKE IT DID.
IF I WAS CASTRO, I WOULD TRY TO
THROW THE SAME PITCH RIGHT NOW.
>> IT'S LIKE IF YOU FOUL ONE OFF
YOUR SHIN, YOU KNOW THE PITCHER
IS GOING TO TRY TO THROW IT
RIGHT BACK IN THERE.
>> PITCH INSIDE.
>> YOU SEE THAT COMEBACKER
MOVEMENT.
THE BALL STARTS IN ON HIS HIP
AND TRIES TO COME BACK OVER THE
PLATE.
>> CASTRO COVERS THE BAG FOR THE
SECOND OUT.
>> I THINK THAT FIRST PITCH HE
SWUNG AT, WHEN HE FELL DOWN,
THAT MESSED THEM UP.
YOU KNOW AS A PITCHER, IN THE
BACK OF HIS MIND, HE THOUGHT
THAT WAS GOING TO COME AGAIN
SOONER OR LATER.
>> MARTE AND ESCOBAR, ESCOBAR
SKIES ONE.
ALONSO CALLING FOR IT, DRIFTING
IN.
SIDE RETIRED.
THREE
CASTRO.
WE HAVE PLAYED SEVEN IN THE
DESERT, TIED BALLGAME.
>> WE ARE STATIC TO MAKE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT THE NEW YORK
METS ACQUIRED MIKE PIAZZA.
>> WHEN WE FINALLY FOUND OUT WE
GOT MIKE PIAZZA, I REMEMBER IT
WAS LIKE, WE GOT MIKE PIAZZA?
EVEN THOUGH HE HAS THE HOLLYWOOD
FROSTED TIPS HAIR, HE IS A
BLUE-COLLAR, REAL BASEBALL FAN.
THE AVERAGE NEW YORKER GOT HIM.
THERE WAS A CONNECTION.
>> THIS ONE HAS A CHANCE.
HOME RUN, MIKE PIAZZA, AND THE
METS LEAD.
>> HE WAS RELENTLESS IN HIS
BEHAVIOR, HIS ATTITUDE, HIS WORK
ETHIC.
THEY WANT YOU TO GRIND.
THEY WANT YOU TO PLAY YOUR NEW
-- YOUR YOU KNOW WHAT OFF AND
GIVE 100%.
AND THEN BE THE MAN.
>> MIKE PIAZZA.
>> YOU'RE NOT JUST LIKE A NICE
HITTER.
YOU ARE THE GUY.
SCOTT: ACCESS EXCLUSIVE BEHIND
THE SCENES CONTENT ON THE NEW
YORK METS YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
6-6, WE HAVE REACHED THE EIGHTH.
WITH YOU ON YOUTUBE TODAY.
BALL MISSES AWAY TO JOSÉ PERAZA.
PERAZA MOVING OVER TO THIRD
BASE, STARTED THE GAME AT
SECOND, VILLAR HAD TO EXIT WITH
RIGHT HAMSTRING TIGHTNESS.
HE AND PARADA HAVE DONE AN
OUTSTANDING JOB FILLING IN
INFIELDERS WITH SOME KEY
INJURIES.
J.D. DAVIS ALSO SUFFERED A BIT
OF A SETBACK.
>> IT'S A LONG SEASON, AND YOU
ARE GOING TO NEED MORE THAN
THESE 26 GUYS.
VETERAN GUYS KNOW THEIR ROLES.
AND THEY GET PLENTY AT BATS.
>> I REMEMBER THINKING, DO THOSE
GUYS KNOW HOW MANY PLAYERS ARE
ON THE METS ALREADY?
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO FIND
PLAYING TIME FOR THEM?
A BLINK AND A FEW IL STUDENTS,
AND THEY ARE PLAYING EVERY DAY.
-- STINTS, AND THEY ARE PLAYING
EVERY DAY.
>> I THINK A LOT OF THOSE
VETERAN GUYS, WHEN THEY ARE FREE
AGENTS LOOKING FOR A JOB, THEY
ARE TOLD YOU MIGHT HAVE TO
MENTOR A YOUNG PLAYER AND IF
SOMETHING HAPPENS, BE READY TO
STEP IN.
SCOTT: FOUL DOWN THE LINE.
>> THERE COMES A POINT IN GUYS
CAREERS WHEN THEY HAVE TO
REALIZE THAT TO STICK AROUND
LONGER, THEY HAVE TO BE A ROLE
PLAYER AND MENTOR YOUNG PLAYERS.
TEACH THEM HOW TO PLAY THE GAME.
>> ZIMMERMAN IS A GREAT EXAMPLE
OF THAT WITH THE WASHINGTON
NATIONALS.
HE GETS HIS STARTS HERE AND
THERE, IS A PRODUCTIVE PLAYER,
NOT PLAYING EVERY DAY, BUT WHEN
HE IS IN THERE, HE IS DOING HIS
JOB.
SCOTT: HE HAS BEEN A VERY
DIFFERENT HITTER WITH NOBODY ON
BASE THIS YEAR.
>> GIVE CREDIT TO BOTH BULLPENS.
EVERYTHING HAS REALLY KIND OF
SETTLED DOWN.
THERE HAVEN'T BEEN A LOT OF
FIREWORKS LIKE WE SAW THE FIRST
INNING ON BOTH SIDES.
BOTH OF COME IN AND DONE
FANTASTIC JOBS.
>> MCKINNEY FOULS ONE BACK.
>> I HAVE TO AGREE WITH YOU,
THEY HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB.
ESPECIALLY THE BULLPEN GUYS.
YOU HAVE TO ROOT FOR THE BULLPEN
GUYS.
>> 0-2 TO MCKINNEY.
MY FAVORITE COMMENT IN THE LIVE
CHAT, JUST GIVE US A DEGROM
PINCH-HITTING APPEARANCE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A CRAZY
SUGGESTION.
THERE'S ONLY ONE MAN LEFT ON THE
BENCH FOR THE METS RIGHT NOW.
>> IT'S HAPPENED BEFORE.
WITH OF THOSE GUYS SWING THE BAT
PRETTY GOOD.
>> MCKINNEY DOESN'T BITE.
DEGROM'S 9-20 AT THE PLATE.
THAT IS AMAZING.
CHECK OUT THE BOX SCORE.
GOOD WORK AFTER BUMGARNER.
>> I SAW A CRAZY STAT ON DEGROM.
I THINK HE HAS DRIVEN AND MORE
THAN RUNS HAVE SCORED AGAINST
HIM, SOMETHING CRAZY LIKE THAT.
HE IS DEFINITELY -- THERE ARE
FEW AND FAR GUYS LIKE HIM THAT
COME THROUGH THIS GAME.
SOMETHING SPECIAL.
SCOTT: ANOTHER STRIKEOUT FOR
BUCHTER.
DEGROM HAS ALLOWED FOUR EARNED
RUN THIS YEAR AND DRIVEN AND
THREE, SO IT IS A TIGHT RACE.
>> IT'S CLOSE.
HE SLEEPS GOOD AT NIGHT KNOWING
HE HAS THAT 93 MILE PER HOUR
SLIDER.
SO FREE AND EASY.
GETS OUT THERE, SAME RELEASE
POINT ON EVERYTHING.
SCOTT: FIRST AT-BAT FOR TRAVIS
BLANKENHORN.
HIS 2021 NUMBERS IN THE MINOR
LEAGUES.
THE LATEST CALL UP BY THE METS,
SELECTED YESTERDAY.
HOPPED IN THE GAME IN THE SECOND
WHEN VILLAR LEFT WITH A
HANDSPRING -- HAMSTRING ISSUE.
>> THAT'S A TOUGH DRAW.
YOU GET CALLED OFF THE BENCH IN
A LEFTY LEFTY SITUATION.
>> STRIKES OUT THE SIDE IN THE
EIGHTH.
WE GET TO THE D-BACKS AND THE
INNING COMING UP.
>> I'VE GOT THE MIC.
IF GOT THE MIC ON TODAY.
I'M GOING ALL THE WAY.
ALL THE WAY, BABY.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
I'M GREAT.
LIVING THE DREAM, LIVING THE
DREAM.
AFTER THAT, ANY PITCH.
WHAT ARE THE CHANCES HE WILL
SWING AT THE FIRST PITCH?
I'M UP THE MIDDLE.
YOU CAN PROBABLY SHADE A LITTLE
MORE.
LAST YEAR I DIDN'T GET THIS.
LAST YEAR WAS A LOT OF IN
BETWEEN.
NOW I'M LIKE STARTING TO GET
INTO IT.
I'M SWINGING MY BARREL A LITTLE
BETTER THAN LAST YEAR.
SCOTT: ACCESS EXCLUSIVE BEHIND
THE SCENES CONTENT ON THE
ARIZONA DIAMONDBACKS YOUTUBE
CHANNEL.
FOLLOW THE TEAM TODAY.
6-6 IN THE DESERT.
I YOUTUBE CREATOR GOING I NEVER
THOUGHT AFTER THE FIRST INNING
THAT THIS WOULD TURN INTO A
PITCHING DUEL.
>> FROM THE SECOND INNING ON.
SCOTT: EVERYONE JUST WAKING UP
IN THE FIRST AFTER A LATE ONE
YESTERDAY WENT TO EXTRA INNINGS.
FIRST PITCH SWING, CHRISTIAN
WALKER WITH SOME OPEN SPACE,
RIGHT CENTER, AND IT IS CAUGHT.
DOWN IT RIGHT BY BILLY MCKINNEY.
GREAT CLOSING SPEED.
ONE PITCH, ONE OUT FOR MIGUEL
CASTRO IN THE EIGHTH.
>> YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
HE WENT A LONG WAY TO GET THAT
BALL.
CUT THE ANGLE PERFECT.
NICE EXTENSION TO MAKE A GREAT
PLAY.
>> 90 FEET, RUNS IT DOWN TO GRAB
THE BASEBALL.
BILLY LOOKED VERY COMPOSED.
TRACKS IT DOWN.
SMITH HAS REACHED BASE TWICE
TODAY.
TOREY LOVULLO SAYS THIS IS A PRO
HITTER, WORKING COUNTS DAY ONE
WITH THIS CAMPAIGN.
HE LOOKS LIKE HE BELONGS.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS ALL SERIES
LONG.
>> FROM DAY ONE, YOU ARE
STARTING TO SEE MORE AND MORE
CONFIDENCE FROM THIS KID.
HE IS NOT IN A SET POSITION ON
THE FIELD.
TORI HAS USED HIM EVERYWHERE IN
THE LINEUP.
HE HAS PLAYED HIM EVERYWHERE IN
THE OUTFIELD AND THE INFIELD AND
HE HAS MOVED TO OR THREE TIMES
IN THE GAME.
SCOTT: WALKS AGAIN.
TOREY SAID HE HAD THEM IN THE
LEADOFF SPOT AT ONE POINT AND
THEN DECIDED TO TAKE A LITTLE
PRESSURE OFF THE ROOKIE.
THEN HE TOOK OFF AGAIN.
HE HAS BEEN ON BASE MACHINE, ONE
OUT RUNNER FOR NICK AHMED.
STEVE, WHAT ELSE DO YOU HAVE FOR
US?
>> PAIVA IS NOT YOUR TYPICAL
FIRST NAME.
PAVIN SMITH IS NAMED AFTER CORY
PAVING, THE PGA TOUR PLAYER OF
THE YEAR IN 1991.
SCOTT: HOW ABOUT THAT?
MIDDLE NAME SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PLAYER.
PAVING PLAYER SMITH.
DO WE KNOW HIS MIDDLE NAME?
THERE WE GO, RESEARCH STAFF.
JOE WORKS.
2-0 TO AHMED.
AARON LOUP RE-WARMING.
JOHNNY, DO YOU REMEMBER THE MOST
YOU HAVE EVER WARMED UP IN ONE
GAME?
>> BEFORE I WAS A CLOSER, SET UP
MAN, I WOULD THROW IT LIKE 67
TIMES ONE TIME.
YOU GET CALLED INTO THE GAME,
YOU LET A COUPLE GO, YOU ARE
READY.
BUT AFTER THE FIRST TIME ANY
RELIEVER IS UP, HE GETS TO SIT
DOWN AGAIN, THEN GET UP AGAIN, I
THINK YOU ARE ALREADY LOOSE.
LAST COUPLE OF THROWS, YOU LET
IT GO.
BUT NOW IF YOU GET UP TWO OR
THREE TIMES A GAME, YOU HAVE TO
TAKE A DAY OFF.
>> IT'S ON THE GROUND, AND THIS
COULD BE TWO.
THERE IS ONE.
TURNED.
LINDOR TO BLANKENHORN.
TWO ON.
CASTRO WITH A SCORELESS EIGHTH.
>> THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING WITH
US TODAY.
ASCENDANT -- IT IS AN EXCITING
DAY FOR THE ARIZONA
DIAMONDBACKS.
RANDY JOHNSON WAS ELECTED TO THE
HALL OF FAME TODAY.
>> I WAS?
WOW!
I GOT AN AMAZING PHONE CALL.
CONGRATULATIONS, YOU HAVE BEEN
INDUCTED INTO THE HALL OF FAME.
I FELT LIKE I HAVE NEVER FELT
BEFORE IN MY LIFE.
>> EXPOS, MARINERS, ASTROS,
D-BACKS.
>> FIVE YEARS AGO, PEOPLE WERE
TALKING TO ME ABOUT IT AND I PUT
IT OFF.
I NEVER JOINED A FRATERNITY IN
COLLEGE AND NOW I'M IN ONE OF
THE COOLEST IN THE WORLD.
>> IT IS THE ULTIMATE PAT ON THE
BACK FOR HIM.
HE HAD A GREAT CAREER, AND NOW
HE IS PART OF THIS ELITE CLUB OF
AMAZING ATHLETES.
AND I THINK HE IS TOTALLY
PLEASED WITH IT.
SCOTT: YOU ARE LOCKED INTO A
GOOD ONE ON YOUTUBE.
6-6, METS AND DIAMONDBACKS.
NEXT WEEK, WE HAVE THE DODGERS
AND THE PIRATES EXCLUSIVELY ON
OUR YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
JUNE 17, THE A'S AND RANGERS,
MARINERS AND BLUE JAYS, THEN THE
REDS AND BREWERS RIGHT BEFORE
THE ALL-STAR BREAK.
THE ROOF IS CLOSED.
IT'S HOT TODAY.
THE DRY HEAT.
DO YOU LIKE THE DRY HEAT OR THE
HEAVY STUFF?
>> WELL, I GREW UP IN FLORIDA
WHERE THE HUMIDITY IS PRETTY
BAD, BUT I GREW UP HERE.
THIS IS A GREAT PLACE, YOU GET
TO DO A LOT OF ACTIVITIES
YEAR-ROUND, AND SPRING TRAINING
IS HERE, SO I CAN'T COMPLAIN.
SCOTT: THEY THOUGHT HE WOULD BE
THE CLOSER.
HE HAD AN UP-AND-DOWN BEGINNING
OF THE SEASON.
WILL TAKE OVER IN THE NINTH FOR
ARIZONA.
TIE BALLGAME.
2, 3, FOUR DUE UP FOR NEW YORK.
FRANCISCO LINDOR WILL LEAD THE
NINTH.
>> PLAYER OF THE GAME MIGHT COME
DOWN TO THE LAST COUPLE OF
PITCHES.
>> MIGHT COME BACK TO THE LAST
AT -- DOWN TO THE LAST AT-BAT.
UP THE MIDDLE, BASE HIT, AND HE
IS THINKING TWO.
AND THERE WITH A STANDUP DOUBLE
TO START THE NINTH.
>> NICE PIECE OF HITTING.
GETS ENOUGH OF IT TO HIT IT.
HE WAS THINKING DOUBLE RIGHT OUT
OF THE GATE.
SCOTT: LINDOR IS MIKED UP TODAY.
SOUNDS OF THE GAME ALL DAY LONG.
HE ADVANCES ON THE D.H..
BREAKING BALL IN THERE TO JAMES
MCCANN.
>> LINDOR IS STARTING TO HEAT UP
A LITTLE BIT.
>> THAT'S A TOUGH ERROR.
>> LINDOR ONCE THE DEVIL.
GIVE ME SOME SLUG.
>> NOT ONLY THAT, BUT HE SLID
FOR THE WALL.
MCCANN LATE.
THERE IS EDWIN DIAZ, SAVE
YESTERDAY.
THESE GUYS ARE IN THEIR
BACK-TO-BACK DAYS.
>> ESPECIALLY AS A CLOSER, I
ALWAYS WANTED TO GET BACK IN
THERE AS QUICK AS POSSIBLE.
IT LEAVES A BAD TASTE IN YOUR
MOUTH.
SCOTT: HE HAS BEEN MONEY ALL
SEASON UNTIL LAST NIGHT.
THE SLIDER WASN'T RIGHT THERE.
MCCANN OFF THE INNER PART OF THE
BAT.
MAKES THE OUT AT FIRST.
LINDOR STICKS TO SECOND.
>> THAT IS A BIG OUT TO GET A
HOT HITTER LIKE MCCANN.
STAYED ON HIM, COULDN'T GET
ANYTHING ON THE RUNNER.
SCOTT: ALONSO HAD A SINGLE IN
THE FIRST.
0-3 SINCE THEN.
THAT IS GOING TO SKIP PAST THE
CATCHER.
LINDOR TROTS TO THIRD.
ALL THE FLY BALL POWER IN THE
WORLD AND A CHANCE TO DRIVE IN
LINDOR WITH A SAC FLY EFFORT AND
A 1-0 COUNT.
>> THAT IS A BIG PASSED BALL ON
KELLY.
SCOTT: WHAT IS THE PLAN HERE,
JOHN?
JOHNNY: I WOULD THINK HE'S
THINKING ABOUT IT.
BUT PULL OUR HAS BEEN SWINGING
THE BAT GOOD.
STEVE: THEY ARE GOING TO PITCH
TO HIM, MAY VERY CAREFULLY.
SCOTT: THAT'S IN THERE.
STEVE: I GUESS NOT.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE SITTING HERE.
SCOTT: MAYBE NOT.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
TWO STRIKES AGAINST HIM.
HE MAY BE TRYING TO PITCH HIM
THE SAME WAY HE DID MCCANN, JUST
TRY TO TIE HIM UP, NOT LET HIM
GET EXTENDED.
SCOTT: THEY HAVE ARM STRENGTH AS
YOU CAN SEE.
CASTRO NOT AS BIG OF AN ARM OUT
THERE.
SEE IF ALONSO CAN LIFT ONE ON
THE 1-2, IT'S ON THE GROUND, IT
GETS THROUGH, AND THE METS TAKE
THE LEAD.
R.B.I. HIT FOR PETE ALONSO.
IT IS 7-6 IN THE NINTH.
>> THAT IS A CHANGEUP.
>> ALMOST HIT IT OFF THE GROUND.
>> HE JUST GOT ENOUGH OF IT AND
HE KNEW IT RIGHT AWAY.
SEE THE REACTION.
SCOTT: LOW-BALL HITTER, PETE
ALONSO WITH A BIG R.B.I..
>> HOW BIG IS HE FOR THIS TEAM?
WAXY IS A PRESENCE.
>> HE IS HUGE FOR THIS BALLCLUB.
HE BRINGS A DIFFERENT ENERGY
LEVEL EACH AND EVERY DAY TO THIS
TEAM.
HE DID IN HIS FIRST NIGHT OUT IN
THE SERIES AND HE HAS DONE IT
AGAIN HERE TO GET THE BIG HIT.
SCOTT: HIGH FLY BALL, SHALLOW
CENTER, AND MARCUS RETIRES
PILLAR.
>> CROSSED UP THERE, FASTBALL
DOWN, FAST BALL, CHANGE IT.
GOOD PIECE OF HITTING.
>> NOT ONLY THAT, I THINK PETE
KNEW, MAN ON THIRD, I'VE GOT TO
PUT THE BALL IN PLAY, SHORTEN
UP, NOT LOOKING TO DRIVE ONE OUT
OF THE PARK UNLESS HE MAKES A
MISTAKE, AND HE DID.
IT WAS A CHANGEUP DOWN, WHICH IS
A GOOD PITCH FOR THE PITCHER,
BUT HE WAS ABLE TO GET THE
BARREL TO IT.
SCOTT: THERE WAS A LOT OF
COMMOTION.
IT'S PETE ALONSO, OPEN BASE,
DOUBLE PLAY.
DOM SMITH.
>> I THINK HE MIGHT BE
SECOND-GUESSING HIMSELF ON THAT
LAST PLAY LIKE YOU GUYS SAID.
SCOTT: WHY NOT A SMILE?
HE HAS REACHED FOUR TIMES.
THREE SINGLES AND A WALK.
HE IS IN ONE OF THOSE GROUPS
NOW.
FISH GROOVES -- IN ONE OF THOSE
GROOVES NOW.
>> EARLIER, GUYS WERE STRUGGLING
TO SCORE RUNS.
NOW THEY ARE STRUGGLING TO SWING
THE BAT.
SCOTT: I DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE --
>> THE WEATHER IS STARTING TO
HEAT UP.
SCOTT: IF GUYS COME OFF THE
INJURED LIST AS PLANNED, I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU EVEN HAVE TO LOOK
INTO MANY TRADES.
SO MANY PLAYERS ARE GOING TO BE
A BOOST OF ENERGY.
J.D. DAVIS, HOPEFULLY NOAH
SYNDERGAARD IF HE COMES BACK
FROM HIS ELBOW SETBACK.
CARLOS CARRASCO.
THAT IS A BULK.
-- BALK.
ALONSO, MOVE UP.
>> THAT'S A MISCOMMUNICATION
RIGHT THERE.
>> THIS HAS BEEN SOMETHING THAT
HAS KIND OF HAPPENED TO THE
D-BACKS ALL LAST MONTH.
LITTLE MISTAKES LIKE THIS, NOT
ABLE TO MAKE PITCHES OR GET
HITS.
WILD PITCH IS LIKE WE SAW
EARLIER, GET THE RUNNER TO
THIRD.
SCOTT: AND HE PUTS AWAY SMITH.
SO THAT DOESN'T BITE HIM BUT THE
R.B.I. HIT FOR ALONSO DOES.
LINDOR MOVES OVER ON THE WILD
PITCH CREATING ACTION ON THE
BASE PADS.
SPEEDS HOME ON THE R.B.I.
SINGLE.
T'S HAVE THE LEAD.
EDWIN DIAZ TIME AGAINST 7, 8, 9,
COMING UP.
>> THE CLICHÉ AROUND THE METS IN
1998 WAS THAT THE METS WERE A
NICE LITTLE TEAM.
>> AND THE SUBTLE TEAM.
>> A GOOD LITTLE TEAM ON THE
RISE.
>> BUT THEY DIDN'T HAVE THAT SET
PIECE, A ROCK STAR, A SUPERHERO.
>> NOT A STAR, A SUPERSTAR.
>> WE ARE ECSTATIC TO MAKE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT THE NEW YORK
METS HAVE ACQUIRED MIKE PIAZZA.
>> GET OFF THE PLANE AT
LAGUARDIA, THERE ARE FANS,
PEOPLE CHEERING.
>> LINE DRIVE BASE HIT, AND
FRANCO IS SAFE AT THE PLATE.
>> I AM TOTALLY IN A DAZE.
>> TRY TO FOCUS ON THE MIDDLE
PART OF THE BASE.
SCOTT: FRANCISCO LINDOR, A
PERSONALITY BUILT FOR NEW YORK
CITY.
>> MIDDLE PART OF THE BASEBALL,
THAT'S WHAT HE ALWAYS KEEPS
SAYING.
SCOTT: EDWIN DIAZ TO TRY TO SHUT
THINGS DOWN IN THE NINTH FOR NEW
YORK.
TOP OF THE INNING.
IT STARTS WITH VARGAS AND THAT
PITCH AWAY FROM DIAZ.
ALSO, JOSH ROJAS ON DECK CAME UP
BIG WITH TWO OUTS IN THE NINTH
YESTERDAY.
HERE'S A STRIKEOUT, 100 FOR
DIAZ, BLEW HIS FIRST SAVE OF THE
SEASON LAST NIGHT.
EVEN TO THE SCORE IN THE NINTH
YESTERDAY IN THE D-BACKS WENT ON
TO WIN IT 6-5 IN EXTRAS.
>> HE IS SO DIFFERENT THIS YEAR,
JUST HIS DEMEANOR ON THE MOUND,
THE WAY HE CARRIES HIMSELF.
HE'S A LITTLE ERRATIC, A LITTLE
WILD.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
HE LOOKS LIKE HE HAS A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE GOING.
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF DOUBT IN
DIAZ'S MIND.
THE STORY FOR DIAZ IS THE HOME
RUN PREVENTION THAT HAS CHANGED
SIGNIFICANTLY.
GIVE UP 15 HOME RUNS LAST YEAR,
NONE SO FAR THIS YEAR.
A BALL AND TWO STRIKES.
NOW 2-2.
I MEAN, THE E.R.A. LAST YEAR --
MAKE THAT 2019 -- WAS 2.50.
A FEW BAD OUTINGS LAST YEAR, BUT
MOSTLY A BIG IMPROVEMENT.
HE HAS REALLY PUT IT TOGETHER SO
FAR THIS YEAR.
>> AGAIN, COMING TO THE BIG
STAGE FROM SEATTLE TO NEW YORK.
AND HE GOT HURT.
SCOTT: FASTBALL OR SLIDER HERE?
>> I AM GOING TO SAY SLIDER.
THAT IS HIS OUT PITCH.
SCOTT: IT'S LINDOR.
SCOTT: JOHNNY, I KNOW YOU HAVE
SEEN SOME SHIFTS, BUT WERE GUYS
STANDING THERE WHEN YOU ARE
PITCHING?
>> NO.
>> IF LINDOR WAS STILL PLAYING
REGULAR, HE MIGHT HAVE MADE THAT
PLAY.
SCOTT: DIAZ WOULD LOVE SOME
REVENGE AGAINST JOSH ROJAS WHO
SINGLED TO TIE THE NINTH.
STARTS HIM OFF WITH 101 MILES
PER HOUR.
>> 101 RUNNING AWAY FROM ROJAS.
ROJAS TRYING TO GET THAT FIRST
PITCH, TRYING TO AMBUSH HIM.
>> WITH DIAZ'S ARM ANGLE, TOO.
SCOTT: SAME SPOT.
LAST NIGHT, ROJAS, TWO OUTS IN
THE NINTH, AND A FRESH BALLGAME.
IT JUST TOOK ONE FOR THE
DIAMONDBACKS TO WIN IT.
ROJAS PROVIDING THE BOOST FOR
ARIZONA.
HERE HE IS AS A PINCH HITTER.
AND HE WAS THE BRIGHT SPOT IN
THE MONTH OF MAY.
ROJAS WITH A REALLY SLOW START
TO HIS SEASON, ENDED UP ON THE
BENCH.
INJURIES PUT HIM BACK INTO THE
LINEUP.
HE WAS THEIR BEST HITTER THAT
MONTH.
>> HE EVEN SAID THE FIRST MONTH
OF THE SEASON HE WAS TRYING TO
DO TOO MUCH.
HE GOT INTO THAT MOMENT WHERE HE
WAS HAPPY TO BE THE GUY THAT
CARRIED THE CLUB.
NOW HE IS JUST KIND OF SETTLING
BACK IN.
HE KNOWS HE IS GOING TO BE OUT
THERE PLAYING.
>> TWO MORE LEFTIES AVAILABLE
OFF THE BENCH INCLUDING DAVID
PERALTA, AND HE STRUCK HIM OUT.
101, HE CLIMBS THE LADDER, TWO
GONE IN THE NINTH.
>> GOOD RUN ON THAT FASTBALL,
TAILING AWAY.
ONE THING HE HAS BEEN DOING THIS
YEAR ALSO, HITTING THE FASTBALL
UP IN THE ZONE, NORTH AND SOUTH,
NORTH AND SOUTH, MOSTLY NORTH IN
THE ZONE.
SCOTT: COME IN AND CHANNEL YOUR
INNER FRANCO.
SPINNER, LEFT SIDE, DOM SMITH IS
THERE, GAME OVER.
METS TAKE IT 7-6, AND THEY
IMPROVED TO 27-21 ON THE SEASON.
FRANCISCO LINDOR SCORES THE
WINNING RUN, BROUGHT IN BY PETE
ALONSO.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY KNOWS HOW
TO LINE UP A GAME LIKE THIS
PREDICTION-WISE.
WE HAD 10 RUNS IN THE FIRST TWO
INNINGS.
THE METS GET THE CLUTCH HIT THEY
NEED.
DIAZ SHUTS THE DOOR.
10 SAVE OF THE SEASON FOR EDWIN.
LET'S TALK THROUGH THIS THING
FOR 30 MINUTES LIVE ON YOUTUBE
RIGHT NOW.
METS TAKE IT 7-6, YOUR FINAL
SCORE.
WE ARE STATIONED AT THE
BALLPARK.
THE METS GRABBED THE SERIES.
2-3 AGAINST ARIZONA.
THE STREAK STRETCHES BACK TO A
FEW YEARS AGO.
PETE ALONSO COMING THROUGH.
HE IS GOING TO JOIN US FOR A
POST GAME CHAT IN JUST A MOMENT.
YOU GUYS KNOW WHAT TO DO.
IF YOU ARE WATCHING ON YOUR
PHONE OR COMPUTER, THE PULL OF
THE GAME IS LIVE RIGHT NOW FOR
YOU TO SELECT THE WINNER.
IF HE GETS THE TROPHY, WE WILL
LET YOU KNOW.
EDWIN DIAZ DOES HIS JOB IN THE
NINTH.
>> WHAT IS HE, NINE OUT OF 10,
10 OUT OF 11?
IT WAS A DIFFERENT YEAR FOR HIM,
VERY CONFIDENT.
HE IS A GUY YOU RELY ON IN THE
GAME.
>> I AM GLAD I AM SITTING UP
HERE AND NOT DOWN THERE.
I USED TO HATE FACING A GUY LIKE
FRANCO LATE IN THE GAME.
THEY ARE STARTING TO GET PLAYERS
HEALTHY AGAIN.
ALONSO IS HUGE TO COME BACK IN
THIS SERIES.
THEY ARE FEELING PRETTY GOOD
ABOUT TODAY'S GAME.
SCOTT: 7-6 YOUR FINAL SCORE.
THIS IS A TEAM THAT HAS
PERSEVERED ALL YEAR LONG WITH
PLAYERS ON THE SHELF, 13 SO FAR.
JONATHAN VILLAR WITH A HAMSTRING
ISSUE.
MAKE IT 14.
WE WILL GET MORE DETAILS POST
GAME FROM ROJAS.
HE HAD TO LEAVE THE GAME TODAY
FOR NEW YORK.
>> HE IS A CATALYST AT THE TOP
OF THE LINEUP.
HE HAS BEEN DOING REALLY WELL
SINCE HE IS IN THERE.
SCOTT: NICE TO HAVE ALONSO BACK
IN THE LINEUP FOR NEW YORK.
METS WONDERING IF THEY WOULD
HAVE ALONSO AT THE PLATE IN THAT
SITUATION.
IT WAS A CHANCE, POTENTIALLY,
FOR SOME MANAGERS TO SAY LET'S
SET UP THE DOUBLE PLAY, LET'S
ALSO NOT DEAL WITH THE METS MOST
PRODUCTIVE RUN PRODUCER.
>> THAT'S A CHANCE YOU TAKE AS A
MANAGER, COIN FLIP.
HE TOOK A CHANCE.
HE BELIEVED IN HIS PITCHER.
IT WAS A GOOD PITCH.
YOU HAVE TO TIP YOUR HAT TO
PETE.
SCOTT: METS TAKE IT SEVEN-SIX,
YOUR FINAL SCORE.
WE SAW THREE RUN HOME RUN FROM
THE CANON THE FIRST INNING.
NO RE--- FROM MCCANN IN THE
FIRST INNING.
WE WILL GO OVER THE PLAYER OF
THE GAME RESULTS IN JUST A FEW
MOMENTS.
AND HERE HE IS, PETE ALONSO
JOINING US WITH A BIG HIT IN THE
NINTH.
GREAT TO TALK TO YOU.
DID YOU CONSIDER THE FACT THAT
MAYBE THEY WOULD GIVE YOU A FREE
PASS TO FIRST?
>> I HAVE TO BE READY TO GO.
I CAN'T JUST ASSUME THEY ARE
GOING TO WALK IN THERE.
I DIDN'T THINK THEY WERE GOING
TO WALK ME.
MAYBE WITH A LEFTY ON THE MOUND,
BUT I THINK THEY WERE PLAYING
RIGHT ON RIGHT, TRYING TO GET ME
TO HIT A POP-UP OR STRIKE ME
OUT.
>> HEY PETE, I HAVE BEEN TELLING
THIS GUY, I CALLED YOUR NAME OUT
IN THE DRAFT YEARS AGO, SO I
HAVE A LOT OF CONFIDENCE IN YOU.
SINCE YOU'VE COME BACK, YOU ARE
FEELING REALLY WELL, NO
LINGERING EFFECTS.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING DAY TODAY --
DAY TO DAY?
>> I AM JUST HAPPY THAT I WAS
ABLE TO RECOVER AND THAT MY BODY
RESPONDED WELL TO THE REST AND
THE REHAB.
I AM GLAD TO BE JOINING THE
PARTY AGAIN.
I AM REALLY HAPPY I CAN IMPACT
THE GAME I HAVE THIS SERIES.
>> LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION.
IN THE OFF-SEASON, YOU HAD A
GREAT ROOKIE SEASON, SHORT
SEASON.
WHAT WAS YOUR MINDSET GOING INTO
SPRING TRAINING KNOWING THAT
YOUR OWNER WENT OUT AND GOT ALL
OF THESE GUYS?
>> FROM ONE TAMPA GUY TO
ANOTHER, I WAS REALLY EXCITED.
I DIDN'T KNOW YOU WERE CALLING
THE GAME.
THAT'S REALLY EXCITING.
I GOT A REPRESENT IN THE 813,
HELL YEAH.
I WAS REALLY EXCITED.
ALL THE ACQUISITIONS AND MOVES.
IT WAS REALLY EXCITING THIS
OFF-SEASON BECAUSE WE HAVE A
REALLY STRONG CORE, GOOD
CHEMISTRY, AND THEN EVERYONE WHO
WAS BROUGHT IN, THE GELLING AND
THE CAMARADERIE STARTED FROM DAY
ONE.
ALL THE PIECES THE FRONT OFFICE
GOT REALLY FIT THE GROOVE.
IT'S AWESOME.
SCOTT: WAS HE ONE OF YOUR
FAVORITES GROWING UP?
>> SO YEAH.
I LOVE THE HOMETOWN GUYS.
SCOTT: ALRIGHT, I HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS FROM OUR CREATORS IN
THE LIVE CHAT.
WHAT HAS BEEN THE KEY TO THE
OFFENSIVE SURGE FOR THIS TEAM?
FIRST, SOME MORE DETAIL, LINDOR
WITH A SCORCHING BAT LATELY.
JAMES MCCANN TURNING IT UP.
DOM SMITH HAVING A BIG WEEK.
WHAT HAS CHANGED?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
BASEBALL IS A LONG SEASON.
IT IS A GAME OF FAILURE.
AND IT IS A MARATHON, NOT A
SPRINT.
BASEBALL IS MEANT TO BE PLAYED
160 TWO GAMES.
THE LAW OF AVERAGES KIND OF
PLAYS OUT.
YOU CAN HAVE A WEEK WHERE YOU
ARE SMASHING BALLS OF PEOPLE YOU
CAN GET A COUPLE OF BLOOPERS.
THIS GROUP'S PREPARATION AND
MENTALITY HAS BEEN A ONE FROM
THE JUMP.
I AM REALLY EXCITED THAT WE ARE
PUTTING UP RUNS.
WE HAVE THAT GRITTY, NASTY
MENTALITY THAT WE ARE GOING TO
WIN REGARDLESS.
IT IS PARTLY CAMARADERIE THAT WE
HAVE AS WELL THAT EVERYTHING IS
GOING TO COME TOGETHER NICELY,
GET SOME GUYS OFF THE D.L. AND
BE FIRING AT FULL CAPACITY.
I AM EXCITED FOR HOW WE ARE
GOING TO BE MIDDLE TO THE END OF
THE SUMMER.
SCOTT: TAKE ME THROUGH YOUR
PREPARATION.
WHAT IS YOUR PREPARATION RIGHT
-- LIKE?
DO YOU GET THE SCOUTING REPORT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
HE KINDA OF FLIPPED THE SCRIPT
ON ME.
HIS PITCH IS UP IN THE ZONE IN A
WAY.
I AM JUST HAPPY HE MADE A
MISTAKE.
AND GAVE ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DRIVE IN THE WINNING RUN.
SCOTT: CONGRATS ON THE W-4 YOUR
SQUAD.
SAFE TRAVELS.
ENJOY SAN DIEGO COMING UP.
>> WILL DO.
LF G.M., THANKS GUYS.
SCOTT: I'M GOING -- IF YOU WANT
TO LOOK UP THAT HASHTAG, GO FOR
IT.
GOOGLE IT.
FIRST INNING, A THREE RUN SMASH,
AND THEN A COUPLE MORE HITS
AFTER THAT MCCANN DROVE IN FOUR
FOR NEW YORK.
AND A BIG SMILE ON HIS FACE.
THE CATCHER WITH A SLOW START TO
THE SEASON.
HE HAS BEEN PICKING THINGS UP.
ALONSO IN THE FIRST SPOT, AND
SMITH FINISHES IN FOURTH.
THE FANS DECIDED, AND JAMES
MCCANN GETS A SPECIAL,
CUSTOM-MADE YOUTUBE TROPHY WITH
HIS NAME ON IT.
THERE WILL BE ON
HIS FACE AFTER THAT AND A HAPPY
FLIGHT FOR THE NEW YORK VETS AS
THEY LEAVE THE DESERT.
MUCH MORE TO GO ON THE POST GAME
SHOW ON YOUTUBE.
♪
[CAPTIONS MADE POSSIBLE BY MLB
NETWORK]
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO.
>> THAT ONE IS CRUSHED.
>> THAT'S GOING TO DO IT.
>> OH MY, STRIKE THREE.
>> HE TALKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS.
THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
QUICK SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS
WHAT THEY CAME FOR.
>> A GREAT ONE ON YOUTUBE TODAY.
LET'S GET INTO THE HIGHLIGHTS
FROM THIS GAME.
HIS BAT HAS LIT UP, SPEED ON THE
BASES AND DEEP TO LEFT FIELD,
FORGET ABOUT IT.
JAMES MCCANN MUSCLES UP FOR HIS
FOURTH HOME RUN OF THE SEASON
AND THE METS GRABBED A 3-0 LEAD.
>> THE FIRST THREE BATTERS, TOO
MUCH AT THE PLATE.
THE BALL IS JUST LABORING RIGHT
OVER THE PLATE.
>> THAT IS A NICE PIECE OF
HITTING BY MCCANN.
HE GETS A GOOD PITCH RIGHT DOWN
THE HEART OF THE PLATE.
>> JOC PEDERSON RUN -- WORKING
WITH A COMFY LEAD BEFORE HE
STARTS HIS DAY.
>> HE'S GOT HIMSELF A TWO RUN
SHOT.
MARTE POWERS UP FOR HIS FOURTH
OF THE YEAR, IT'S 4-2.
I'M STARTING TO WORRY ABOUT THE
OVER-UNDER CALL.
WE ARE NOT EVEN OUT OF THE FIRST
INNING.
WE'VE GOT SIX RUNS ALREADY
SCORED.
NOBODY OUT IN THE BOTTOM OF THE
FIRST.
>> A SINGLE AND A TWO-RUN HOME
RUN ON THE DIAMONDBACKS SIDE OF
THE INNING.
IT'S GOING TO SCORE TWO FOR THE
DIAMONDBACKS.
WE ARE TIED IN THE FIRST.
VARGAS JUST TRADED FOR THIS
AFTERNOON.
HE'S BACK WITH THE DIAMONDBACKS
AND WE HAVE A FRESH BALLGAME IN
THE OPENING INNING.
REMEMBER WHEN MADISON BUMGARNER
WAS PITCHING IN THE FIRST?
NOW HE'S AT THE PLATE.
>> SOLID CONTACT INTO LEFT.
D-BACKS JUMP AHEAD.
5-4, R.B.I. SINGLE FROM THE
PITCHER SPOT IN THE FIRST.
ARIZONA HAS CLIMBED ALL THE WAY
BACK.
>> TO SAY THIS IS A CRAZY GAME
ALREADY IS AN UNDERSTATEMENT, I
WOULD IMAGINE.
MCCANN UP THE MIDDLE, SOLIDLY
STRUCK, AND HERE COMES VILLAR
ROUNDING THIRD, HE WILL SCORE
EASILY.
AND R.B.I. SINGLE FROM JAMES
MCCANN TO TIE THE GAME UP.
HIS FOURTH R.B.I., WE ARE IN THE
SECOND.
DRURY CLOCKS IT OVER SHORT AND
HE'S GOT HIMSELF A KNOCK.
HERE COMES PILLAR IN THE METS
TAKE  THE LEAD BACK,6-5.
>> THAT'S GOT TO FEEL GOOD FOR
DRURY, TO COME UP AND GET A HIT
AGAINST HIS FORMER TEAM THE
DIAMONDBACKS.
>> VARGAS MAKES CONTACT, LEFT
SIDE.
THAT'S GOING TO BRING IN THE
RUN.
PERAZA HAS TO EAT THE BASEBALL.
AN INFIELD KNOCK FROM VARGAS.
VARGAS HAS HAD AN IMPACT IN THIS
GAME HIS FIRST DAY BACK.
FROM THE TRADE THIS MORNING,
DRIVEN IN THREE RUNS ALREADY.
JUST MAKE CONTACT, CONTACT UP
THE LINE, JUST ENOUGH TIME FOR
THE RUN TO SCORE.
>> THAT WAS THE LAST WE SAW FROM
THE DIAMONDBACKS OFFENSE.
THERE GOES FRANCISCO LINDOR WITH
A SINGLE.
AN ERROR CHARGE AGAINST KETEL
MARTE, FUMBLED THE BASEBALL A
LITTLE BIT.
A WILD PITCH SUDDENLY YOU HAVE A
RUNNER 90 FEET AWAY FROM
BREAKING UP THE TIE IN THE
NIGHT.
THAT'S WHEN PETE ALONSO DID HIS
R.B.I. THING.
>> YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT COULD
HAPPEN, BRING HIM IN.
>> A PITCH PRETTY LOW THAT HE
CONNECTS ON, DRIVES IT INTO LEFT
PAST THE INFIELD.
DOM SMITH WITH THE SQUEEZE AND
THE METS WITH A W.
THEY ARE 27-21 ON THE SEASON.
FIRST PLACE IN THE NL
-- 16 HITS TODAY, ONLY TWO THE
VARIETY.
A LITTLE MORE OLD-FASHIONED
BASEBALL.
>> A LITTLE HERE, THERE,
POP-UPS, DOUBLE PLAY, A LITTLE
OF EVERYTHING.
AND A HOME RUN.
>> STATE FARM GAME SUMMARY, METS
GOT THREE HITS FROM LINDOR,
MCCANN, ALONZO  --ALONSO.
7-6, YOUR FINAL IN THE DESERT.
STEVE?
STEVE: BIG WIN FOR THE METS,
THAT GIVES THEM 2-3 IN THIS
SERIES, THE BEGINNING OF A LONG
NINE-GAME TRIP.
THEY HAVE NINE GAMES AGAINST THE
PADRES.
THAT WILL BE TOUGH FOR THEM AT
PETCO BEFORE THEY CLOSE IT UP
WITH A COUPLE GAMES AGAINST THE
ORIOLES IN BALTIMORE.
TO WIN A SERIES, ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU LOSE A 4-0 LEAD, THAT WILL
MAKE FOR A HAPPY FLIGHT TO SAN
DIEGO.
ON THE FLIPSIDE, YOU HAVE THE
DIAMONDBACKS.
THEY HAVE A LONGER FLIGHT TO
MILWAUKEE AND THAT WILL NOT BE
QUITE AS ENJOYABLE.
A TOUGH NIGHT FOR THEM.
MADISON BUMGARNER DID NOT HAVE
HIS STUFF TODAY.
THE STRUGGLES FOR THEM CONTINUE.
THEY HAVE WON 2-3 TODAY, BUT
FIND THEMSELVES ON THE WRONG
SIDE OF THINGS IN THIS ONE.
SCOTT: STEVE, THANK YOU.
GREAT STUFF TODAY.
WE ARE ALL JEALOUS.
ENJOY THAT IN ARIZONA.
ALWAYS GORGEOUS.
HOT, THEY CLOSE
THE ROOF IN ARIZONA.
MORE FROM THE POSTGAME SHOW,
INCLUDING MIC'ED UP PLAYERS,
NEXT.
>> WE ARE GOING TO CALL THAT NOT
A FAIR BALL, BUT A FAIR BAT.
>> A SWING AND A HIGH POP-UP.
>> TRYING TO PICK IT OUT OF THE
DOME.
THEY SOMEHOW MADE THE CATCH.
>> FIRST-PLACE UMPIRE SAYS YES,
WITHIN RANGE.
WHAT A JOB BY SEAN MURPHY, AND
ALL FOR NOTHING.
>> COMING UP ON CAMERA, SAW THE
TOWEL WAS GONE, AND A TOWEL IS
OFF.
STILL STARING AT THE CAMERA.
HE WANTS TO GO HIGH.
WATCH.
>> RIZZO VERSUS FREEMAN.
>> HE WANTS TO PUNCH HIM OUT SO
BAD.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I HAD TO TURN.
SCOTT: BACK IN ARIZONA METS TAKE
IT 7-6.
IT IS THE POSTGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
WE DID RECEIVE NEWS ON THE
ARIZONA SIDE THAT MADISON
BUMGARNER LEFT THE GAME WITH
LEFT SHOULDER DISCOMFORT.
HE IS GOING TO HAVE AN MRI
TONIGHT.
WE WILL GET TO THAT IN THE
SECOND.
WE HAD MIC'ED UP PLAYERS.
EDUARDO ESCOBAR.
IT SOUNDED LIKE THIS.
>> A BEAUTIFUL DAY TO PLAY
BASEBALL.
HOW YOU DOING, MAN?
NICE SHIFTED TODAY.
>> I HAVE THE MIC, BOYS.
>> SAY HELLO TO EVERYBODY.
1, 2, 3, CHECK, CHECK.
YOU SEE ME?
I GOT THE MIC TODAY, I GOT THE
MIC.
>> WE ARE COMING TO SAN DIEGO.
WHAT HAPPENED?
WATCH OUT.
OH TO THE RIGHT SIDE.
-- GO TO THE RIGHT SIDE.
SLICK.
>> LET IT GO.
MAY IS IN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> HEY, YOU ARE MAKING THAT BALL
BOUNCE.
>> THAT IS A LONG SINGLE.
>> I COULD HAVE DONE THAT.
THAT IS A LONG SINGLE.
>> SAFE!
SAFE!
>> ARE YOU A JORDAN GUY?
YOU LIKE THE SHOES?
>> I LIKE THE SHOES.
I LOVE THE JORDANS, MAN.
>> I THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO
REPEAT HISTORY, BASIC, BASIC,
HOME RUN.
>> GOOD INNING, FELLAS, GOOD
INNING.
STAY UP.
>> NEW PITCHER, TIME TO GET ON
HIM.
>> NICE PLAY.
>> PLAY BASKETBALL.
ONE BASE AND NOW YOU ARE A BASE
STEALER?
SCOTT: I KNOW YOU KNEW LINDOR
CAN TALK.
HE IS FUN AND ALSO A COACH OUT
THERE.
LOOK AT HIS SPLITS.
HE CRUSHES DIAMONDBACKS PITCHING
SO FAR THIS YEAR.
NOT SO MUCH AGAINST THE REST,
MAYBE IT IS A BOOST.
I THINK EDUARDO ESCOBAR SURPRISE
YOU.
JOHN: ANOTHER GUY WHO LOVES THE
GAME, LOVES TO HAVE FUN WHEN HE
IS OUT THERE.
THEY ARE A PLEASURE TO WATCH AND
SO MUCH OF A POSITIVE VIBE FOR
THE GAME OF BASEBALL.
SCOTT: SO MUCH FUN TO LISTEN TO,
FRANCISCO LINDOR AND EDUARDO
ESCOBAR, MIC'ED UP FOR THIS
GAME.
MADISON BUMGARNER ONLY LASTED A
COUPLE INNINGS.
WE THOUGHT MAYBE AFTER THE ROUGH
FIRST INNING HE WOULD GO 5, 6
INNINGS.
WE SAW THEM DO THAT BEFORE AND
HIS TEAM PLAYED CATCH UP.
HE LEFT THE GAME WITH LEFT
SHOULDER DISCOMFORT.
HE WILL HAVE AN MRI TONIGHT,
ACCORDING TO HIS MANAGER.
THAT IS TOUGH NEWS FOR THE
DIAMONDBACKS.
>> WE SAW THAT.
JOHNNY POINTED OUT, HE WAS NOT
HITTING HIS SPOTS.
THE VELOCITY WAS WHAT HE
NORMALLY THROWS, BUT WAS NOT
ABLE TO HIT HIS SPOTS.
ANOTHER NOTCH TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS WITH MADISON BUMGARNER.
LET'S HOPE IT IS NOT A SERIOUS
INJURY.
SCOTT: FOR THE METS, VILLAR GOES
DOWN WITH A HAMSTRING ISSUE.
ALONSO COMES BACK ON MONDAY.
SETH LUGO, ANOTHER RELIEF ACE
FOR THE TEAM.
THEY ARE STARTING TO GET
HEALTHIER AND HAVE BEEN FINE
WITH THE SUBS, WITH THE BENCH
MOB.
>> LIKE I SAID EARLIER, YOU NEED
THESE PLAYERS TO COME IN AND A
STEP UP WHILE REGULAR PLAYERS
ARE HURT, AND GETTING BACK THE
TRADE DEADLINE COMING, CONFORTO
IS GETTING A TRADE BACK.
THE CAVALRY IS COMING.
THESE GUYS HAVE DONE A GREAT
JOB, EVERYONE OF THEM, WHOEVER
CAME IN TO HELP OUT, THEY ARE
DOING A TREMENDOUS JOB.
SCOTT: THE STILL IN'S ARE DOING
NICE -- THE FILL-INS ARE DOING
NICELY.
WHAT HAS BEEN THE KEY TO THE
OFFENSIVE SURGE FOR THE METS?
I ASKED THAT QUESTION TO KELLY
-- I ASKED THAT QUESTION TO PETE
ALONSO.
WHERE IS IT FROM LINDOR?
WHERE IS IT FROM JAMES MCCANN?
WHERE IS THE OFFENSE FROM DOM
SMITH?
IT IS LIKE THEY ALL WOKE UP AT
THE SAME TIME.
JOHN: A COUPLE THINGS.
WARM WEATHER.
THEY ARE SUCH GOOD PLAYERS, IT
IS A MATTER OF TIME BEFORE THEY
START COMING AROUND.
LIKE PETE SAID, IT IS A LONG
SEASON.
THERE WILL BE WEEKS WHERE YOU
GET LINE DRIVES AND WEEKS WITH
BROKEN BAT SINGLES.
IT EVENS OUT IN AN 160 GAME
SEASON.
SCOTT: YOU SEE A METS TEAM
PRIDING ITSELF ON PITCHING AND
DEFENSE AND THE DEFENSE STARTED
TO COME AROUND WITH ARIZONA WITH
MANY MORE REINFORCEMENTS ON THE
WAY.
>> I THINK WHAT YOU WILL SEE
WITH THE METS, LUIS ROJAS HAS
HIS CORE GUYS WITH PETE ALONSO,
LINDOR.
NOW THEY ARE GETTING HEALTHY,
FEELING GOOD ABOUT THEMSELVES.
WHEN THEY ANSWER THE BELL EACH
AND EVERY DAY, GET A STEADY
LINEUP, YOU WILL SEE THE OFFENSE
PICK UP MORE.
SCOTT: YOU CAN SEE THEY WON SIX
OF THEIR LAST SEVEN, AVERAGING
5.5 RUNS PER GAME.
THERE IS A POWER SURGE AS WELL.
A TON OF SAN DIEGO PADRES GAMES
COMING UP FOR THE METS.
SEVEN OF THEIR NEXT NINE ARE
AGAINST SAN DIEGO.
JOHN: A BIG SERIES.
SCOTT: NEXT WEEK DODGERS TAKING
ON THE PIRATES.
THE DEFENDING CHAMPS ARE ON
YOUTUBE.
AND SHOHEI OHTANI AND ANGELS,
USING GREAT.
MARINERS MATCH UP THE BLUE JAYS
AND VLADIMIR GUERRERO JR. ON
JUNE 30.
THE REDS TAKE ON THE MILWAUKEE
BREWERS.
THAT IS YOUR EXCLUSIVE.
NEXT, THE DODGERS AND THE
PIRATES.
YOU GET TO SEE THIS TOO MUCH,
BEING THAT YOU WORK WITH THE
DIAMONDBACKS.
WHAT DO THE DODGERS LOOK LIKE
THIS YEAR, TREVOR BAUER ADDED TO
THE MIX.
THE DODGERS HAVE HAD INJURIES
THEY HAVE DEALT WITH.
WHEN YOU GET TO THE END OF THE
SEASON, WHEN YOU HAVE THE
STARTING ROTATION INTACT, I AM
LOOKING AT KERSHAW, BUEHLER,
BAUER, OTHER NAMES THAT IF THEY
COME BACK LOOK LIKE TOP OF THE
ROTATION GUYS.
>> I THINK THIS YEAR COMING OUT
AFTER THE WORLD SERIES THEY WERE
EXPECTING TO BE IN FIRST PLACE,
THE SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS
SURPRISED EVERYBODY.
I THINK THE GIANTS ARE GOING TO
FADE, THE PADRES ARE RIGHT
THERE, BUT THE DODGERS WITH THE
PITCHING STAFF THEY HAVE, THEY
WILL BE IN THE MIX AND LOOKING
FOR OFFENSIVE GUYS TO GET HOT.
THEY JUST GOT BELLINGER BACK AND
SOME OF THEIR KEY OFFENSIVE
PLAYERS.
SCOTT: I THINK OF LINDOR IN
COMPARISON TO MOOKIE BETTS AND
THAT HE MOVES OVER TO THE TEAM,
GETS TRADED, SIGNS THE BIG
CONTRACT.
HE CAN CONTRIBUTE IN A NUMBER OF
WAYS.
BETTS IS LIKE THAT.
YOU CAN SEE HIM CONTRIBUTE IN A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT WAYS.
YOU WILL SEE BETTS AND THE
DODGERS.
WE DON'T KNOW THE PROBABLES THAT
FAR IN ADVANCE.
CHANCES ARE YOU WILL GET A GUY
WHO IS A CY YOUNG CONTENDER.
>> ANY TIME YOU FACE THE
DODGERS, YOU HAVE YOUR WORK CUT
OUT FOR YOU.
SCOTT: THE DODGERS TAKING ON THE
PIRATES NEXT WEEK.
IT WAS GREAT TO HAVE YOU BACK ON
A METS BROADCAST.
>> THANK YOU, I ENJOYED CATCHING
UP WITH YOU, SEEING MY OLD BUDDY
IN ARIZONA.
IT WAS A GREAT DAY.
SCOTT: 15 SEASONS WITH THE NEW
YORK METS.
LOUIS, IT WAS AWESOME, GREAT TO
HAVE YOU ON BOARD.
YOU MATCHED UP IN 1999.
TO HAVE TWO GUYS WHO ARE VALUED
AND CHERISHED WAS SPECIAL FOR US
ON THE YOUTUBE SIDE.
YOU DID A GREAT JOB FROM
ARIZONA.
WE FELT WE WERE ALL TOGETHER.
>> WE SURE DID.
>> APPRECIATE IT.
SCOTT: THANK YOU TO LUIS
GONZALEZ, DON FRANCO, STEVE
GILBERT.
WE WILL DO THIS AGAIN NEXT WEEK
ON YOUTUBE WITH THE PIRATES
HOSTING THE LOS ANGELES DODGERS
ON JUNE 10, THURSDAY.
COVERAGE STARTS AT NOON EASTERN
WITH OUR PREGAME SHOW ON MLB'S
YOUTUBE SHOW.
OVER 3 MILLION SUBSCRIBERS.
WE WILL SEE YOU THEN.
FROM OUR CREW, I AM SCOTT BRAUN,
LOGGING OUT.
WE WILL BE HERE NEXT WEEK FOR
BASEBALL ON YOUTUBE.
METS WIN, 7-6.